WELCOME.
TO THIS OVERSIGHT HEARING OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE.
THIS MORNING WE'LL BE DISCUSSING
THE FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
IDENTIFIED BY OUR STATE AUDITOR
AND IN OUR REPORT RELEASED THIS
APRIL.
TITLED THE COMMUNITY.
CHILD CARE COUNCIL OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY --
WHICH THINK A SENATOR.
BELL WHO I KNOW IS.
AT IN THE HALLWAY.
NO WILL BE JOINING US ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU. FOR REQUEST IN THIS AUDIT
ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC.
TODAY WE'LL BE DISCUSSING THE
AUDIT RESULTS AS WELL AS THE
STATUS OF CHANGES AND CORRECTIVE
ACTIONS TO BE IMPLEMENTED.
BY THE COMMITTEE CHILD CARE
COUNCIL OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THE STATE HAS COMMITTED ITSELF
TO HELP PROVIDE QUALITY
CHILDCARE AND DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES.
CHILDREN FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF FOLLOWING UP ON
THAT COMMITMENT AND ENSURING.
THAT THE FUNDS ARE BEING SPENT
HAS INTENDED.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
CONTRACTS OF LOCAL ENTITIES.
SUCH AS BEFORE SEIZE THE
COMMITTEE CHILD CARE COUNCIL. TO
PROVIDE CHILDCARE PROGRAMS.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ALSO
PROVIDES OVERSIGHT.
IT FORESEES AND SIMILAR ENTITIES
THROUGHOUT STATE AND REGARD. TO
THESE CONTRACTS.
DURING THE AUDIT PERIOD THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAD
SEVEN CONTRACTS WITH THE POOR
SEIZE THAT COVERED APPROXIMATELY
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
CHILDREN.
THE AUDIT REPORT WE ARE FOCUSED
ON TODAY.
LOOKED AT FORESEES EXPENDITURES
ITS POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND
ITS ADMINISTRATION OF THE SEVEN
CONTRACTS.
THE AUDIT REPORT ALSO EXAMINE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
OVERSIGHT OF FORESEES CONTRACTS.
THE AUDIT CONCLUDED.
THE FORESEES UNFAIRLY DISRUPTIVE
CHILD CARE SERVICES FOR SOME
FAMILIES.
PROVIDED UNREASONABLE DEADLINES
FOR FAMILIES TO RESPOND TO
IMPORTANT NOTIFICATIONS.
THESE INCLUDED NOTIFICATIONS TO
TERMINATE THE SERVICES THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
THE AUDIT ALSO FOUND THAT
FORESEES MADE.
ON ALLOWABLE.
PURCHASES TOTALING OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDS.
AND IT DID NOT COMPLY WITH THE
TERMS OF ITS CONTRACTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN SOME
KEY AREAS.
NUMBER ONE DETERMINING
ELIGIBILITY AND NEED. TO STAFF
DEVELOPMENT. THREE PROGRAM SELF
EVALUATION.
THE FORCE HE'S ALSO ENGAGED IN
QUESTION A PRACTICES AND
ADMINISTERING AND STATE FUNDED
SUPPLEMENT A RETIREMENT PLAN.
HE ALSO THE AUDIT ALSO FOUND
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
DID NOT DETECT SOME OF THE NON
COMPLIANCE AT THE STATE AUDITOR
FOUND AT THE POOR SEIZE.
THE AUDITOR ALSO FOUND A LACK OF
DOCUMENTATION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION'S REFUSE.
JUST PROCEDURALLY TODAY --
FEW HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS --
ASK THE PANELISTS TODAY KEEP THE
PRESENTATIONS TO THE TIMES
ALLOCATED THAT'S UP TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES FOR THE STATE AUDITOR'S
PRESENTATION.
WILL THEN HAVE UP TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES FOR REPRESENTATIVES FROM
FORESEES TO MAKE THEIR
PRESENTATION.
AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WILL HAVE UP TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES TO PRESENT.
THE FOLLOWING EACH PANEL MEMBERS.
OF THIS COMMITTEE WILL HAVE UP
TO FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR QUESTIONS
AND ANSWERS WILL THEN --
PRESENT TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
THAT WILL BE [inaudible]
THE HOUSE ROSE FOR TODAY.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS A SERVER
OUT BELL AS THE I REQUEST HER OF
THIS AUDIT WHICH LIKE --
TO MAKING OPENING STATEMENT YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
SIR ROTH APPRECIATE DAHLE
[inaudible]
THE OUR COMMITTEE DOING THIS
AUDIT IT WAS SO.
QUITE A CONCERN FOR THE
COMMUNITY IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY --
THE COMMUNITY CHILDCARE COUNCIL
SANTA CLARA COUNTY COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS FORESEES.
OF WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
COMMITTEE BASED AGENCY.
WHOSE MISSION IS TO PROVIDE
CHILDCARE AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN --
IN MY DISTRICT --
TO CARRY OUT ITS MISSION IN --
THEY'D MANNER MINISTER TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDS.
CLING APPROXIMATELY FORTY
MILLION ANNUALLY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
I SUBMITTED THIS AUDIT REQUEST.
AFTER YEARS OF ALLEGATION
REGARDING THE FINANCIAL
MISMANAGEMENT --
ALLEGATIONS ENCLOSURES OF FOR
CHILD DEVELOPMENT CENTERS RAISE
CONCERNS.
THE AUDITS FINDING --
SUBSTANTIATES SEVERAL OF THE
COMMUNITIES CONCERNED.
AND THAT WILL BE WHAT YOU WILL
HERE SHORTLY.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE AGENCY'S
MISMANAGEMENT RESULTED IN FEWER
TROLL CHILDCARE SLOTS AVAILABLE
TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
AFTER REVIEWING THE AUDIT
FINDINGS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
DID A NOTIFICATION TO FORESEES
THAT IS CONTRACT WOULD BE NOT
RENEWED.
BUT THIS DECISION WAS OVERTURNED
AFTER APPEAL TO REVIEW PANEL.
IT I HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S CONTRACTING POLICIES.
SPECIFICALLY I STRONGLY DISAGREE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S PRACTICE.
OF TO AUTOMATICALLY RENEW
CONTRACTS WITH ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE PERFORMING POORLY.
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZES
DEPARTMENT TO RE BID CONTRACTS
AN EFFORT TO ENSURE.
CHILDREN RECEIVE QUALITY CARE.
THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED TO LOOK
FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
AND HOW THE DEPARTMENT PLANS TO
IMPROVE THEIR PROCESS AND MOVE.
FOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU.
VICE CHAIR SERA WHICH I LIKE TO
MAKE ANY OPENING STATEMENTS
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING A RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT THERE WE WOULD THEN
LIKE TO INVITE THE STATE AUDITOR
EARNERS STAFF TO THE TABLE TO
OPEN THE THE TESTIMONY.
BEFORE YOU START THAT OUGHT --
MADAM CHAIR I DO NEED TO EXCUSE
MYSELF I HAVE THREE BILLS THAT
AND YOUR PRESENT THIS MORNING
AND SO VICE CHAIR ROTH CENTER
ROTH WILL BE [inaudible]
PRESIDING OVER [inaudible]
HEARING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANKYOU MISTER MURCH HG AND
MEMBERS NOW FOR THE RECORD MY
NAME'S ELAINE HOWELL I WILL
QUICKLY TURN IT OVER TO STAFF ON
MY RIGHT IS LYING ASLEEP LINUS
WAS THE AUDIT MANAGER ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT.
ON MY LEFT IS JOSHUA HOOPER
THOUGHT HE WAS THE TEAM LEADER
ON THIS PROJECT LEADING THE
AUDIT STAFF AND CONDUCTING THE
AUDIT.
AND THEY WILL GO OVER THREE KEY
ISSUES MISTER MURATSUCHI DID A
NICE JOB OF SUMMARIZING THE
FINDINGS WE HAD IN THE AUDIT
REPORT BUT CLEARLY THERE WERE
THREE KEY AREAS.
THAT WILL GO OVER TODAY ONE IS
WITH RESPECT TO DISRUPTED
SERVICES FOR FAMILIES --
BECAUSE OF TERMINATION NOTICES
WILL GET INTO SPECIFICS MISTER
LEE WILL DISCUSS THAT AREA --
ISSUES RELATED TO LATE PAYMENTS
TO PROVIDERS WHICH REALLY CAUSED
HARDSHIP AND THEN A DECISION TO
END A PRESCHOOL CONTRACT TO
AVOID SCRUTINY OF OTHER
CONTRACTS.
ALSO THAT'S ONE KEY AREA THE
NEXT AREA IS CONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS AND DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S OVERSIGHT --
IN FACT NOT DETECTING MANY OF
THE MISTER HOOPER WILL DISCUSS
SOME OF THE TESTING WE DID WITH
RESPECT TO EXPENDITURES IN OUR
DETERMINATION THAT SOME OF THOSE
WERE.
NOT ALLOWABLE UNDER THE
CONTRACTS --
THE FACT THAT FORESEES WAS NOT
COMPLYING WITH VARIOUS
CONTRACTING TERMS SUCH AS
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS.
PROVIDING STAFF DEVELOPMENT AND
TRAINING.
AND SELF EVALUATION --
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION
COMMENTS FROM THE BOARD STAFF
AND OTHERS IN ACTUALLY FROM
PARENTS AS WELL.
AND ASSESSING THEIR PROGRAMS SO
THAT'S A SECOND AREA THE THIRD
AREA MISTER HOOPER AGAIN WILL
DISCUSS IS RELATED TO THEIR
RETIREMENT PLANS.
AND SOME IN OUR VIEW VERY
QUESTIONABLE DECISIONS MADE WITH
RESPECT TO MANAGEMENT OF THE
RETIREMENT PLANS INVESTING FUNDS
IN VERY RESTRICTIVE SECURITIES
WHICH WAS REALLY NOT IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE PARTICIPANTS IN
THAT.
AND THOSE PARTICULAR PLANS THE
CREATION OF A SUPPLEMENTAL
RETIREMENT PLAN --
ONE LOGISTICAL SO WHEN WE ISSUED
A REPORT IN APRIL I WAS APRIL
FIFTH OF THIS YEAR --
ANY AGENCY THAT WE OUGHT TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY PROVIDER
RESPONSE WE PUBLISH THAT IN THE
AUDIT REPORT.
A BUT WE ALSO FOLLOW UP AT SIXTY
DAY SIX MONTHS IN ONE YEAR WE
HAVE RECEIVED THE SIXTY DAY
RESPONSE --
EARLIER THIS MONTH STAFF HAVE
REVIEWED [inaudible]
ARE OUR PERSPECTIVE ON THAT
RESPONSE BOTH FROM FOR SEIZE AND
THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION.
IS POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE WHEN
I'M MISTER LEE AND MR COOPER
DISCUSS THE RECOMMENDATIONS
RELATED TO EACH OF THE THREE
ISSUES THEY'LL BE ABLE TO GIVE
YOU.
BASICALLY WHAT OUR PERSPECTIVE
IS ON THE SIXTY DAY STATUS
REPORT THAT WE RECEIVED FROM
EACH OF THE TWO ENTITIES.
SO WITHOUT MEMBERS ALTERNATE
OVER TO MISTER LEE AND HELD
DISCUSS THE FIRST ISSUE.
RELATED TO DISRUPTED SERVICES
FOR FAMILIES.
A GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MIGHT
IN THE SLIGHTEST WAY I SERVED AS
THE PROJECT MANAGER --
NOT A PRINCIPLE ON THE OUT OF
THE FOUR SEASONS DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION --
AS BUSINESS HOW MANY KID THE
FIRST SET OF FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS IN A REPORT
ADDRESS FORESEES DISRUPTION OF
CHILDCARE SERVICES TO SOME
FAMILIES --
SPECIFICALLY A WE FOUND THAT
FORESEES GAVE --
THE UNREASONABLE DEADLINES TO
FAMILIES FOR RESPONDING TO
TERMINATION NOTICES --
THE THE THE TERMINATION NOTICES
REFER TO AS THE NOTICE OF ACTION
IT'S IT'S A COMMUNICATION METHOD
BY WHICH FORESEES COMMUNICATES
WITH IT'S FAMILIES REGARDING
CHANGES IN SERVICES --
SOME OF THOSE NOTIFICATIONS CAN
BE IN THE FORM OF TERMINATION OF
SERVICES A REDUCTION IN SERVICES
DEPENDING UPON.
THE FAMILY'S.
INCOME ELIGIBILITY AND OTHER
FACTORS.
WE FOUND THAT --
FORESEE STAFF HAD INCORRECTLY
RECORDED NOTIFICATION DATES
WITHIN ITS CHILD CARE DATABASE
SYSTEM --
WHICH IS USED TO GENERATE THESE
NOTICES --
FOR ABOUT 15% OF THOSE NOTIFIED
NOTICES DURING THAT FISCAL YEARS
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THE PERIOD THAT WE
LOOKED OUT.
WE FOUND THAT FIFTY BUT OVER 15%
HAD BEEN --
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE REFER TO THE
REPORT IS BEING BACKDATED --
THE DATES THAT WERE LISTED AS
NOTIFICATION DATES WERE CHANGED
TO EARLIER DATES AND THAT HAD
THE EFFECT OF CREATING A
DEADLINE DATE FOR FAMILIES TO
RESPOND TO BE MUCH EARLIER THAN
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
AS RESULT OF THAT FAMILIES WERE
NOT ABLE TO RESPOND TO THESE
NOTICES --
IN A TIMELY MANNER IN SOME CASES
FAMILIES WERE ONLY GIVEN A FEW
DAYS TO RESPOND INSTEAD OF THE
REQUISITE FOURTEEN TO NINETEEN
DAYS NINETEEN DAYS BEING
FORESEES POLICY IN FOURTEEN DAYS
BEING THE STATE'S OF STATE
REGULATION FOR NUMBER OF DAYS TO
RESPOND.
I IN FACT IN SOME CASES WE HAD
IDENTIFIED THROUGH OUR RESEARCH
OF THE DATABASE OF OVER FOUR
HUNDRED INSTANCES DURING THAT
TWO YEAR PERIOD IN WHICH
FAMILIES WORSE RECEIVE
NOTIFICATIONS WITH --
DUE DATES T
COLLAPSED AND SO THEY WERE
ESSENTIALLY GIVEN A NOTIFICATION
THAT THEY COULD RESPOND TO
BECAUSE THE TIME THAT ALREADY
EXPIRED --
IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY AND
DETERMINE THE EFFECT WE LOOKED
AT CASE FILES FOR A SELECTION OF
TEN NOTICES FOR WHICH THE US
SERVICES WERE --
SUGGEST TO BE TERMINATED AND WE
FOUND IN SOME CASES --
THE SERVICES ENDED UP NOT BEING
TERMINATED.
CASES IN WHICH SERVICES WERE
ACTUALLY TERMINATED --
THUS LEAVING FAMILY WITHOUT
SERVICES.
WE INQUIRED OF FORESEES AS TO
THE REASON WHY THE THE
SPECTATING IT OCCURRED IN THE
COULD NOT PROVIDE AN EXPLANATION
AS TO WHY THEY'RE STAFF
BACKDATED --
THOSE NOTICES NOR COULD THEY
PROVIDE AN EXPLANATION AS TO ANY
TYPE OF RATIONALE AS TO WHY A
DATE WOULD NEED TO BE BACK DATED.
OUR RECOMMENDATION WAS FOR FOR
SEIZE.
TO ESSENTIALLY I ESTABLISH
CONTROL WITHIN ITS DATABASE
SYSTEM TO PREVENT THE SPECTATING
FROM OCCURRING --
FORESEES AGREED WITH THAT
RECOMMENDATION THAT AND HAS
SINCE IMPLEMENTED THAT CONTROL
IN ITS SYSTEM.
OUR RECOMMENDATION ALSO --
I DIRECTED. FIVE TO A MONITOR
THAT CONTROL --
AND ENSURE THAT THE SPECTATING
DOES NOT OCCUR IN THE FUTURE --
IT AS IT IS IT IS STOCK
RESPONDED THAT IT'S GOING TO DO
SO AND WE WILL BE UP FOLLOWING
UP AT OUR NEXT TURN OVER WILL BE.
WHICH WILL BE FOUR MONTHS FROM
NOW AT THE SIX MONTH FOLLOW UP
RESPONSE PERIOD.
ANOTHER A RELATED AYE ISSUE
REGARDING --
THE BACKDATING IN THE
NOTIFICATIONS IS.
ALSO NOTED THAT.
THAT --
GIVEN THE HIGH NUMBER OF NOTICES
THAT HAD UNREASONABLE RESPONSE
PERIODS WE WOULD HAVE EXPECTED
TO HAVE SEEN FAMILIES APPEAL THE
THAT THE PROCESS IN QUESTION THE
AMOUNT OF TIME GIVEN TO THEM TO
RESPOND.
WHAT WE ENDED UP FIGHTING AND
INCREASE WITH BOTH FOR SEIZE AND
EDUCATION BOTH OF WHOM ARE
INVOLVED IN THE APPEAL PROCESS?
FORESEES FIRST IN EDUCATION.
AYE IN BOTH CASES FOR FISCAL
YEAR SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THEY
REPORTED THAT THEY DID NOT
RECEIVE ANY --
APPEALS RELATED TO THE ON
REASONABLE TIME FRAME SWITCHED
WHICH SURPRISED US.
WE WE THEN --
LOOKED INTO THE PROCESS SEASON
INFORMATION THAT WAS BEING
SHARED WITH THE FAMILIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT --
FROM FORESEES PERSPECTIVE WE'VE
WE FOUND THAT ALTHOUGH THEY
DESCRIBE THE FACT THAT THERE IS
AN APPEAL PROCESS WE DETERMINED
THAT.
THE DOCUMENTATIONS THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO THE FAMILIES AYE
LACKS DESCRIPTIONS OF
INFORMATION SUCH AS THE BALLOT
GROUNDS FOR HOW YOU WHAT WOULD
BE AN APPROPRIATE TYPE OF APPEAL.
WHO YOU WOULD CONTACT THE
PROCESS FOR GOING THROUGH THAT --
FROM EDUCATION'S PERSPECTIVE --
WE FOUND THAT EDUCATIONAL THOUGH
IT REQUIRED. FOR SEASON OTHER
CONTRACTORS --
TO ESTABLISHED APPEAL PROCESS
DID NOT SPECIFIC DIRECTION OR
PROCEDURAL REQUIREMENTS AS TO
HOW THOSE --
CONTRACTORS WERE SUPPOSED TO GO
ABOUT THAT.
A SORE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR BOTH
FORESEES AN EDUCATION RELATED TO
DEVELOPING THOSE PROPHECIES --
THE COMMUNICATION WITH FAMILIES
AND ENSURING THAT THERE WERE
REGULATORY OR A REQUIREMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH WITH CONTRACTORS
NOT ONLY HAVING THE
RESPONSIBILITY CONTRACTUALLY BUT
ALSO FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS.
BUT FOR SEIZE AGREED WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION PERTAIN TO IT
DIET IS CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF OF DEVELOPING --
COMMUNICATION AT THAT HOUSE --
DEVELOPED AT SIXTY DAY RESPONSE
AND INFORMED US THAT IT.
UNPREPARED AND APPEAL POLICY --
WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT TO BE
INCORPORATED WITHIN ITS PROVIDER
AND PARENT HANDBOOK.
BUT EDUCATION ON THE OTHER HAND
DID NOT AGREE WITH OUR
RECOMMENDATION --
DATE A EDUCATION BELIEVES THAT
IT'S PROCESS --
IN PLACE FOR DIRECTING.
CONTRACTORS ABOUT ESTABLISHMENT
BILL PROCESSES IS IS OUTLINED IN
SPECIFIED IN THE CONTRACT AND
OTHER PROCEDURES THAT THEY HAVE
IN PLACE OR SUFFICIENT.
WE FEEL THAT --
EDUCATION NEEDS TO SPEND A
ADDITIONAL ATTENTION IN TERMS OF
DEL ABOUT DEVELOPING PROCEDURAL
REQUIREMENTS GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THERE WERE NO APPEALS --
RELATED TO THIS VERY SENSITIVE
MATTER.
AS FAR AS OTHER AREAS RELATED TO
A DISRUPTION OF SERVICES WE ALSO
NOTED THAT FORESEES PAID SOME
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS LATE IN SOME
INSTANCES.
OF THE CAUSE FOR THAT HAD TO DO
WITH A LACK OF A COORDINATION
AND COMMUNICATION --
WITHIN DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE
FORCES ORGANIZATION SO IT A
RECOMMENDATION FOR FORESEES --
TO DEVELOP FORMAL POLICIES FOR
INTO CHOIR DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO TO PAY PROVIDERS --
WE WE DETERMINE THIS WAS A
SENSITIVE AREA FROM THE
STANDPOINT THAT OF PROVIDERS ARE
NOT PAID PROMPTLY THERE IS
CERTAINLY A RISK THAT OF OF THE
DISCONTINUANCE OF SERVICES OR
INTERMITTENT SERVICES.
THAT CAN ADVERSELY AFFECT
PARENTS AS WELL BECAUSE OF THEIR
NEEDS OF TO SEEK OTHER CHILD
CARE.
FINALLY WE IDENTIFIED THAT --
FORSEE SAID AND IT'S PRESCHOOL
CONTRACT TO AVOID SCRUTINY OF IT --
BY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION A
RELATED SORTS OTHER CONTRACTS --
EDUCATION AS PART OF ITS
MONITORING PROCESS THAT
IDENTIFIED CONCERNS HEALTH AND
SAFETY CONCERNS OUT SOME OF THE
PRESCHOOLS --
AB FORESEES.
AND HAD MADE A DECISION TO PLACE
THE FORESEES PRESCHOOL CONTRACT
UNDER CONDITIONAL STATUS.
BY THAT CONDITIONAL STATUS WOULD
THEN REQUIRE ADDITIONAL SCRUTINY
BY EDUCATION OF FORESEES
CONTRACT.
STATE LAW ALSO DICTATES THAT --
IF A CONTRACT DISPLACEMENT
CONDITIONAL STATUS THAN ALL
OTHER CONTRACTS OF THAT
CONTRACTOR ALSO TO BE PLACED ON
A CONDITIONAL STATUS --
THERE BY --
ESTABLISHING THIS SCRUTINY
ACROSS THE BOARD --
IN WRITTEN RESPONSE FORESEES IN
MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND FORM TO EDUCATION THAT IT
WAS.
GOING TO TERMINATE ITS PRESCHOOL
CONTRACT --
IT DID SO TO ESSENTIALLY --
THE ADDITIONAL SCRUTINY FROM THE
CONDITIONAL STATUS OF ITS OTHER
SIX CONTRACTS --
BUT AS A RESULT OF DOING THAT
AGAIN IT IT YET.
TERMINATED SERVICES FOR US A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF FAMILIES THAT
WERE RELYING ON THE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM --
NEVERTHELESS OR EDUCATION --
DESPITE --
THOSE OTHER SIX CONTRACTS NOT
BEGUN CONDITIONAL STATUS --
EDUCATION DID INITIATE A
PERFORMANCE AUDIT --
OF THOSE SIX CONTRACTS WHICH IS
CURRENTLY ONGOING AND AS WAS
INFORMED TO US IS EXPECTED TO BE
COMPLETED IN SEPTEMBER OF THIS
YEAR.
ALSO WITH ADULT TURNED OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER HOOPER WILL
WILL TALK ABOUT THE OTHER TWO
MAJOR AREAS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOSH UBER ON THE TEAM
LEAD FOR THIS AUDIT.
THOUGHT THE SECOND SET OF
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS IN
OUR REPORT INVOLVE FORESEES
FAILURE TO COMPLY.
WITH SOME OF THE REQUIREMENTS OF
ITS CONTRACTS WITH EDUCATION.
FIRST WE FOUND THAT FOR SEIZE
YOU STATE GRANT FUNDS FOR ON
ALLOWABLE AND QUESTIONABLE
PURCHASES.
WE LOOKED AT SIXTY NINE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOCUSING ON
COSTS THAT APPEARED TO BE LESS
TYPICAL OF CHILD DEVELOPMENT
CONTRACTS.
AND FOUND THAT TWENTY TWO OF
THOUGH SIXTY NINE WERE NOT
ALLOWABLE FOR REIMBURSEMENT
UNDER STATE AND FEDERAL
REGULATIONS AND THE TERMS OF THE
CONTRACTS.
THESE COSTS INCLUDED ATTORNEY
FEES FOR PRIVATE PRESCHOOL.
FOOD FOR BOARD MEETINGS AND
PERSONAL AMENITIES.
IN ADDITION WE FOUND THE FORCES
DO NOT HAVE PROPER DOCUMENTATION.
FOR FIFTY SIX STEVE NINE COSTS
WE REVIEW. TO ADDRESS THESE
FINDINGS WE RECOMMENDED THAT
FORESEES SHOULD STRENGTHEN ITS
CONTROLS OVER PURCHASING.
INCLUDING SPECIFICALLY TO RETAIN
SUPPORT DOCUMENTATION FOR IS
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
WE ALSO RECOMMENDED THAT
EDUCATION SHOULD RECOVER ANY
FUNDS FROM ON ALLOWABLE COSTS
FORESEES SHOULD REPAY.
IN LOOKING AT OAK EDUCATIONS
OVERSIGHT WE FOUND THAT
EDUCATION CONDUCTS ANNUAL
CONTRACTOR AUDITS BUT EDUCATIONS
AUDITS FOR THE MOST RECENT THREE
YEARS DID NOT IDENTIFY ANY ON
ALLOWABLE COSTS. FOR THIS REASON
WE RECOMMENDED THAT AFTER
EDUCATION.
PLEASE THE AUDIT THAT MISTER LEE
MENTIONED.
THAT IT SHOULD DETERMINE WHETHER
IT NEEDS TO EXPAND ITS OVERSIGHT
OVER PROCEDURES FOR IDENTIFYING
THESE ON ALLOWABLE COSTS.
ANOTHER WAY WE FOUND THAT
FORESEES WAS NOT COMPLYING WITH
THE TERMS OF ITS EDUCATION
CONTRACTS IS IN ITS
DETERMINATIONS OF ELIGIBILITY.
ELEVEN OF THE TWENTY FOUR CASE
FILES WE REVIEWED LACKED
SUFFICIENT DOCUMENTATION TO
JUSTIFY FORESEES DETERMINATIONS
[inaudible]
OF ELIGIBILITY. TO ADDRESS THIS
WE RECOMMENDED THAT FORESEES
SHOULD DEVELOP FORMAL PROCEDURES
FOR ITS ELIGIBILITY INCLUDING A
POLICY TO RETAIN THE
DOCUMENTATION IT USES TO MAKE
ITS ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS.
WE RECOMMENDED THAT FORESEES
SHOULD COMPLY WITH ITS
CONTRACTUAL REQUIREMENTS TO
IDENTIFY IT STAFF TRAINING NEEDS.
AND TO CREATE ORIENTATION AND
TRAINING PLANS FOR IT STAFF TO
MEET THOSE NEEDS.
THIRD WE FOUND THAT FORESEES WAS
NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH SOME OF
ITS EDUCATION CONTRACT
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO ITS SELF
EVALUATIONS OF ITS CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS.
SPECIFICALLY WE FOUND THE FORCE
HE'S WAS NOT DESCRIBING THE
PROCEDURES THAT TOOK DURING THE
SELF EVALUATION PROCESS
SEPARATELY FOR EACH PROGRAM.
AND IT WAS NOT CONSISTENTLY
DOCUMENTING THAT IT USED
FEEDBACK FROM STAKEHOLDERS SUCH
AS THE BOARD [inaudible]
PARENTS STAFF.
IN TO IMPROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF ITS PROGRAMS.
AFTER DISCOVERING FORESEES
NONCOMPLIANCE WITH ITS EDUCATION
CONTRACTS.
WE EVALUATED EDUCATIONS
DETERMINATIONS OF COMPLIANCE.
AND FOUND THAT EDUCATION FOUND
COMPLIANCE.
IN CONTRAST TO WHAT WE FOUND IN
TWO AREAS.
FORESEES WAS UNABLE TO PROVIDE
THE SUPPORT DOCUMENT
[inaudible]
JASON.
EDUCATION WAS UNABLE TO PROVIDE
THE SORT PORT DOCUMENTATION THAT
USED TO MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS OF COMPLIANCE SO
WE RECOMMENDED THAT EDUCATION
SHOULD BEGIN MAINTAINING A
RECORD OF THE EVIDENCE IT USES.
SPORT IT'S DETERMINATIONS.
DURING THIS REVIEW WE ALSO FOUND
THAT ALTHOUGH THE CONTRACTS
REQUIRE FORESEES TO INCLUDE
PROGRAM ASSESSMENTS BY ITS BOARD
MEMBERS FORESEES DID NOT DO SO.
TO ADDRESS THIS WE RECOMMENDED
THAT EDUCATION SHOULD ADOPT
MEASURES TO ENSURE ITS
CONTRACTORS DEMONSTRATE THE
BOARD MEMBERS CONDUCT APPRAISALS
OF EACH EDUCATION.
AS EDUCATIONS CONTRACTS REQUIRE.
IN ITS SIXTY DAY RESPONSE
EDUCATION INDICATED THAT IT
WOULD NOT IMPLEMENT THIS
RECOMMENDATION.
IN CONTRAST TO THE REQUIREMENTS
OF ITS CONTRACTS.
EDUCATION CONSIDER DOCUMENTATION
THAT FORESEES MADE ITS BOARD
AWARE OF THE STATUS OF FORCES
CONTRACTS I SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
THAT FORESEES MET THIS
REQUIREMENT.
HOWEVER THE DOCUMENTATION
PROVIDED NO INDICATION THAT
FORESEES PORT CONDUCTED AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE PROGRAM'S THE
CONTRACTS REQUIRE.
EDUCATION AGREES WITH THE OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE TO IT IN
THE SECTION.
AND FOUR SEASONS WORKING TO
IMPLEMENT EACH OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IT.
THE THIRD SECTION OF OUR REPORT
ADDRESSES OUR FINDINGS WITH
REGARD FOR SEIZE ADMINISTRATION
OF ITS RETIREMENT PLANS.
WE FOUND THE FORESEES FORMER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR COMMITTED
FORESEES TO FOLLOWING THE ADVICE
OF ITS FINANCIAL ADVISER TO
PLACE THE FUNDS. FOR ITS PRIMARY
AND ITS SUPPLEMENTAL RETIREMENT
PLANS INTO RESTRICTIVE
SECURITIES WITH HIGH WITHDRAWAL
CHARGES.
THIS RESULTED AND HARDSHIPS FOR
ITS EMPLOYEES AND BENEFICIARIES.
WE RECOMMENDED THAT FORESEES
SHOULD MOVE THE FUNDS FOR ITS
RETIREMENT PLANS OUT OF THE
RESTRICTIVE SECURITIES TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT CAN DO SO WITHOUT
INCURRING.
ADDITIONAL CHARGES PER FOR
BENEFICIARIES.
WE ALSO FOUND THAT FORESEES WAS
DEFICIENT AND MEETING SEVERAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR ITS
RETIREMENT PLANS INCLUDING.
DISCLOSING THE SOURCE OF THE
FUNDING FOR ITS PLANTS AND THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE BENEFITS
BENEFICIARIES ACCRUED.
WE RECOMMENDED THAT FORESEES
SHOULD PROVIDE THE REQUIRED
DISCLOSURES IN ITS RETIREMENT
BENEFITS STATEMENTS IT'S SUMMARY
PLAN DESCRIPTIONS AND IN ITS
ANNUAL REPORT.
AND BUT IT SHOULD SUBMIT THESE
REPORTS ON TIME WHILE RETAINING
DOCUMENTATION BUT IT DID SO.
LASTLY WE FOUND THAT FORCES MAY
HAVE IMPROPERLY YOU STATE
FUNDING TO FIND AT SUPPLEMENTAL
RETIREMENT PLAN.
WE FOUND THAT FORESEES DID NOT
CONDUCT AN ANALYSIS OF THE
FUTURE NEEDS OF THIS PLAN
FUNDING IT SPORADICALLY AND IN
VARYING AMOUNTS.
WE FOUND THAT IF THE FORMER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OPTED INTO
THE SUPPLEMENTAL RETIREMENT PLAN.
IT WOULD DEFEAT DEPLETE THE
FUNDS IN THE PLANNED LEAVING
NOTHING FOR OTHER POTENTIAL
BENEFICIARIES. FOR THIS WE
RECOMMENDED THAT EDUCATION
SHOULD REQUIRE FORESEES. TO
REIMBURSE THE STATE FOR IMPROPER
PAYMENTS OF STATE FUNDS IT MADE
TO ITS SUPPLEMENTAL RETIREMENT
PLAN. FOR SEASON EDUCATION OF
BOTH INDICATED THAT THEY AGREE
WITH THE RETIREMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE SEX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND NOW
WE'RE HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT --
EXCELLENT REPORT.
I RECEIVED COVERED SEVERAL AREAS
ME JUST MAKE SURE THAT I'M CLEAR
DURING THE STATE AUDIT YOU FOUND
THAT THERE WERE SIX THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
BACKDATED NOTICES.
YES THAT'S THAT'S SIX THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
BACKDATED NOTICES. SIX THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY SENATOR
DIANNE DYSLEXIC SIX SIX THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
BACKDATED NOTICES AND FORESEES
PROVIDED NO EXPLANATION FOR THE
BACKDATING.
THAT THAT'S CORRECT WE INQUIRED
ABOUT THE THE RATIONAL FOR WHY
ONE WOULD GET BACK DAYS --
AND THEY WERE UNABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT DID FORESEES IDENTIFY THE
EMPLOYEES WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
THE BACKDATING AND INDICATE
WHETHER THEY WERE SUPERVISOR
ORIEL EMPLOYEES OR SUBORDINATE
EMPLOYEES ARE BOTH --
THAT THEY INFORMED US THAT A
WHILE DEPARTMENT THE THE THE
ORGANIZATION WAS UNDER A
DIFFERENT MINISTRATION DURING
THAT PERIOD --
WHAT WE WERE INFORMED OF ITS
THAT THE THE CURRENT SUPERVISOR
OVERSEEING THAT PROCESS INFORMED
US THAT THAT PRACTICE WOULD
DISCONTINUE BUT DIDN'T PROVIDE
ANY CONTEXT AS TO WHO WAS
INVOLVED PRIOR TO THAT?
DID FORESEES BRIEF YOU IS.
TO WHAT INTERNAL CORRECTIVE
ACTION SPECIFICALLY INCLUDING
DISCIPLINE THAT THE ORGANIZATION
EITHER HAD TAKEN OR INTENDED TO
TAKE AS A RESULT OF THE
INFORMATION DISCLOSED BY YOUR
AUDIT ASSUMING.
SOMEBODY DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT
BEFOREHAND.
THEY DO NOT PROVIDE US ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT ANY DISCIPLINE
ACTION REGARDING EMPLOYEES THEY
BASED AND IT'S ACTUALLY INFORMED
US THAT MOVING FORWARD THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO IT INSTILL THOSE
CONTROLS AND ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE WAS OF INFORMED OF WHAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE.
WE YOU KNOW WHEN YOU WHEN YOUR
ACTIONS BECAUSE THE TERMINATION
OF SERVICES OR WHEN YOUR ACTIONS
INTERFERE WITH SOMEONE'S APPEAL
RIGHTS YOU WHEN YOUR ACTIONS.
FAILED TO PROVIDE SUFFICIENT.
TO INFORMATION ABOUT A VARIETY
OF THINGS INCLUDING AVAILABILITY
OF SERVICES OR THOSE APPEAL
RIGHTS THOSE ARE OBVIOUSLY VERY
SERIOUS.
MATTERS AS ARE THE OTHER MATTERS
SUCH [inaudible]
THAT --
COOPER YOU --
DISCLOSED DURING YOUR PORTION OF
THE PRESENTATION.
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE MOST
SERIOUS THING HERE AND THE MOST
FRANKLY OF RAGES.
PIECE OF THIS [inaudible]
AUDIT.
I HAS TO DO WITH --
AND IT WAS VERY SERIOUS
INTEGRITY PROBLEM.
AND WHEN YOU BACK DATE
[inaudible]
THINGS.
OR IN THE MILITARY RELEASED
CAUGHT PENCIL WHIPPING --
REQUIREMENTS --
TRANSLATED THAT TRANSLATES INTO
LINE.
IT'S UNINTENTIONAL ACTION THAT
IS NOT NEGLIGENCE --
AND CERTAINLY NOT INADVERTENT.
YOU KNOW --
OUR CORE VALUES IN THE AIR FORCE
WERE INTEGRITY FIRST --
SERVICE BEFORE SELF AND
EXCELLENCE IN ALL WE DO --
SOMEBODY YEAR FORGET THE
INTEGRITY PEAS.
AND SO -- I
WILL BE VERY INTERESTED TO HEAR
A DURING THE NEXT PRESENTATION --
AND THE ONE FOLLOWING FROM THE
DEPRIVED OF EDUCATION.
WHAT ACTION HAS BEEN TAKEN?
WITH RESPECT TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ENGAGED AND AN INTENTIONAL
ACT THAT IN LEAST IN SOME CASES
AS YOU'VE INDICATED --
RESULT IN A LOSS OF SERVICE.
SO I THOUGHT I WILL.
TURN THE QUESTIONING OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO UNDOUBTEDLY KNOW
MUCH MORE ABOUT THIS SUBJECT AND
I DO SO COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SENATE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I I
HAD QUESTIONS ON THOSE LINES SO
ABOUT THE BACKDATING AND CAN YOU
CAN YOU EXPLAIN --
MORE FULLY THE IMPLICATIONS OF
BACKDATING WHAT WHAT KIND OF
REASON WHAT SOMEBODY BACKDATE --
THOSE DOCUMENTS.
SIR CERTAINLY --
AT AS WE MENTION IN THE REPORT --
WHILE WE WERE NOT PROVIDED WITH
DIRECT EXPLANATIONS AS TO WHY
FORESEES DID THAT WE WE DID NOTE
THAT -- ONE
POTENTIAL REASON FOR DOING THAT
WAS TO MAKE FOUR SEES AS A
CONTRACTOR LOOK MORE COMPLIANT
AND MAYBE IT ACTUALLY WAS IF IT
WAS BEHIND ON PROCESSING THE
NOTICES BY --
USING EARLIER DATES IT MAY --
PRESENT THE IMAGE THAT IT IS --
MORE UP TO DATE THAT IT THAT IT
WAS IN TERMS --
RESPONSES FROM FAMILIES THAT
THAT IS ONE THING WE MENTION IN
THE REPORT --
ASIDE FROM THAT --
THERE MAY BE OTHER MOTIVATIONS
THAT WE WE WERE NOT ABLE TO GET
ANY TYPE OF CLARIFICATION ON
FORESEES AS TO WHY THEY DID IT.
THEY'RE THE FOLKS THAT WE SPOKE
WITH WERE FOCUSED MORE ON WHAT
TRIP SHORT CORRECTIVE ACTION TO
BE TAKEN IN TERMS OF MOVING
FORWARD AND SO THEIR FOCUS WAS
PRIMARILY ON ADDRESSING THE THE
CONTROL WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
AND ALSO IDENTIFYING THE IMPACT
OF THE EXTENT TO WHICH FAMILIES
WERE AFFECTED THAT THEY WERE IN
THE PROCESS OF RESEARCHING THAT
TOWARDS THE END OF OUR AUDIT.
CAN YOU CAN YOU CALM.
IN TERMS OF THE BACKDATING CAN
YOU -- TELL
US -- HOW
THOUSANDS OF BACKDATING
DOCUMENTS?
WHAT'S THE PROCESS THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION USED.
IN REVIEWING IT DOES --
PROGRAM.
AND HOW THEY MISSED THOSE --
BACKDATING.
THAT OCCURRED AND THE CORRECTION
ACTION YOU'RE RECOMMENDING TO
THEM.
IT WE WE WE MENTION THE REPORT
THAT --
EDUCATIONS OVERSIGHT OF OF
FORESEES A IN THIS PARTICULAR
AREA BACK DATING WOULD BE VERY
LIMITED OF WE HAD THE ABILITY
THROUGH OUR THROUGH OUR IT
AUDITS UNIT TO BE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH THE ACTUAL DATA IN THE
DATA SYSTEM AND AND ESSENTIALLY
EXTRACT THIS INFORMATION AND IN
PRESENTED AT A AT A HIGH.
LEVEL I AS WELL AS BREAKING CORD.
I EDUCATION AS PART OF ITS --
COMPLIANCE REVIEWS --
OUR ON SITE AND FOCUS IN ON A
NUMBER OF OF DIFFERENT AREAS
REALLY TO THE PROGRAM BUT WE
INQUIRED ABOUT.
THE LEVEL OF INVOLVEMENT
ASSOCIATED WITH --
FINISHES SUCH AS THIS THEY
INFORMED US THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE TECHNICAL EXPERTISE --
IT DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME
FOR THE REVIEW TO BE GOING AT
THAT LEVEL OF DEATH THAT WE DID
ON OUR ON OUR AUDIT --
AND THEY WOULD THAT WOULD
REQUIRE SOME TECHNICAL
EXPERIENCE FOR WHICH THE
CONSULTANT AND STAFF ASSIGNED TO
THAT -- ARE
OR MORE PROGRAM FOCUSES OPPOSED
TO TECHNOLOGY FOCUSED SOON TURNS
OF THEIR INTERNAL --
OVERSIGHT MECHANISMS.
UM THIS IS CONSIDERED TO BE A
DEFICIENCY THAT.
NEEDS TO BE CORRECTED IS THAT
TRUE.
I THINK WE WE WE WE LOOKED AT IT
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF CERTAINLY
IF THIS THAT THIS OCCURRED --
HERE AT FOUR SEIZE IT COULD
POTENTIALLY OCCUR --
ELSEWHERE WITHIN THE STATE WITH
OTHER CONTRACT. TO INFORM THEM
OF OUR AS THEY WERE AWARE OF OF
THE ISSUE THAT WE IDENTIFIED --
INFORMS US THAT THEY THAT THERE
AS PART OF THEIR REVIEW THAT
THAT ISN'T PART OF THEIR
STANDARD REVIEW ALTHOUGH I WOULD
DEFER TO THEM IN TERMS OF YES
GUESSING HOW THEY MIGHT.
APPROACH THAT [inaudible]
WHEN --
THERE WAS TWO OTHER AUDITS OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT ON
DIFFERENT SUBJECTS CALIFORNIA
PART EDUCATION.
BEFORE THIS --
ONE RICK WHAT A RELATED TO THIS
SUBJECT --
IN THOSE AUDITS THERE WAS --
AGAIN.
A CONCLUSION THAT THERE WAS AN
AD HOC GROUPS --
OR INADEQUATE OVERSIGHT.
THE IN THOSE ON IT SO --
IN TERMS OF THIS AUDIT.
ARE THEY FULLY COMPLYING.
WITH THIS AUDIT.
OR YOU SAID EARLIER THAT YOU'RE
NOT.
FULLY COMPLYING WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE AUDIT.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE AREAS
THAT THEY'RE NOT.
FULLY COMPLYING WITH THIS AUDIT.
SO I UNDERSTAND THEM --
A LITTLE BIT MORE CLEARLY --
FORESEES IS INDICATED THAT THEY
AGREE WITH EACH OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN OUR REPORT
AND THEY'RE WORKING ON IT
EDUCATION --
GREECE WITH FOUR OUT OF THE SIX
RECOMMENDATIONS IN A REPORT --
THE DISAGREE WITH US ARM --
ARE THE ISSUE OF THEY DISAGREE
WITH US ON THE ISSUE OF A HAVING
BOARD.
REVIEW OF ITS SELF EVALUATION
PROCESSES AND ON EDUCATION
BELIEVES THAT ITS INTERPRETATION
OF ITS OWN CONTRACTS IS
SUFFICIENT --
AND ABOUT MISTER LEE SPOKE ABOUT
THE OTHER.
AREA WHERE EDUCATION DISAGREES
WITH A RECOMMENDATION CAN YOU.
YEAH -- WILL
WE WERE WE WERE REFERRING TO THE
APPEAL PROCESS I THINK SENATOR
BILL THOUGH YOU'RE RIGHT YOU'RE
REFERRING --
TO AREAS IN WHICH WE IDENTIFIED
NONCOMPLIANCE ASSOCIATED WITH
FORESEES CONTRACT THAT BRADFORD
FROM --
WHERE EDUCATIONS REVIEW WAS AND
AND THOSE TWO AREAS WHAT WE'RE
FOCUSED AROUND ABOUT STAFF
DEVELOPMENT AND PROGRAM SELF
EVALUATION BEYONCE WAS MISTER
COOPER DESCRIBED THE PROGRAM
SELF EVALUATION?
THE STAFF DEVELOPMENT WAS THE
OTHER AREA FOR WHICH WE
DETERRENT WE IDENTIFIED ISSUES
RURAL REGARDING STAFF
DEVELOPMENT THAT THE APPROPRIATE
OUT REGION.
LEVEL OF DETAIL --
EDUCATIONS REVIEW TEAM --
REVIEW THAT AREA AND SHERMAN
THAT THEY WERE LANCE.
NO --
PRACTICALLY EVERY DEPARTMENT OF
THE STATE [inaudible]
OF CALIFORNIA.
THEN MINISTERS CONTRACTS AND
THEY HAVE THEY ALL HAVE LIKE
SOME.
DEGREE OF OVERSIGHT --
TO PROCESS IN PLACE.
AND THE CONCERN I HAVE ON THIS
IS.
BASED ON YOUR EXPERIENCE IN
REVIEWING OTHER.
DEPARTMENTS.
HOW DOES THE --
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
OVERSIGHT PROCESS.
CONTRACTORS COMPARED TO OTHER
STATE DEPARTMENTS [inaudible]
IS -- SOME
OTHER EXAMPLES OF WHERE THEY CAN
DO IT MORE RIGOROUS OVERSIGHT.
THAT SHOULD BE USED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THAT WOULD IMPROVE THEIR
OVERSIGHT COME YOU KNOW SIMILAR
TO OTHER.
DEPARTMENTS --
INTERESTS OF CONTRACTS SO.
THEN I HAD ANOTHER AREA WAS THE
SUBCONTRACTS.
OF THE FOUR CITIES HAVE YOU
EXAMINED THE SUBCOMMITTEE OTHER
THE VARIOUS CONTRACTORS THAT
CONTRACT WITH FORESEES.
YEAH WE DID NOT --
WE DO NOT GO DOWN TO THE LEVEL
OF OF SUBCONTRACTORS AND I IN
OUR REVIEW --
WE FOCUSED ON AS MISTER COOPER
DESCRIBED CERTAINLY --
EXPENDITURES THAT WERE PART OF
OUR SCOPE --
ADMINISTRATOR EXPENDITURES BUT
NOT TO THE CONTRACTORS --
AS FAR AS AS FAR AS
COMPARABILITY --
AMONGST OTHER OVERSIGHT
FUNCTIONS I THINK THAT --
IT CERTAINLY DOES VARY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE DEPENDS ON
THE LEVEL OF OF OF OF FOCUS AND
EFFORT BY AN OVERSIGHT AGENCY
THERE ARE CERTAINLY CERTAINLY
STATE AGENCIES OUT THERE THAT
HAVE -- TAKE
A DIFFERENT APPROACH WHEN IT
COMES -- TO
OVERSIGHT AND MONITORING AND
MANAGEMENT OF CONTRACTS --
FORESEE A EDUCATIONS APPROACH IS.
TO IS THAT IS TO HAVE BEEN
ASSIGNED CONSULTANT THAT
OVERSEES THAT PARTICULAR
CONTRACTOR GROUP OF CONTRACTORS
TYPICALLY REGIONAL --
CONDUCTS A OUR ON SITE VISITS
AND IS IS ALSO AVAILABLE IN ITS
AND CONSTITUTED XIN WITH THE
CONTRACTOR THROUGHOUT.
THE DURATION OF THE CONTRACT --
CERTAINLY THERE COULD BE.
SITUATIONS WHERE.
THE CONSULTANT OR WHOEVER COULD
BE OUT THERE MORE FREQUENTLY OR
OR A TAKE ON A GREATER LEVEL OF
OVERSIGHT --
WE'RE ALSO INFORMED THOUGH THAT
THOSE THAT THOSE CONSULTANTS AT
EDUCATION ALSO HAVE
RESPONSIBILITIES ELSEWHERE WITH
OTHER CONTRACTS SO.
ADMIT SOME OF IT MAY BE A
WORKLOAD ISSUE AND IT DEPENDS ON
THE LEVEL OF ETHICISTS TO FOCUS
ON OKAY SO.
THIS PARTICULAR CONTRACT
[inaudible]
WAS OVERSIGHT.
BY SOMEBODY WHO ALSO RECITES
OTHER CONTRACTS THAT'S CORRECT --
HOW MANY OTHER CONTRACTS IN THE
OVERSEAS HAVE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY --
FOR I'D I'M NOT AWARE THAT
SPECIFICALLY I THINK THE
PARTNERS KITCHEN COULD PROVIDE
THAT IT'S YOUR THAT INFORMATION.
UGH GIVE IT GIVEN THE LIMITED
SCOPE OF THE AUDIT --
IN YOUR EXPERIENCE DO YOU DO THE
FINDING SUGGESTS THAT --
OR INDICATE THE AGENCY HAS
DEFICIENCIES IN OTHER AREAS.
OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF THIS AUDIT
THAT SHOULD BE EXPLORED.
AND DOES THAT EXHIBIT A LONG
STANDING.
PATTERN OF NONCOMPLIANCE WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS.
A I WOULD SAY THAT --
ALTHOUGH OR OR ON IT WAS FOCUSED
ON SPECIFIC AREAS WE CERTAINLY
AS PART OF OUR PROCESS --
WE WERE LOOKING AT THE OVERALL
CULTURE WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION --
IN TERMS OF LEADERSHIP AND
DIRECTION AND AND ALL OF THAT --
AS AS YOU MAY BE AWARE IF
DIRECTOR OF THAT ORGANIZATION
HAD BEEN IN THAT POSITION --
FOR CLOSE TO FORTY YEARS OR MORE
HAD -- HAD
RETIRED DURING OUR AUDIT
FIELDWORK AND SO --
HE WAS REPLACED BY AN INTERIM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR --
THE INTERIM EXECUTIVE RECTOR IS
TAKING -- IS
IS DEVELOPING --
APPROACHES IN RESPONSE TO THE
AUDIT REPORT OTHER THINGS THAT
THAT ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE WHETHER OR NOT THOSE
ALSO COVER OTHER AREAS OF
CONCERN WITHIN FORESEES A I
WOULD DEFER TO THE INTERMIX
AFTER ACTOR TO SPEAK OF WHAT I
WOULD SAY THOUGH THAT THE
CULTURE OF THE ORGANIZATION.
CERTAINLY IS SOMETHING THAT THAT
WOULD -- BE
SUMMED IT UP TO CONSIDER WITH
HAD OUR SCOPE IN LARGER WE
PROBABLY --
WOULD --
LOOK INTO OTHER AREAS RELATED TO
FOR EXAMPLE EXPENDITURES WHERE
WERE WE ARE ASKED LOOKING AT
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENDITURES THAT
WAS ALL AS A COMPONENT AS WE
INDICATED THAT WE LOOKED AT 1% --
BUT CERTAINLY THAT WAS AN AREA
WHERE WERE GIVEN WHAT WE FOUND
WE THOUGHT WE WE WE COULD
CERTAINLY SAY THAT THERE MAY BE
CONCERNS ELSEWHERE RELATED TO
THAT BUT WITHIN.
OUR SCOPE AND TIME FRAME WE
FOCUSED ON THE ONES THAT WE
REPORTED THE MOST LOW ONE OF THE
MOST ALARMING FINDINGS OF WAS AT
THE FOR SEEDS IN GAUGING
QUESTION ALL MANAGEMENT.
OF ITS RETIREMENT PLANS.
AND LOOK LIKE THEY WERE UNABLE
TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS OKAY.
ARM OR PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
DOCUMENTATION REGARDING THE
RETIREMENT PLANS.
SO HOW HOW --
CONCERNING THIS IS SITUATION HOW
MUCH PUBLIC FUNDS.
ARE CURRENTLY HELD IN THESE
RETIREMENT PLANS CAN YOU GIVE US
AN IDEA.
OF THE SCOPE OF THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THE WE WE THAT THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAD ON THE SIDE IT WAS
DETERMINING THE THAT THE PORTION
OF FUNDS THAT COULD BE
ATTRIBUTED TO PUBLIC FUNDS
WHETHER IT BE STATE OR FEDERAL
FUNDING OR OTHER --
PUBLIC SECTOR FUNDING --
A LOT OF IT HAD TO DO WITH THE
LIMITATION ON RECORDS ASSOCIATED
WITH -- WITH --
THE HISTORY OF THE PLANTS WHICH
HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS SO WE CAN'T WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO IDENTIFY A SPECIFIC
NUMBER --
PER SE HOWEVER.
A WE DO INCLUDE WE MAKE
REFERENCE TO BOTH THE PRIMARY
PLAN WHICH IS THE A RETIREMENT
PLAN THAT WAS MADE AVAILABLE TO
ALL EMPLOYEES AND THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PLAN WHICH MISTER
COOPER DESCRIBED AS BEING A A
CREATED PLAN THAT BENEFITTED A
SPECIFIC NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING THE FORMER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR --
WE DO HAVE I DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT SUPPLEMENTAL PLAN AS
AS MISTER COOPER INDICATED --
AND THE MAGNITUDE OF THAT THIS
IS GOING TO BE --
IT'S ONLY A FACTOR TO BE LOOKING
AT IN TERMS OF HOW FORESEES
MOVES AHEAD.
OF THE AUDIT FOUND THAT THE IS
THAT IF THE FORMER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SUCCESSFULLY ENROLLED.
IN THE SUPPLEMENTAL PLAN.
AND HE WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
MORE THAN TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
AND QUESTION I HAVE IS.
BASED ON THE HOUSE REVIEW OF
OTHER --
STATE FUNDED NON PROFITS OR
PROGRAMS IN THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION --
ARE THESE TYPES OF PLANTS CARMEN.
AND THOSE THOSE --
PLANS THIS DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION --
ALLOW THOSE PLANS AND OTHER --
OTHER NON PROFITS SAID THEY HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH --
AND DO WE KNOW TO DO TO DATE IF --
FORMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HAS
SUCCESSFULLY ENROLLED IN ANY OF
THESE PENSION PLANS --
I I WOULD DEFER TO THE CARNAGE
CATION REGARDING YOUR FIRST
QUESTION ABOUT THE CONTEXT OF
THIS TYPE OF OF PLAN --
AS FAR AS THE FORMER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AYE AS OF AS OF THE
ISSUANCE OF OUR AUDIT WE DID NOT
KNOW FOR CERTAIN WHETHER OR NOT
THE FORMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
HAD AND ROLLED UP THE PROVISIONS
OF THE PLAN.
ESSENTIALLY ALLOW AN EMPLOYEE
WHO IS WHO RETIRES TO ENROLL IN
THE PLAN --
WITHIN SIX MONTHS --
AS AS YOU SAW BUT WE CLEARLY SAW
EVIDENCE OF SO WHERE WE CAN'T
SAY FOR CERTAIN WHETHER OR NOT
HE HAS OR WILL THAT ROLE IN THE
FUTURE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF OUR EDUCATIONS
PROCESS --
FOR LOOKING AT CONTRACTS IN
RENEWING CONTRACTS.
SEEMS RATHER STRANGE PROCESS TO
ME -- DO YOU
HAVE ANY --
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT THEIR
PROCESS FOR REVIEWING AND
RENEWING.
CONTRACTS --
THAT WOULD --
INCREASE THE TRANSPARENCY AND
PROCESS --
FOR RENEWING A REVEALING AND
RENEWING CONTRACTS --
WITH THE THESE THESE PROGRAMS.
ABOUT ME I WOULD SAY THAT --
GIVEN THE THE AREAS THAT WE
REPORTED NO REPORT CERTAINLY AS
IT PERTAINS TO FORESEES --
THAT THAT EDUCATION FOCUSING ON
THOSE PARTICULAR AREAS AS WELL
AS WELL AS THE RESULT OF ITS
AUDIT ITS ONGOING AUDIT THAT
THAT -- WILL
BE ISSUED SOON --
IN TERMS OF FOCUSING IN ON THOSE
AREAS WHAT WE WHAT WE
RECOMMENDED IN OUR REPORT AS IT
RELATED TO FOR EXAMPLE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF WAS.
TO LOOK AT THE TYPES OF ISSUES
IDENTIFIED.
IN THOSE AND CONSIDER FACTOR IN
THOSE IN AS YOU LOOK AT OTHER
CONTRACTS OF A SIMILAR NATURE.
SO I THINK THAT THE THAT THOSE
TYPES OF FACTORS SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED IN --
WHEN IT DOES NOT COME TIME TO
LOOK AT A PARTICULAR CONTRACT
FOR RENEWAL LOOKING AT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS THE
PROGRAMMATIC AN OPERATIONAL
SIDES I THINK A REPORT INCLUDES
A NUMBER OF?
I DIFFERENT AREAS START TO CALL
TO THE COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION AS
WELL AS EDUCATIONS ATTENTION AND
EDUCATION HAS INDICATED THAT
IT'S PERFORMANCE AUDIT.
IS ALSO COVERING SIMILAR AREAS
SO WE WOULD EXPECT THAT THAT
INFORMATION COULD BE UTILIZED IN
TERMS OF THE DECISION PROCESS
FOR RENEWAL.
WHEN THEY COMPLETE THAT
PERFORMANCE OUGHT --
TO WILL --
YOU IN YOUR UPDATING YOUR AUDIT
REPORT BACKED --
ANY OF THE CONCLUSIONS THAT --
ARE ENGAGED IN THE DISCUSSION OF
YOU AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS TO
SEE WHAT THEY'RE RECOMMENDING.
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU WILL DO
THAT YET YES TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE IS OVERLAP IN FACT THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT THAT. FOR WHICH EDUCATION
IS DIRECTLY RESPONDED THAT AS A
RESULT OF THEIR PERFORMANCE ON
IT.
THEY WILL THEN CONSIDER --
WHAT TYPES OF CHANGES THAT NEED
TO BE MADE BASED ON A
RECOMMENDATION SO WE WILL WOULD
DEFINITELY LOOK AT THAT TYPE OF
CHANGE?
CERTAINLY OF THEIR PERFORMANCE
AUDIT ADDRESSED ANYTHING ELSE
THE REPORT FOR WHICH FORESEES IS
RESPONDING WE WOULD WANT TO
FACTOR THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
AS WELL IN TERMS OF ANY ACTION
FOUR SEASONS TAKING AS A RESULT
OF THAT ON IT [inaudible]
I THINK.
SENATOR OF IF I MIGHT ADD.
UP COUPLE OF A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS RELATED TO THEIR
CONTRACT EDUCATIONS OVERSIGHT OF
CONTRACTS --
WE DISCUSSED IN THE AUDIT REPORT
THEY DO RELY ON THAT ON
INDEPENDENT AUDITS THAT ARE DONE
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO LOOKING
AT ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
THE CONCERN WE HAVE WITH THAT OR
I PERSONALLY WOULD HAVE AND
BASED ON WHAT WE SAY IN THE
REPORT IS A LOT OF TIMES AN
INDEPENDENT AUDITOR THAT'S HIRED
BY.
A NONPROFIT IS DOING A VERY HIGH
LEVEL REVIEW.
OF ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS SO
THEY'RE GONNA LOOK AT THE BIG
DOLLAR AMOUNTS AND MAY NOT
NECESSARILY DRILL DOWN TO THE
SMALLER AMOUNTS LIKE WE IDENTIFY
WHAT EDUCATION SHOULD BE DOING.
IS LOOKING AT THOSE INDEPENDENT
AUDITS AND THEN DETERMINING
WHETHER OR NOT THEY NEED TO
DRILL DOWN DEEPER PART OF A A
DETERMINATION WOULD BE.
A RISK ASSESSMENT SO FOR EXAMPLE
AS MISTER LEE INDICATED THERE
WAS A PRESCHOOL CONTRACT THAT
THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
INTENDED PUT ON CONDITIONAL
STATUS.
FORESEES DECIDED TO JUST
TERMINATE THEIR CONTRACT TO
AVOID THE SCRUTINY THAT THAT
MEANT ALL OF THEIR CONTRACT
WOULD HAVE BEEN ON CONDITIONAL
STATUS WHICH MEANT MORE
OVERSIGHT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE OR I THINK
ANY REASONABLE PERSON THAT
RAISES A RED FLAG THERE
SOMETHING THAT FORESEES IS
CONCERNED ABOUT SO IF I WERE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IF IT
WERE OUR RESPONSIBILITY WE'D SAY
WE NEED TO GET INTO THIS ENTITY
AND REALLY DRILL DOWN AND LOOK
DEEPER.
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT WE HAD.
RELATED TO SOME OF THEIR
CONTRACT MONITORING AS THEY GO
OUT AND THEY LOOK AT SOME OF
THESE CONTRACTS AND DETERMINE
THEIR RISK THEY'RE COMPLYING
WITH CERTAIN TERMINOLOGY.
BUT WHEN MY STAFF SAID SHOW ME
THE EVIDENCE THAT YOU USED TO
REACH THAT DETERMINATION THEY
DON'T CAPTURE THAT EVIDENCE NOW
THEY MAY NOT NECESSARILY HAVE TO
DO IT FOR EVERY SINGLE.
ELEMENT THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
BUT AT LEAST A SAMPLE OR A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF DOCUMENTATION
SO THAT.
AND ID SOMEONE SEPARATE FROM THE
REVIEWER CAN LOOK AT THAT AND
SAY YES WE'VE DONE OUR DUE
DILIGENCE IN DETERMINING WHETHER
OR NOT THEY ARE IN COMPLIANCE
FOR SEIZE OR ANY OTHER NONPROFIT.
THAT HAS A CONTRACT WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SO THOSE
TWO THINGS THE THIRD THING THAT --
IS I THINK OF CONCERN IS A PART
OF EDUCATION IS AWARE THERE ARE
ISSUES WITH FOUR SEATS THEY
STARTED THIS AUDIT IN MARCH OF
SEVENTEEN THEY'RE NOT GONNA
FINISH THIS AUDIT UNTIL
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THAT'S EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
SO WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
DEPARTMENT I WOULD WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN A
HIGH PROFILE.
VERY CONCERNING ISSUE THAT THEY
WOULD GET IN THERE.
REALLY DETERMINE WHAT THEIR
SCOPE SHOULD BE WHICH THEY HAVE
DETERMINE THEIR SCOPE BUT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS IS A LONG TIME --
TO COMPLETE AN AUDIT OUGHT TO
GET THE RESULTS TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT YOU WANT TO RENEW WHETHER
YOU WANT TO PUT THIS SPENT AND
IT THIS CONTRACT ON
CONSTITUTIONAL STATUS SO SORT OF
THING SO.
YEAH IT'S OUR BELIEF THAT
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION NEEDS TO
STRENGTHEN ITS MONITORING --
IN A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT WAYS
TIMELINESS THE DUE DILIGENCE OF
DOCUMENTING WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING
AT AND THEN CERTAINLY DOING MORE
RISK ASSESSMENT AND AND
DETERMINING WHAT WE WE INTENDED
TO PLACE THEM ON CONDITIONAL
STATUS FOR THIS PARTICULAR
CONTRACT THEY DECIDED TO
TERMINATE.
THAT'S A RED FLAG SO THIS JUST A
FEW ADDITIONAL COMMENTS FOR YOU
SENATOR --
BUT CAN MISTER CHAIRMAN WITHOUT
DISTANCE BONTA REQUEST YOUR
COMMENTS --
DOES THE DEPARTMENT TIME THERE
AUDITS AND EVALUATIONS.
WITH THE CONTRACT RENEWAL
PROCESS SO THERE --
LINKED TOGETHER IN SOME WAY.
SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE
[inaudible]
CONTRACT AND THEN.
MAKE A DECISION ON THE CONTRACT
OR IS IT --
OUT OF SYNC YOU SAID IT TOOK
EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
OR WERE GOT IT WHERE WHAT WE
HAVE GOT TO REPORT YET SO WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW IT'S GOING TO
TAKE IT COULD TAKE LONGER --
POSSIBLY THEY MIGHT WANT TO
EXPLORE SOME OTHER AREAS SO.
I WOULD SUGGEST THEY GO PRETTY
DEEP INTO THIS [inaudible]
ISSUE.
BUT THEY'VE ALREADY MADE SOME
DECISIONS [inaudible]
ABOUT.
RENEWING --
GIVING US ADDITIONAL TIME FOR
THE CONTRACTOR [inaudible]
YEAH.
THEY HAVEN'T FINISHED THEIR
AUDIT.
IT'S BEHIND TIME RIGHT.
SO WHAT'S A NORMAL TIMELINE FOR
THESE KINDS OF STUDIES I MEAN IS
IT.
USUALLY TAKE EIGHTEEN MONTHS IS
THAT.
IS THAT UNUSUAL.
YEAH I MEAN AGAIN WE CAN DEFER
TO THE DEPARTMENT TO TO TO
ANSWER THAT THE THE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS --
ORDER STANDING WAS THE AUDIT
THAT WHAT THAT --
WE REFER TO AS IT IS A STE IT'S
A SPECIALLY AS A SPECIAL I
REQUEST THAT INTERNALLY
REQUESTED ON IT WITH IN
EDUCATION AS A RESULT OF
CONCERNS.
REGARDING THE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
AND SO THAT AUDIT WHO IS IS
SOMETHING THAT ISN'T NECESSARILY
RECURRING EVENT EVERY YEAR --
CONTRAST THAT WITH SOME OF THE
COMPUTER COMPLIANCE REVIEW WORK
THAT IS DONE BY THE PROGRAM
STAFF AS WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
IS MORE PERIODIC AND OR THE
CONTRACT ISSUES WHICH IS WHAT WE
REFER TO THAT WE COMPARE TO
GUEST.
IN OUR REVIEW SO THERE ARE THERE
ARE MULTIPLE METHODS IN WHICH A
REVIEW TAKES PLACE THE
DEPARTMENT AND CERTAINLY SPEAK
TO THAT --
BUT YET AS MICHELLE SAID THE THE
EIGHTEEN MONTHS FOR NOW IT DOES
SEEM LIKE A LONG PERIOD OF TIME
FOR PURPOSES OF OF THE TIMING OF
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH FORCES
POINT.
APOLOGIZE AND THEN I PROMISE I
WILL STOP.
SO WITH RESPECT TO THIS THIS
CONTRACT --
WITH FORESEES THAT WAS AND WHEN
WE ISSUED A REPORT IN APRIL
DEPARTMENT CATION GAVE NOTICE TO
FORESEES THAT THEY WOULD BE.
TERMINATING THE CONTRACT AND
THEN OF COURSE FORESEES APPEALED
WE RECEIVED SOME COMMUNICATION
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OCCASION --
THAT IT HAD WITH FORESEES BACK
IN MAY.
SAYING WHERE OFFERING
CONDITIONAL STATUS.
NOW FOR THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
CONTRACT JULY FIRST EIGHTEEN
MOVING FORWARD BUT THERE WOULD
BE AN ADDENDUM THAT WOULD CITE
THE CONDITIONS WHAT SPECIFICALLY
LAY OUT THOSE CONDITIONS.
A STAFF JUST GAVE THIS TO ME
THIS MORNING TO RECEIVE IT FROM
EDUCATION LAST NIGHT.
THAT ADDENDUM HAS NOT BEEN
COMPLETED YET AND THAT ADDENDUM
IS SUPPOSED TO HAVE ALL OF THE
CONDITIONS THAT FORESEES IS
SUPPOSED TO MEET TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO CONTRACT WITH.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
JULY FIRST IS NEXT WEEK.
SO AGAIN ANOTHER CONCERN THAT WE
WOULD HAVE IS THERE THERE WAS A
DECISION MADE IN MAY MAY FOURTH
IS THE DATE OF THIS LETTER.
THAT THEY WOULD GO AHEAD AND
OFFER CONDITIONAL STATUS WERE
PREPARING AN ADDENDUM THESE ARE
THE CONDITIONS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE IN THE ADDENDUM WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THAT YET I ASKED MY STAFF
THIS MORNING.
EDUCATION HAS INFORMED US AND
AGAIN WILL DEFER TO THEM WHEN
THEY PRESENT.
WHAT THE STATUS IS OF THIS
BECAUSE AS I SAID THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEARS THE END OF THIS
WEEKASO THIS CONTRACT I WOULD
ASSUME IS GOING TO GO FORWARD
AND CONDITIONAL STATUS?
WITHOUT AN ADDENDUM HAVING BEEN
COMPLETED AND PRESENTED TO
FORESEES WE WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN SEEING THAT.
CERTAINLY BECAUSE AS WE CONDUCT
OUR FOLLOW UP IN LOOKING AT THE
SIX MONTHS WE WOULD WANT TO SEE
THIS AND DETERMINE.
OKAY WE'LL KIND OF OVERSIGHT ARE
YOU INTENDING TO PROVIDE.
ON BEHALF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE SURE THAT
FORESEES IS MEETING ALL THESE
CONDITIONS.
FINAL COMMENTS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SOME OF THANK YOU SENATOR UP AND
FRANKLY WAS HOW I DON'T MIND IF
YOU KEEP GOING ON BECAUSE OF THE
INFORMATION PROVIDING IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT --
AND BUT UNFORTUNATELY --
TO RESOLVE THIS AUDIT AND I
THANK ALL OF YOU --
FOR PREPARING AND PRESENTING IT
CONFIRM CONCERNS I KNOW THAT
SENATOR BELL AND I AND NUMBER
THE COLLEAGUES HAD.
A PARENTS BEING UNJUSTLY
TERMINATED FROM PROGRAM STATE
FUNDS BEING ISSUES PROVIDERS
BEING PAID LATE.
AND UP A PATTERN OF EITHER NOT.
ANSWERING --
QUESTIONS OR NOT SUBMITTING
FORMS ON TIME AND THIS IS A
TROUBLING TO SAY THE LEAST.
AND THESE ARE ISSUES THAT ARE
SUSPECT CHILDREN BUT THE
FAMILIES FAMILIES ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE IN.
A ONE OF THOSE EXPENSIVE PLACES
TO LIVE AYE IN THE NATION.
SO I'M I'M THANKFUL --
THAT THE THE AUDIT OF THE
AUDITOR'S OF LETTER OF JOB.
IS SHOULDN'T TAKE A STATE OUGHT
TO DO THIS BUT THAT'S WHY THIS
CAN EXIST BECAUSE SOMETIMES ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE.
I YOU NEED.
TO LOOK.
AT LEAST GET SOME QUESTIONS
ANSWERED [inaudible]
I WITH YOUR LAST COMMENTS YOU
KNOW -- WITH
FOUR SEASONS NEW RECEIVING FOR
FUNDING AGAIN AND AS SOUNDS LIKE
THIS ADDENDUM --
THAT WAS JEWS LIVE PERSISTS.
NOT BEEN SUBMITTED AND CAN YOU
ELABORATE A LITTLE MORE S. WHAT
THE DENIM SHOULD INCLUDE --
IF.
CONSIDERING A CONDITIONAL STATUS.
I HAVE STAFF MIGHT BE ABLE TO
HELP ME BUT I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THEY INTEND TO PUT IN.
THE THEY CONDITIONAL Y. AND THEN
DOES AUDITOR WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE.
SEE WHAT WHAT WOULD YOU WHAT
WOULD YOU CAN WATER TO BE.
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE NATURE OF
THE HOT IN THE WORLD BUT I THINK
I THANKS HOPEFULLY MUCH OF WHAT
WE SUGGESTED IN OUR AUDIT REPORT
AS FAR AS MAKING SURE THAT
FORESEES HAS PROPER CONTROLS
THAT THERE ISN'T BACKDATING
OCCURRING.
THAT THEY DO HAVE APPROPRIATE
PROTOCOLS WITH RESPECT TO MAKING
SURE PROVIDERS ARE PAID ON TIME
IN SOME CASES PROVIDERS ARE
FAMILY MEMBERS AND THAT REALLY
HAS.
CAUSED HARDSHIP --
SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES RELATED
TO MAKING SURE THAT THEIR
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS ARE
PROPERLY DOCUMENTED THAT THEY
ARE.
PROVIDING TRAINING TO THEIR
STAFF ORIENTATION WE DIDN'T SEE
ORIENTATION PLANS FOR NEW STAFF
WHO ARE BEGIN WORKING AT
FORESEES.
WE WOULD WANT TO SEE --
BOARD MEMBER INPUT FAMILY MEMBER
INPUT REALLY BEING CONSIDERED
NOW THEY'RE ASSERTING ITS BEING
CONSIDERED BUT WE DON'T SEE ANY
EVIDENCE AND AUDITOR'S SHOW ME I
NEED TO SEE THE EVIDENCE.
SO A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDIT REPORT I
WOULD THINK WOULD HAVE TO BE IN
THIS CONDITIONAL --
THIS ADDENDUM THAT THAT LAYS OUT
THE CONDITIONS FOR CONTINUING TO
RECEIVE STATE FUNDING.
AND OTHER THE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
THAT WAS.
TERMINATED I AND I AGREE I I I
THINK THAT IT IS ABOUT FLAG THAT --
TO AVOID FURTHER SCRUTINY.
I'M YOU KNOW [inaudible] EIGHT
DAYS.
CERTAINLY HAVE A RIGHT NOT TO
EXPLAIN THEMSELVES BUT
INFERENCES.
YOU MADE AND I THINK THAT IT
WOULD BE A WELCOMED HIM I'M SURE
THEY'LL HAVE ANSWERS SOON --
HOW MANY?
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY FAMILIES --
MORE AFFECTED BY TERMINATION THE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM --
SO WE CAN GET YOU THAT NUMBER
YEAH GREAT THANK YOU --
AS THE SENDER INDICATED THE
MISUSE OF FUNDS AND SOME OF THAT
PREVIOUSLY SERVED ON RETIREMENT
BOARD IN CITIES SALAS A
EXTREMELY TROUBLING --
BUT THAT THE CLIP FIDUCIARY DUTY --
THAT BE HOLD DEAR IN AND THOSE --
POSITIONS OF RESPONSIBILITY --
ANOTHER TIE IN THE THESE ARE
RETIREMENT FUNDS THAT HARD
WORKING PEOPLE ARE RELYING ON
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE'S
ALREADY DID THAT ARE ARE ALWAYS
DEBATES ON THEM. FOR NGHE
PENSIONS AND ALL THAT AND THEN
THE QUESTION HOW WE CAN STATE.
CAN SURVIVE IN RETIREMENT AND
AND LIVE OFF OF IT AND SO TO BE
TO MISUSE RETIREMENT FUNDS IN
THAT NATURE --
IS EXTREMELY TROUBLING AND THERE
THERE WAS INDICATION I THINK I I
SOUGHT I THINK BY OCTOBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT THE MONEY WOULD BE
A LOT OF OF A RECOMMENDATION THE
MONEY BE TRANSFERRED OUT OF THE
RESTRICTED FUNDS.
INTO A MORE.
BEARABLE FUND FOR THOUGH THE
WORKERS TERMS SECURITY NINE TO
BE THERE FIFTEEN YEARS TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS IT WITHOUT BE IS
ALL THAT.
HAS NOT BEEN DONE OR DO YOU KNOW
THAT'S GOING TO BE DONE HAVE YOU
HAD ANY WORD ON THAT.
GOTTA IN IN --
FORESEES RESPONSE INDICATED THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO LOOK INTO ONCE THEY
DETERMINE HOW THE PLAN IS GOING
TO EVOLVE.
OKAY LED THAT WHEN THE DOW WAS
IN OCTOBER EIGHTEEN WITNESSES SO
SOMETIME FOR THEM DIRECT COMPLY
WITH THAT --
AND YOU KNOW THE THE BACTERIA
TERMINATION NOTICES THOUSANDS OF
THEM -- IF
WAS.
A FEW DOZEN THAT BE ATTRIBUTED
TO A CERTAIN EMPLOYEE JUST YOU
KNOW TRYING TO COVER THEIR
PERSONAL TRAXXAS ONE THING.
BUT I THINK THIS CLEARLY
INDICATES A PATTERN --
AND WHEN YOU HAVE A PATTERN THAT
YOU HAVE TO LOOK TO SEE WHAT
OTHER THERE'S A POLICY.
AND THAT THEY'RE NOT EXPLAINING
IT I'M IT WOULD BE INTERESTING
AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE ANY OF
THE WORKERS ARE ACTUALLY WE'RE
DOING THE DATA ENTRY SPOKEN TO
ORIGINS.
WELL AS AUDIT.
COMMUNICATIONS STRICTLY WITH
MORE HIGHER LEVEL.
MANAGEMENT SUPERVISOR PHOTO AS
IT WAS IT WAS WITH THE
MANAGEMENT A SIP AND SUPERVISORS --
IN TERMS OF INQUIRING ABOUT THE
PROCESS SEASON THEN EXPLAIN TO
US WHAT WHAT THEY DID WHAT THE
PROCESS WAS AND AND IN THE CASE
OF WHEN WE INQUIRED SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE THE CAUSE AND SOURCE
WE BY DATE COULD NOT PROVIDE ANY
INFORMATION ON SO THAT SO NO
WORKERS RISKS.
TALK TO THAT.
MAY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SAY IT WAS
A POLICY IN PLACE OR NOT THAT
THEY'RE INSTRUCTED TO DO
SOMETHING OF THE OTHER THAT'S
THE SIDE THAT WASN'T.
THAT WASN'T TO DIE UNDER IS PART
OF THE AUDIT THAT'S GREAT
[inaudible]
I'M. FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVEN
TERMINATION NOTICES SENT AFTER
AN APPEAL DATE.
AFTER AN APPEAL DATE IMAGINE
BEING A FAMILY MEMBER OF A
FAMILY IN AFTER AN APPEAL DATE.
SHE IS IS JUST STUNNING TO ME
[inaudible]
I'M.
THE L. A THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IN CASE SAID THEY
BELIEVE THE PILLS PROCESS JUST
FINE AND THE WAY THAT NOTICES
GIVEN IS FINE THE WAY IT IS.
YEAH EITHER THAT THE EDUCATION
HAS INFORMED US THAT THAT --
THE CONTRACTS TO THE CONTRACTS
WITH THE WITH THE CONTRACTORS
INCLUDING FORESEES STIPULATES
THAT ABOUT FORESEES ANOTHER
CONTRACTORS HOW THE BILL PROCESS
IN PLACE AND THAT THEY ENSURE
THAT --
FAMILIES ARE NOTIFIED IN ARE
INFORMED OF THE PROCESS THE
CONCERN WE HAD WAS.
YOU KNOW AT IT AS IT MULTI STEP
PROCESS FAMILIES GO TO FORESEES
FIRST TO TO APPEAL IF THEY ARE
NOT SATISFIED WITH THE WITH THE
OUTCOME THEY CAN GO TO EDUCATION --
WE FELT THAT EDUCATION NEEDED TO
BE MORE FIRM IN TERMS OF IN
INFORMING AND VERIFYING THAT
CONTRACTORS WERE DOING THAT IN
PLACE THAT HAD SYSTEM IN PLACE
THE COMMUNICATION EXISTED THAT --
A CONTACT INFORMATION INCLUDING
TELEPHONE NUMBERS AND AND
OUTREACH COULD BE DONE IF
FAMILIES --
HAD THAT ISSUE THAT NEEDED TO BE
PROP FOURTH EDUCATION THE FACT
THAT THERE WERE NO APPEALS
RAISED A RED FLAG IN OUR MIND
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT YOU KNOW
THAT PROCESS --
THAT PROCESS CERTAINLY WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL AND CERTAINLY
COULDN'T CAUSE ANY HARM FROM
THAT STANDPOINT OF GREATER
AWARENESS.
I THINK IT THE ACT I THINK
THAT'S ANOTHER RED FLAGGED THAT
REALLY CREATES A PRETTY CLEAR
INFERENCE THAT.
I THE SYSTEM'S NOT WORKING IF
YOU HAVE ZERO APPEALS AND YOU
HAVE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
TERMINATED AND EDUCATION WAS
LYING ON AN AGENCY THAT'S
ALREADY SHOWN THAT IS VIOLATING
ITS OWN POLICIES LET ALONE STATE
POLICIES.
IT.
BUT UP TO END SO I BUT I MAYBE.
HAVE A DISAGREEMENT EDUCATION AS
TO WHETHER THE APPEALS PROCESS
IS APPROPRIATE IN THE WAY THAT
IT HAS --
THE END.
THE THE OTHER ANOTHER AREA THAT
I AND YOU AND A REYES CUTTING
EDUCATION IS THAT THIS
COMPLIANCE BUT NO EVIDENCE OR
DOCUMENTATION OF COMPLAINTS I
THINK THAT'S STEP LEAN AREA.
A A AND I'M IN AGREEMENT WITH
YOU THAT CAN YOU SOME TIGHTENING
UP BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'M THAT WAY
IT IT'S NOT A MATTER OF OF
DISTRUST US.
OF THE REALITY IS THAT A
PARTICULAR IS A PLACE TO
OVERSIGHT IN OUR OPERATIONS OF
THE AGENCY.
BEFORE SEIZE OR ANY AGENCY TO
OPERATEIN THE WAY THAT THEY CAN
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON SO THEY
KNOW THAT THAT THAT --
BECAUSE AGAIN YOU HAVE.
MULTI LAYERS MANAGERS
SUPERVISORS A PLACE WHERE YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
SINGLE DOLLAR THAT'S COME TO HIS
BEING SPENT RESPONSIBLY.
I SOBRE EDUCATION ON TOP OF THAT
TO NOT.
PRESENT OR OR KEEP DOCUMENTATION
AND JUST HAVE AN OPINION --
IT IS JUST IS NOT A MATTER OF
WHETHER YOU TRUSTED AGENTS HERE
TRUST THE DEPARTMENT IT'S THAT
LOOK WE ALL HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A PROPER OVERSIGHT
HOW WHEN WE HAVE.
A TAXPAYER DOLLARS BEING SPENT I
THINK IT'S EXPECTED OF US.
I'M ONE OF THE THINGS IN
COMMENTS ICMP SIXTY ONE IS A
DISAGREEMENT EDUCATIONS CLAIMED
THE INFORMATION ON THIS BILL
PROCESS.
IS OFFICIALLY AVAILABLE AND THEN
THE NEXT PARAGRAPH IN REGARDS TO
WHETHER THE TRAINING IS DONE
PROPERLY IS UNCLEAR TO US WHY
EDUCATIONALLY PARTIAL CONCURS.
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION AND I
SAW THE FORM THAT'S REQUIRED FOR
THE APPEAL AND I THINK THAT --
THERE'S DEFINITELY UP DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT HIS OUR FAMILIES
AREN'T FOLKS WITH.
LEGAL BACKGROUNDS ARE FOLKS ARE
FAMILIAR WITH APPEALS PROCESSES --
AND EMAIL JUST GOT ONE SHOT TO
APPEAL I NOW I HOPE IS OCCURRING
APPROPRIATELY WITH NEW
MANAGEMENT --
I THINK THAT THE THAT WE CAN
MAKE IT WE WANNA MAKE APPEALS
PROCESS IS SIMPLE AND CLEAR AS
POSSIBLE FOR THESE FAMILIES THEY
MAY LOSE THEIR BILL.
AND THAT'S BY WAY OF A PLAY HOW
THAT'S WHAT THE PROCESS IS
FORCED.
TO HEAR IT OUT OF BUT TO NOT
GIVE THEM A REAL OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAL MATA IN IN A WAY THAT'S
SIMPLIFIED I THINK I AM IS IS --
UNACCEPTABLE.
AND SO I THINK YOU FOR RAISING
THAT ISSUE AS WELL AND I'M.
ALONE UP UP UP HALL PLAZA
BECAUSE I HAD.
PRODIGAL ONE FROM LAST LONGER
BUT I THINK I JUST WANTED
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO YOU
AND TO THE COMMITTEE --
FOR FOR TAKING UP THIS ISSUE AS
WELL.
NO PROBLEM THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE CALL UP OUR
NEXT PANEL.
LET'S COOPER SECOND PANEL --
BETTER MONITOR I DON'T MIND IF
YOU STAY AT THE TABLE BUT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO SHIFT YOU TO THE
TWO YOU'RE MY RIGHT YOUR LEFT IF
YOU WANT TO STAY OTHERWISE YOU
CAN RUN.
AND WILL CALL UP OUR NEXT PANEL.
THAT'S WHAT.
THAT'S PERFECT [inaudible]
YOUR CHOICE.
OUR NEXT PANEL.
JOSEPH MAN RANG IF I PRONOUNCE
THAT CORRECTLY IF NOT YOU CAN
CORRECT ME [inaudible]
WILLIE BROWN.
AND GERALD RITUALS.
SPEAKER WE COULD TRADE PLACES
[inaudible]
NOT REALLY.
GENERAL IF YOU WOULD IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD AND
FOR YOUR WHO WAS DISARM WILLIE
BROWN [inaudible]
REPRESENTING FORESEES.
CURRENT LEADERSHIP IT FORESEES
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US SIR.
GERALD RITUAL SAN ALSO AN
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING FORESEES
INDIA CURRENT OVERSIGHT MATTER
STRETCHED AND THINK JOINING US
GOOD MORNING --
JOSEPH MENTORING AND INTO A
MUSICAL DIRECTOR FOR FORCE
MANNER THANKS WHICH RUNS YOU MAY
PROCEED [inaudible]
THE BUSINESS OF OPERATE IN
[inaudible]
AN AGENCY.
AS IS THE CASE WITH FORESEES.
IT'S ONE OF HOPEFULLY. TWO ONE
SERVICE. FOR A GROUP OF PEOPLE.
IN A NEIGHBORHOOD LINE A
COMMUNITY.
THAT NEEDS IT.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE OTHER AGENCY HAS
[inaudible]
THAT.
CONTRACT WITH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS DO SO.
WITH THAT GOAL IN MIND.
BUT THE YEARS IN WHICH FORESEE
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE [inaudible]
THEY HAVE.
ATTEMPTED TO DO JUST THAT.
THEY'VE ATTEMPTED TO DO IT
[inaudible]
HOWEVER WITH [inaudible]
BOARD MEMBERS THAT ARE
[inaudible]
USUALLY BENEFICIARIES.
OF WHATEVER THE PROGRAMS.
HAPPENS TO BE.
LET THAT AGENCY IS SO DO.
ONE THEY DO IT WITH [inaudible]
WORKERS WHO ARE ALSO THE
BENEFICIARIES SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS.
AND IT IS.
AND NOT UNUSUAL FOR A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. TO BE
CONSISTENTLY PLAGUED.
WITH ALL KINDS OF AND
MISUNDERSTANDINGS AND AND OF
INDIAN ABILITY TO ACTUALLY AND
OUT OF UNDERSTAND [inaudible]
THE REQUIREMENTS THE AGENTS AS A
GOVERNMENT ARE USUALLY
ESTABLISHED TO GIVE.
THEY HAVE SYSTEMS AND THE
GUIDANCE THAT THEY MAY NEED. TO
ACHIEVE OF THOSE GOALS AND THESE
AGENCY IS NOT A FUNCTION
[inaudible]
ACCORDINGLY.
AND HOPEFULLY FOUR SEASONS
FUNCTION IN THAT WAY.
AT EVERY STAGE WHATEVER THE
REQUIREMENT HAVE BEEN.
AND THE PREVIOUS PEOPLE RUNNING
FORESEES HAVE ATTEMPTED UP TO OF
COMPLY.
AND IN MANY CASES HAVE ASSUME.
THAT THEY HAVE COMPLIED.
HOWEVER.
IN MANY CASES.
OBJECTIVE EVIDENCE INDICATES
[inaudible]
AN ABSENCE OF EXPLANATIONS AN
ABSENCE OF VERIFIABLE
INFORMATION THAT SHOWS
[inaudible]
CLIENT.
UNDER THE NEW.
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT HAS COME IN TO PLACE.
SINCE MID YEAR.
A TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ON ALL
OF THE CLEANUP THERE'S TEMPTED
TO BE DOWN.
ALL OF THE COMPLIANCE.
IN EVERY WAY.
AND A POSITIVE WAY AND NOT IN
ANY WAY [inaudible]
OF DENIAL.
THE DESIRE TO CONTINUE.
THE LONG YEARS OF DISTINGUISHED
SERVICE THAT THIS AGENCY HAS
GIVEN.
OUR IN SPITE OF OF SOME CLEAR
WELL LAPSES AND OR BEEN.
ADDRESSED AND GOING FORWARD. FOR
SEASON TENDS TO RENDER THE
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED AND THE
THAT.
IN THAT COMMUNITY AND TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE THERE AND
HOPEFULLY.
WITH THE PEOPLE LA THEMSELVES AS
I INDICATED AT THE OUTSET
FORESEES IS ALSO.
BEGIN TO REACH OUT AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR BOARD MEMBERS
[inaudible]
WHO ARE SKILLED --
BEYOND A WHAT THEY HAVE
PREVIOUSLY EXPERIENCE IN TERMS
OF BOARD MEMBERSHIP.
AND THEY AND PAN AND EVERY WAY
OUGHT TO BE AND THE KIND OF
SERVICE ORGANIZATION.
THAT'S NEEDED OF FOR THE PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY WHICH THEY
DESIRE TO SIR.
MY TWO COLLEAGUES. ONE IS THE
INTERIM --
DIRECTED.
AND OF FORESEES WHO HAS.
BEEN THERE NOW.
FOR ABOUT LENT TENANTS TEN
MONTHS.
MODE HE'LL TELL YOU ABOUT HIS
BACKGROUND AND WE HAVE.
AND THEN MISTER RICHARDSON AS A
YOUNG LAWYER THAT CAN.
THE FIRM HAS A AS TO AND WORK
CLOSELY [inaudible]
WITH THE AND NEWT [inaudible]
LEADERSHIP.
JUST TO ENSURE ON A DAILY BASES.
THAT COULD HELP.
THERE IS COMPLIANCE WITH ON
EVERY REQUIREMENT.
STATE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON
ANY OF THE OTHER AGENCIES
[inaudible]
HAVE AS REGARDS TO THE
RETIREMENT [inaudible]
A PROCESS THERE IS AND AND LONG
GONE --
OPERATION.
INCLUDING --
SOME LAWSUIT ALL A LAWSUIT AND
MISTER RICHARDSON WILL.
BRIEFLY WALK YOU THROUGH THAT.
OBVIOUSLY CONCLUSIONS HAVE NOT
BEEN REACHED --
WITH REFERENCE TO THAT
PARTICULAR LAWSUIT --
BUT BEARS DECLARE HA INDICATION
OF THE ARE MORE OF THEM AND
AGGRESSIVE DESIRE BY.
OF THE CURRENT LEADERSHIP OF FOR
CITIES.
THE TO ENSURE THAT EVERY ASPECT
OF THE RETIREMENT PROGRAM LAW IS
ADAM.
BUT ADDRESSED AND IN AN
EFFECTIVE WAY FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
LOVE EMPLOYEES AND THEY
ANTICIPATED.
RETIREES IN THE BENEFITS THAT
WOULD BE OF SENT TO THEM
[inaudible]
V. EXCLAMATION.
WILL BE IN TWO PARTS.
WITH THE RETIREMENT PLAN THE
FINAL DISCUSSION AND HAS
INDICATED.
THE EXPLANATION ON THE
RETIREMENT SIDE WILL INCLUDE ALL
OF THE BUSINESS OF WHAT'S A
CURRENT IN THE LAWSUIT.
THE LAW OFFICES THAT REPRESENTS
FORESEES HERE WILL DO NOT
REPRESENT FORESEES AND THE HOT
RETIREMENT THE LAWSUITS IN THE
RETIREMENT CONTENTION.
THE THAT IS BEING DONE --
AT THE MOMENT.
A BY THE APPROPRIATE INSURANCE
[inaudible]
AREA.
FORESEES HAD WISELY YEAH
CONTRACTED WITH.
AND SECURED THE SERVICES OF A
PROTECT IN EVERY FASHION ALL
EVERY PERSON ASSOCIATED WITH
TRYING TO MANAGE THAT.
OF SYSTEM AND THOSE ISSUES ARE
BEIN HANDLE A BY THE INSURANCE
[inaudible]
OPERATION THE MOMENT IT THE
INSURANCE OPERATIONS EXPENSE
THAT MAYBE A DISPUTE SOMEWHERE
DOWN THE LINE.
BUT AT THE MOMENT OF THE
INFORMATION YOU CAN GAIN FROM US
LOW WILL BE SOMEWHAT LIMITED ON
THAT.
AND A BONE MAY HAVE EVERY OTHER
ASPECT OF THE AND CURRENTLY
OPERATION AND TERRIBLY AFFORD
THESE CAN BE ADDRESSED.
AND TO BE A PERSON WHO IS THE
INTERIM DIRECTOR WILL NOT SPEAK.
GOOD MORNING --
THE FEW THINGS THAT --
THAT WE'VE FALLEN ON THE ON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT.
AB PLUS MORE OF THOSE WERE
PRESENTED TO US BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
WERE THOSE OF THE FOUNDATION OF
THEIR DECISION TO PROVIDE US A
NOTICE OF ACTION. TO NOT TO
RENEW OUR THE CONTRACT. FOR THE
FISCAL YEAR.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WITH THAT
RESPECT.
AT THE CONCLUSION OF OUR MEETING
WOULD -- THE
CALIFORNIA DID AUDITOR'S EXIT
INTERVIEW AS YOU WOULD SAY.
WE CONCORD WHERE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE WORK RESOLUTE IN MEETING
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CORRECTIONS.
AND US SUCH AS PART OF OUR SIXTY
DAY RESPONSE WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED
AND CORRECTED MOST OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
WITH A FEW THINGS TO INCLUDE BUT
NOT LIMITED TO THE OF RETIREMENT
PROGRAM WHICH IS PENDING
LITIGATION.
A LAWSUIT THAT'S BECAUSE THE
MORE IMPORTANTLY UP WHEN I CAME
IN ONBOARD IN AUGUST OF TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN AT THE
REQUEST OF THE BOARD.
I HAD TO RE EXAMINE THE WHOLE
ORGANIZATION IN TERMS OF THE
ISSUES AND CONCERNS THAT IT WAS
GOING THROUGH.
A MAILING TO THOSE OF HOW IT IS
COULD DELIVER.
THE SERVICE IS THAT IT HAS FOR
THE PAST FORTY FIVE YEARS.
ENSURING THAT IT WAS COMPLY WITH
ALL THE ITS FUNDS.
RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT WE HAD
FIVE SECTORS OF OF CLIENTS
[inaudible]
SEC.
WE HAD THE CHILDREN [inaudible]
THE PARENTS THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS.
DOT DON'T STAKEHOLDERS AND
FUNDERS THAT WE HAVE FROM STATE
THE FEDERAL TO COUNTY AND CITY.
AND THEN OUR STEP.
WITH THAT IN MIND.
WE EXAMINE ALL THE THINGS THAT
WHERE.
WHAT TO WHAT WHAT --
OUTLINED BY THE THE FINDINGS
FROM THE STATE AS WELL AS IT
DOES THAT WERE PROVIDED.
IN IN THE CITIES CALIFORNIA PART
OF EDUCATION'S NOTICE OF ACTION
FOR US.
WE HAVE RESPONDED TO THOSE --
OUT [inaudible]
THE FINDINGS AND OUR DATA FILE
THE PROPER CORRECTIONS.
BUT CORRECTIONS IN LINE WITH
THOSE OF THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO FULFILLING
THOSE THINGS.
OTHER EARLIER STATES AS WE HAVE
COMMITTED.
TO BECAUSE WE WANTED TO SECURE
DICKON.
TING YOU'D SERVICE FOR OUR OUR
COMMUNITIES.
UP THE FEW THINGS THAT WE NOTICE
ON ON JOIN THE FIRST
PRESENTATION WAS THERE WAS THE
COMMENT OF THE SIX THOUSAND
KNOWS OF ACTION.
OUT OF TO CLARIFY THAT IN THOSE
OF ACTION.
CAN BE WITH ANYTHING IT COULD BE
A CHANCE OF EMPLOYMENT IT COULD
BE A CHANGE OF OUR CHILDREN
CHANGE UP HOURS.
BOB AND WE DID A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW OF ALL THE SIX THOUSAND
AND A IT WAS ONE OF THOSE A THE
RESULT OF THOSE WHO USE WERE
PRESENTED.
PART OF OUR APPEAL PROCESS TO
THE CALIFORNIA PROVOCATION.
WE HAVE YET TO PROVIDE THAT. TO
THE UP THE STATE AUDITOR'S.
IT'S ADDRESSING THOUGH FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS OF SUCH
[inaudible]
TODAY.
ARE WE WILL PROVIDE THAT NOW IN
TERMS OF TO ILLUSTRATE THE FACT
THAT DOES.
IT'S THOUSAND THOSE OF ACTIONS
WHERE COMPREHENSIVE BE
IDENTIFIED IN DETAIL.
AND A SUCH THAT INFORMATION WAS
PRESENTED TO THE CALIFORNIA
PRIVATE EDUCATION THE CLOCK
PROVIDE CLARIFICATION ON DOES.
GOD KNOWS OF ACTIONS INCLUDE BUT
NOT LIMITED.
TO CHILDREN AGING OUT.
UP PEOPLE MOVING OUT OF STATE.
IN ONE CASE A PARENT WAS
INCARCERATED --
IT AND OF MAINLY PEOPLE ARE
DECIDING TO MOVE OUT OF TO
ANOTHER COUNTY IN A SUCH.
BECAUSE OF THE CONDITIONS OF
PROVISIONS FOR CONTRACT FOR
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IF YOU'RE NOT
IN THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
A NEW AND DIFFERENT COUNTY YOU
HAVE TO AVAIL YOURSELF OF THE
SERVICES A CHILD CARE. FOR THAT
COUNTY.
SO THOSE ARE THE FEW THINGS THAT --
WE HAVE --
LOOKED INTO DURING THE TIME OF
FOLLOW THE AUDIT.
IF I MAY PROVIDE SOME
CLARIFICATION --
WE HAVE OUR DATA FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES FORMA FROM.
IT AND ALSO FROM A CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR'S.
THAT.
THEY WERE ASKING QUESTIONS. TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE --
ITEMS AND FINDINGS.
IT IS --
UNFORTUNATE FOR US THAT.
MOST IF NOT ALL OF THE
MANAGEMENT TEAM OUR NEW.
WE HAVE GREAT AN EXECUTIVE TEAM
UPON MY ARRIVAL. TO BE EXAMINED --
ALL THE SCUTTLED PIES IN THE
FINDINGS AS WELL AS THE
IMPROVEMENT.
BOB DOES THE MECHANISMS ABOUT
FOUR SO WE HAVE.
WE HAVE --
CREATED THAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
A DIRECTIVE COMPLIANCE TO LOOK
INTO THE WHOLE PROGRAMMATIC
ISSUES.
OF THAT WE WAS PRESENTED
[inaudible]
FISCAL.
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER.
AND THE SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR
PERSONNEL AND OPERATIONS.
SO WITH THAT WE ALSO HAVE A
LATER -- OF
OF BOAT MANAGEMENT.
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE THE MANAGERS
AND SUPERVISORS.
AND SO WHEN QUESTIONS IS ASK
ABOUT A PARTICULAR MATTER.
THAT WAS FROM THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
WE COULD OF CERTAINLY SAY THAT I
MYSELF WAS.
INCAPABLE OF ADDRESSING THINGS
THAT WERE NOT I'D I WASN'T PRIVY.
TO NO WAS I PRESENT DURING THAT
TIME.
SO A SUCH WE HAVE ALL THESE --
REALIGNMENT OF CO.
PRIORITIES AND PERSONNEL AND AS
SUCH -- MOST
IN MOST CASES DON'T THINK
PERSONNEL WERE NOT IN THOSE
POSITIONS. TO ADDRESS THOSE
QUESTIONS SPECIFICALLY AND WITH
CERTAIN COMPETENCE. ONE THING
THAT WE HAVE DONE IS
DOCUMENTATION THE RETENTION
ANTICS AB EXAMINATION.
AND OUT OF DOCUMENTATION.
WE WERE --
AWARE THAT IN SOME CASES WE
DON'T HAVE DOCUMENTATION.
AND AS WE POURED MORE TO THAT WE
FILED PARTS OF THOSE
DOCUMENTATION.
BUT IT WAS ALREADY THAT GOD WAS
ALREADY DONE.
AND AS WE START LOOKING FOR MORE
WHAT WE DID IS WE IMPLEMENTED
IMMEDIATELY IMPLEMENT.
A DOCUMENT IN A DOCUMENTATION
RETENTION PROGRAM TO INCLUDE BUT
NOT LIMITED TO A CHECKLIST.
GOING THROUGH A EACH SEGMENT OF
THE DEPARTMENT PRIOR TO SUCH IN
THIS CASE EXPENDITURES.
RIGHT TO SOME EXPENDITURES BEING --
CONDUCTED.
IT GOES THROUGH A BEVY OF LEASE
FOR PERSONNEL AND ULTIMATELY OF
MY SIGNATURE OR THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF OUR OPERATIONS
PERSONNEL TO APPROVE IT.
MEANING THERE'S A VETTING
MECHANISM --
BUT WITH SENATOR ROTH I SHARE
YOUR COMMENTS IN TERMS OF THE
AIRFORCE I TO SPEND.
TIME IN THE AIRFORCE AND I HAVE
BOTH FOLLOWED THROUGH TO WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED IN THE AIRFORCE
ABOUT INTEGRITY AND GETTING
THINGS.
PRIOR THOUGHT AFTER SUBSEQUENT
MY AIRFORCE CAREER I TO OF HAD
THE ESTABLISH MYSELF IN
FOLLOWING THROUGH THE THAT THE
PREMISE OF INTEGRITY.
BY SERVING TWENTY ONE YEARS FBI
HAS COUNTERTERRORISM
[inaudible]
SUPERVISOR.
SO I BELIEVE IN AND ESTABLISHING
THE INTEGRITY OF ANY
ORGANIZATION.
AND LIVE PORTS OF WHICH IS THAT
HAS TO BE A TAKEN OWNERSHIP FOR
EACH INDIVIDUAL.
AND THE WE BELIEVE IN MAXIMIZING
THE TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT IS
ENTRUSTED.
TO WE ARE COMMITTED AND RESOLUTE
IN THE FIDUCIARY OBLIGATIONS
POSSIBILITIES AND THE FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT FOR EVERY
NOT JUST FOR THE FISCAL
DEPARTMENT.
BUT FOR EVERY PERSON AN EMPLOYEE
IN THIS APARTMENT.
I AM COMMITTED AS LONG AS A TEAM
AND ORGANIZATION AND OUR
STAKEHOLDERS ARE COMMITTED IN
MOVING FORWARD.
IN IDENTIFYING AS MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO CORRECT.
THROUGH THE HELP OF THE STATE
THOUGHT UP --
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION TO THE
ASSISTANCE OF THOUGH.
OUR STAKEHOLDERS AND THE CA.GOV
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S WE
ARE COMMITTED. TO DO THAT AND A
SUCH A WE WE FEEL THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY NOW EXIST FOR US TO
CONTINUE.
THE SERVICE BECAUSE WE ARE
FOCUSED ON THE SERVICE OF THE
CHILDREN.
THAT IS WHAT THIS TANTAMOUNT TO
EXPULSION WE HAVE TAKEN
OWNERSHIP OF THAT MISSION.
AND THAT MISSION IS EMBEDDED
WITH US IN TERMS OF YES WE
RECOGNIZE WE HAVE ALL THESE
COMPLIANCE ISSUES.
WHAT DO WE DO WHAT ARE WE DOING
TO MOVE FORWARD AND CORRECTIVE?
ENSURING THAT WE COULD PROVIDE
THE SERVICE AND WITH WITH.
WITH THE THINK AND CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE ARE
COMPLIANCE.
WE ARE CONTINUALLY IMPROVING BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED.
IN DOING SO.
BUT IT TURNED OUT [inaudible]
TO I COLLEAGUES --
BUILDING ON WHAT OUR INTERIM
MANAGING DIRECTOR HAS --
DISCUSSED --
THE BACKGROUND OF FOR SEE IS
THAT THE AGENCY STARTED --
WITH ONLY A BUDGET OF FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THREE
EMPLOYEES BACK IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE THE PRIOR
MANAGING DIRECTOR WAS ONE OF
THOSE THREE EMPLOYEES AND
CONTINUED THROUGH UP UNTIL LAST
YEAR -- IN.
BUILDING THE ORGANIZATION
[inaudible]
I FORESEE.
WAS GREAT AT EXPANDING THE
AMOUNT OF CARE THAT WAS ABLE TO
PROVIDE TO THE COMMUNITY HOWEVER
[inaudible]
I WHEN YOU GROW FROM SUCH A
SMALL ORGANIZATION TO A
ORGANIZATION OF A HUNDRED FIFTY
INDIVIDUALS AND A BUDGET OF
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THE LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT REQUIRED
GROWS EXPONENTIALLY AND THAT
LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT WAS NOT BEING
MET -- THE
CURRENT MANAGEMENT HAS CREATED
AN EXECUTIVE TEAM WHICH INCLUDES --
MISTER MANNERING AT THE TOP --
DIRECTOR OF COMPLIANCE A
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS A CFO AND
THEN THEY ARE PROVIDED OVERSIGHT
BY THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
THE BORDER DIRECTORS INCLUDES
NOT ONLY STAKEHOLDERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY BUT
ALSO --
LOCAL ATTORNEY --
STAFF MEMBER FROM SENATE A
FACULTY MEMBER FROM SAN JOSE
STATE [inaudible]
IT'S NOW.
WE BELIEVE FORESEES MANAGEMENT
IS IN A POSITION TO BE MUCH MORE
PROFESSIONAL IZED --
A COMPLIANT WITH [inaudible]
THE BY.
REGULATORY AND CONTRACTING
ISSUES --
DOT HAVE BECOME APPARENT.
NOW TO ADDRESS CERTAIN SPECIFIC
ISSUES.
FIRST OF ALL OTHER MEANT CURRENT
MANAGEMENT OF FORESEES IS --
HOLDS ALL THE SAME CONCERNS IF
NOT IN GREATER REGARD.
REGARDING THE BACKDATING AND THE
BACKDATING OF NOTICES OF ACTION
IS OF CHIEF AND PARAMOUNT
CONCERN. TO EVERYONE AT FOUR C.
CURRENTLY.
I IN RESPONDING THEIR TO FORESEE
HAS CONTACTED IT SIDE.
I KNOW WHO WHICH IS A DOCUMENT
MANAGEMENT PROVIDER AND THE
SYSTEM BY WHICH THESE NOTICES OF
ACTION ARE GENERATED.
I AM KNOW HO ON ITS BACK AND HAS
LOCKED THE FIELD FOR THE DAY.
SO THERE IS NO ABILITY BY ANY
EMPLOYEE AT FOUR C. CURRENTLY TO
BACKDATE A NOTICE OF ACTION.
ADDITIONALLY FOR C. HAS.
MADE IT POLICY THAT ANY EMPLOYEE
WHO IS GOING TO BE BACKDATING.
IS GOING [inaudible]
TO FACE --
SOME MANNER OF CORRECTIVE ACTION
IF NOT TERMINATION --
IN REVIEWING THE PRIOR
BACKDATING IT IS.
FORESEES CONCLUDED.
THAT ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN BACKDATING
NOTICES OF ACTION ARE NO LONGER
EMPLOYED AT FORESEE [inaudible]
FURTHERMORE.
OF THE SIX THOUSAND NOTICES
FORESEE IS INQUIRED WITH NO.
THE GENERATOR REPORT OF EVERY
SINGLE ONE IN EVERY FEW THOSE
THOROUGHLY.
THEY'VE DETERMINED THAT
[inaudible]
OF THOSE. TWELVE HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT WERE NOTICES OF
TERMINATION [inaudible]
HOWEVER -- A
NUMBER OF THEM WERE.
THOSE REQUESTED BY THE PARENTS
THOSE OF PAGE OUT AND THOSE --
PARENTS MOVING OR RE
CERTIFICATION.
DESPITE THIS THERE STILL
REMAINED.
I SITUATIONS WHERE PARENTS WOULD
NEED TO BE PROVIDED THE FULL
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAL.
AND THAT HAS BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED
BY FOR C. AND FOUR C. SEEKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT NOT A SINGLE
PARENT IS GIVEN A SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME TO PROVIDE THEIR APPEAL
EVER AGAIN.
I IN REGARDS.
TO AS MR MANNERINGSAID IN
REGARDS [inaudible]
TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE.
I EXPENSES THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE --
THERE HAVE BEEN NEW PROCEDURES
THAT ARE REQUIRING.
EVERY PIECE OF DOCUMENTATION. TO
BE PROVIDED AND MAINTAINED AT
FOUR SEE --
AND SIGNED OFF ON BY THEIR
MANAGEMENT BEFORE THOSE EXPENSES
ARE UNDERTAKING.
AND THOSE CHECK LISTS HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED TO THE JAIL LACK.
SO THAT THEY CAN SEE AND PROVIDE
THEIR FURTHER COMMENT ON HOW.
WELL THOSE PROCEDURES ARE
MEETING WHAT THEY BELIEVE FOR
THE INADEQUACIES THAT FORCE HE
PREVIOUSLY HAD [inaudible]
LASTLY -- TO
DISCUSS THE RETIREMENT PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
I FOUR SEED PREVIOUSLY ENTRUSTED.
A FINANCIAL ADVISER TO PROVIDE
IT.
THE BEST ADVICE POSSIBLE. TO THE
EXTENT THAT.
THAT ADVICE WAS NOT.
AS GOOD AS IT COULD HAVE BEEN
FORESEE IS NOW SEEKING TO MOVE
THOSE RETIREMENT PROGRAMS INTO
AN APPROPRIATE VEHICLE.
CURRENTLY HOWEVER THERE IS A
LAWSUIT UNDER THE ORISSA --
BASED ON THOSE VERY SAME
CONCERNS. FOUR SEED DOES NOT.
IS CURRENTLY LOOKING TO
DETERMINE THE MANNER IN WHICH
YOU CAN MOVE THE RETIREMENT
PROGRAMS OUT OF THE RESTRICTED
SECURITIES [inaudible]
IN -- TWO A
MORE TRADITIONAL FOR ONE QUE
TYPE PLAN THAT CAN BE ACCESSED
WITHOUT.
RESTRICTION BY THE BY ITS
EMPLOYEES --
FOR SEE BELIEVES THAT THAT CAN
BE ACCOMPLISHED WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FEE TO THE EMPLOYEES --
AND BELIEVES THAT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT.
OF FUNDING MECHANISM THROUGH ITS --
THE FORFEITURE FUND --
FROM.
NON VESTED EMPLOYEES.
I WHO HAVE LEFT THE COMPANY --
HOWEVER. FOR C. YOU WOULD LIKE
TO DO THIS IN CONJUNCTION WITH
ITS.
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR COUNSEL --
AND DOES NOT WANT TO CONTINUE TO
UNILATERALLY.
MOVE WITHOUT IN PLACE FROM THEIR
EMPLOYEES THEIR POLICE COUNCIL
AND ADVICE FROM THEIR OWN EXPERT
ATTORNEYS ON THE MATTER --
FOR C. ANTICIPATES THAT IT WILL
BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THIS.
BY THE TIME SET FOR OCTOBER BY.
THE J. LACK [inaudible]
LASTLY --
FORESEES CONTINUED FUNDING IS TO
BE.
PREMISED ON AN ADDENDUM OF
ADDITIONAL CONTRACTING TURN. FOR
C. LOOKS FORWARD TO RECEIVE IN
THOSE.
AND IS COMMITTED.
TO ARE IMPLEMENTING ALL OF THOSE
TERMS IN COMPLYING WITH THEM TO
THE FULL EXTENT.
ONCE THEY ARE PROVIDED
[inaudible]
LASTLY.
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE THAT
THE CURRENT MANAGEMENT EXECUTIVE
TEAM.
OF FOUR C. IS COMMITTED FULLY TO
PROVIDING THE BEST LEVEL.
OF SERVICES TO THE COMMUNITY AND
IS LOOKING TO MAKE SURE AT THAT.
FORESEE CONTINUES [inaudible] TO
MAINTAIN [inaudible]
IT'S CARE --
THAT IT'S PROVIDED SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE AND HAS
MADE.
GREAT STRIDES IN THE LAST --
HALF OF THE YEAR TO IMPLEMENT
THOSE NEW.
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES. TWO
MORE PROFESSIONAL ICE
ORGANIZATION [inaudible]
AND COMPLY WITH THE STRIP THIS
LEVEL OF COMPLIANCE IN OVERSIGHT.
THANK YOU SO DOES FOR MAKING IT
CLEAR SO IT'S IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING BASED ON YOUR
TESTIMONY THAT NONE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE INVOLVED
AND THE BACKDATING INCIDENTS
THIS THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SITUATIONS ARE CURRENTLY
EMPLOYED BY THE ORGANIZATION. TO
THE EXTENT.
THAT WEEKEND.
APPROPRIATELY AND ACCURATELY
JUSTIFY THOSE WHO WERE
RESPONSIBLE [inaudible]
THEY'RE GONE [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
WE WE KNOW MOST OF THEM ARE GONE
AND MAYBE ALL OF THEM.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS THIS.
IN MY EXPERIENCE [inaudible]
INTEGRITY DEFICIENCIES CAN BE
INFECTIOUS WITHIN AN
ORGANIZATION.
YOU'VE ESTABLISHED A CREATED A
DIRECTOR OF COMPLIANCE POSITION.
YOU HAVE ESTABLISHED
DISCIPLINARY RULES PRESUMABLY
THE PROHIBIT.
PACIFIC CONDUCT BACKDATING --
YOU HAVE ENSURE THAT YOUR
SYSTEMS ARE AS FOOL PROOF I
SUPPOSE YOU CAN MAKE A SYSTEM
WITH RESPECT TO BEING ABLE TO GO
BACK IN AND BACKDATERS CHANGE
SHOULD DATE IN OTHER WORDS.
ENGAGE IN CONDUCT THAT.
MOST WOULD CONSIDER MISCONDUCT.
WHAT ACTIONS HAVE YOU TAKEN OR
ARE YOU PLANNING TO TAKE? TO
INFLUENCE THE OVERALL CULTURE IN
THE ORGANIZATION TO ENSURE THAT
AS YOU TESTIFIED AND I SPOKE.
INTEGRITY IS A PRIORITY WITHIN
YOUR BECAUSE THAT'S A CULTURE
SHIFT [inaudible]
AND IT.
TAKES MORE THAN A DIRECTOR OF
COMPLIANCE AND IT TAKES MORE
THAN.
PUTTING ANOTHER SENTENCE IN YOUR
DISCIPLINARY POLICY TO PROHIBIT
SOMETHING THAT SOMEBODY SHOULD
ALREADY KNOW [inaudible]
IS INAPPROPRIATE.
THOUGH THAT'S A QUESTION
[inaudible]
THE THINKCENTRE.
CONTINUING ON THE TRADITION AND
EXPERIENCE THAT I'VE HAD AN
AIRFORCE LIKE YOU HAD. ONE THING
THAT WE'VE LEARNED THE AIRFORCE
IS.
TEAM THAT WE HAVE THE SOLDIERS
THAT WE HAVE THE OFFICERS SHARED
THE SAME MISSION AND TAKE
OWNERSHIP THAT MISSION.
IN MANY RESPECTS WE'VE HAD THE
MY OWN ACCORD AYE DIPLOMAT AT
LEAST SIX DIFFERENT KINDS OF
MECHANISMS. TO INSTILL THAT.
I GO AROUND TO COMMUNICATE TO
PEOPLE EVERY DAY.
MY PREDECESSORS DID NOT.
I SHARE THE MOTIVATION.
AND THE THE OWNERSHIP OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY.
OF EACH OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
I'VE LEARNED TO KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEY CAN
IMPROVE WORK SMARTER NOT HARDER.
THE OTHER THE THE OTHER PLATFORM
I DID WAS TO INSTILL IN THEM
THAT THEY ARE THEY'RE THEY'RE
QUALIFIED AND DEDICATED.
BUT THERE S. A RECOGNITION
MECHANISM IN THERE THAT WAS
ABSENT.
FURTHER TRAINING PROGRAMS YES
SIR THAT WAS THAT WAS THE OTHER.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE WE WE'VE
STARTED WAS A WEB IN OUR FOR
SCHOOL VISORS AND MANAGERS TO
LEARN ABOUT DIFFERENT SKILLS IN
TERMS OF MANAGING PERSONNEL
[inaudible]
HI MANAGEMENT.
DOCUMENTARY DOT RETENTION.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY ARE THERE
TO LEAD.
I ALWAYS USE THIS CONSULTATION
MANAGERS KNOW POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AND THEY MAKE THEIR
DECISIONS BASED ON THAT.
LEADERS ON A HANNAH OF THE HAND
THAT I'VE LEARNED IN THE
AIRFORCE.
THEY UNDERSTAND THOSE POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES AND MAKE THINGS
HAPPEN.
SO.
AS WE GO IN TRAINING WE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT SO MUCH
TRAINING IT DIDN'T IT DIDN'T IT
WASN'T LIMITED TO THOSE IN THE
STAFF.
IT WENT BEYOND THAT.
WE STARTING GAUGING THE
PROVIDERS GETTING THEM SO INPUT.
WE STARTED OUT WE HAVE THE EARLY
HEAD START POLICY COUNCIL WHICH
A UNDERSTOOD THAT NOW DO ROLES
ARE MORE INTEGRATED IN TERMS IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING MORE INPUT
THAT CAN BE.
AB WHAT OF THIS WE WANT THAT CAN
YOU DO THIS CAN YOU WORK THAT
OUT DID YOU HAVE WAS THERE
EVIDENCE BEFORE THAT THERE WERE --
EMPLOYEES WHO WERE QUESTIONING
THE BACK DATING BUT HAD NO
REVENUE TO COMPLAIN.
NO UNFORTUNATELY AND AND THAT
MRS SENATOR OUT WE WE COULD NOT --
PROVIDE SOME VERIFICATION AS TO
PART OF MY JOB WAS TO ALSO
EXAMINE SOME OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS THAT WAR INTERNAL.
UP FROM MY PREDECESSOR INTO
THOSE OF THE MANAGERS.
AND THEN IN THAT RESPECT THAT
WAS ONE THING THAT THE WE STRIVE
TO CORRECT IMMEDIATELY.
AND ENGAGE ARE A CONTRACTOR AND
VENDOR FOR THE SOFTWARE AND SAYS
WE NEED TO CORRECT IT
IMMEDIATELY.
AND THROUGH THEIR RESEARCH NUMB
IN A MATTER OF A WEEK THEY CAME
BACK AND SAYS.
WE COULD CLOSE THIS LOOP.
WE WILL CONTROL THIS WEEK
CLOSEST.
NOT THAT NOBODY COULD ACT BACK
DATED.
IT'S A SOFTWARE THERE SO BUT
THERE WAS NO THERE WAS NO
INDICATION IN A WELL YOU MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER SOME
ALTERNATIVE MECHANISM OF
COMPLAINTS SO IF THINGS ARE
GOING ON DOWN IN THE BELLS OF
YOUR ORGANIZATION SOMEONE CAN
BRING THEM TO YOUR ATTENTION
WITHOUT HAVING TO MOVE THROUGH.
DIFFERING LEVELS OF SUPERVISION
THAT MAY NOT IN FACT BECAUSE
OPERATIVE IN THE REPORTING.
YOU MAY RECALL IN THE AIRFORCE
WE HAD A THE CHIEF OF STAFF WHO
DID A BY THE NAME OF FOGLEMAN
WHO DID IT STAND DOWN WHEN THERE
WAS AN AIRCRAFT SHOOT DOWN AND
THAT WAS THE ORIGIN OF THE CORE
VALUES IN THE AIRFORCE BECAUSE
IT WAS.
THERE WERE SERIOUS INTEGRITY
PROBLEMS IN THE REPORTING ABOUT
THE REASONS FOR THE SHOOT DOWN
IN THE PERFORMANCE EVALUATIONS
ON THE INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED.
INTEGRITY PROBLEMS AND SOMETIMES
THE ORGANIZATIONS NATION NEEDS
TO BE LIFTED UP BY ITS
BOOTSTRAPS.
GIVEN A GOOD SHAKE.
A AN ORGANIZATION WIDE TRAINING
PROGRAM NOT JUST SYSTEM CHANGES
AND ENDING A SENTENCE TO A
DISCIPLINARY POLICY.
IT'S A CULTURAL ISSUE AND WHEN
YOU SAW THAT CULTURAL ISSUE I
THINK SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS OF
GO AWAY.
I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS I'M
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WAS A SAID KNOW
MUCH MORE ABOUT THIS AND I DO SO
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS --
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE OF I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WHAT WHAT IS YOUR CAN
YOU GIVE ME OVER ALL YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION.
MY EXPENSIVE JOKE PARSIFAL I'M A
FATHER OF THREE AND YOU IN MY
EARLY YEARS IN THE IN THE
AIRFORCE --
I WAS INVOLVED IN A LOT OF THE A
CHILDREN BECAUSE I WAS A
VOLUNTEER FOR THE U. THOUGHT
CENTER BACK IN THAT NO OVERSEAS.
AND AS SUCH --
MY EXPERIENCE AND TOOK OF
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
UP.
REVOLVES IN MY LAST SO SEVEN
YEARS IN THE AREA AND THE FBI.
S. NATIONAL CHILD ID PROGRAM
INTO HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND EXTRA
EXPLOITATION OF CHILDREN.
SO.
I MODE OF THE ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF AWARENESS AND TRAINING AND
THE BAY AREA WAS ONE OF MY MIGHT.
MY RESPONSIBILITIES IN ENSURING
THAT -- I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THE RECOVERY OF
KIDNAPPED CHILD VICTIMS OVERSEAS.
SO MY A LEVEL OF EDUCATION
CHILDHOOD GOES TO THE EXTENT OF
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW.
PEOPLE ARE HOW CHILDREN TO THEIR
ENVIRONMENTS BECOME INTO THE
DEVELOPMENT BECOME WHERE THEY
ARE.
AND AYE I BEEN INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND A CHILD THE
CHILD SOLDIER ISSUE IN TERMS OF
RADICALIZATION FOR CHILDREN.
SO IN TERMS OF EDUCATION I GOT
GOT MY EXPERIENCE MORE EMBEDDED
INTO.
THE APPLICATIONS OF OF INCIDENTS
AND ISSUES AND AS WELL AS
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WE COULD DO
PRACTICALLY IN TERMS OF
PRESERVING THE SAFETY SECURITY
FACTUAL SO YOU HAVE --
TO THE DEGREE AND I HAVE --
I HAVE INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS
THE GREEN MARKETING OKAY MEISSEN
FRENCH AND SPANISH BUT ALSO
ASSOCIATES IN ELECTRICAL
MECHANICAL.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY --
HAVING BEEN THE OLDEST OF A
CHILD I HELPED RAISE THEM MY
FOUR SIBLINGS.
AND AND MY EXPERIENCE IN THE
EARLY STAGES AS A BOY MUNITY
WHICH I STILL DO.
IN TERMS OF CHILDREN AND AND
SOMETHING IT TO THE EXTENT OF
FOR PROVIDING SOME FUNDRAISING.
FOR CONSCIENTIOUS FOR THE
NATIONAL CHILD ID PROGRAM WHICH
IS A FINGERPRINTING PROGRAM --
XIN ANY FOR SAID ABOUT THE
ATTENTION YOU KNOW CENTER I
WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
PENSION WHO REALLY OF LET HIM
TELL YOU THOUGH.
ABOUT HIS CONNECTION TO FORESEE
HOW HE CAME ABOUT TO BE THE
INTERNAL IT TO BE THE INTERIM
I'M ASKING A QUESTION EXCUSE ME --
I LIKE TO ASK YOU A QUESTION --
DO YOU DO YOU HAVE --
ANY INFORMATION YOU CAN GIVE US
ARM [inaudible]
REGARDING --
WHETHER OR NOT THE FORMER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HAS A ROLE IN
THE SUPPLEMENTAL RETIREMENT PLAN
AT THIS POINT AND WHAT IS THE
BALANCE OF THE THE BALANCE WE
HAVE IN OUR REPORT --
I THINK WAS AS OF A PRO.
MADAM AUDITOR WAS THE BALANCE OF
THE SUPPLEMENTAL.
RETIREMENT WHAT WAS YOUR DATE OF
THAT BALANCE YOU.
ARE YOU HAVE --
AND AND I WANTED TO FIND OUT TO
WHOM.
WHETHER OR NOT SO.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL PLAN --
WHAT THE BALANCE IS NOW AND THEN?
WHETHER OR NOT --
THE PULLED ACCOUNT HAS BEEN
SHIFTED TO A INDIVIDUAL COUNT.
FOR THE FORMER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR --
CAN YOU DESCRIBE ANY ACTIONS
TAKEN PLACE IN REGARDS TO THAT
UP UP FOR CLARIFICATIONS THAT --
SENATOR OUR FIRST QUESTION IS IS
THE FORMER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM.
HERE'S INVOLVED UP PROGRAM AS
PART OF HIS TIME IS SPENT YOU
KNOW NOW THE SECOND QUESTION
WITHOUT THAT OCCURRED ALSO THE
DANE.
IF YOU'RE IN THE TIME THAT I AM
I UNDERSTANDING ENROLLMENT THAT
HE IS PART OF THAT HE IS VESTED
IN THEIR THE QUESTION THAT WOULD
SING FOR ME IS ALL THE RECIPE
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THE FUNDS
YET WE HAVE NO FORMS TO THAT
INDICATED INDICATED THAT HE HAS
FILLED AMPLE FILLED THE FUNDS.
SO -- HAS
THOUGH.
IF IF HE HASN'T ROLLED HE IS A
RHODES.
BECAUSE AS OF THE REPORT.
WE GOT OF THE AUDIT REPORT IT
SAID HE HAD IT WRITTEN IN
RHODESIA.
THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING THE
QUESTION I SO SO.
I WANTED TO FIND OUT.
IF THE ENROLLMENT HAS TAKEN
PLACE ONCE THE AROMA TAKES PLACE.
THEN THERE'S A PROCESS --
TO CREATE A INDIVIDUAL COUNT.
THAT WILL BE DRAWN ON AT SOME
POINT -- IN
TERMS OF THAT RETIREMENT ACCOUNT
IS THAT CORRECT AYE I CAN
CLARIFY BY WEIGHING FIND OUT
WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THAT PLEASE.
THAT I CAN CLARIFY THAT STATUS --
I THINK WE ARE --
BUMPING UP ON A NOMENCLATURE
ISSUE HERE ENROLLMENT IN THE
PROGRAM OCCURS WHEN YOU NEED ALL
THE TESTING REQUIREMENTS DURING
YOUR EMPLOYMENT.
NOW TO AVAIL YOURSELF OF THE THE
THE FINES WITHIN SIX MONTHS OF
LEAVING EMPLOYMENTYOU NEED.
TO SUBMIT CERTAIN FORMS AND
CERTAIN --
CERTIFICATIONS AND NOTARIZED WE
HAVE NO EVIDENCE THAT HE IS.
SUBMITTED ANY OF THOSE AND IT'S
BEEN MORE THAN SIX MONTHS WE
IMAGINE THAT.
AT SOME POINT THERE MAY BE A
DISPUTE OVER WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S BEEN SUBMITTED.
BUT CURRENTLY.
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE THAT MISTER
VS IN YOUR HAS SUBMITTED ALL THE
REQUIRED FORMS TO BAIL
THEMSELVES OF THE RETIREMENT
ACCOUNT IN THE TIME FRAME THAT
IS SPECIFIED IN THE PLAN
DOCUMENT.
SO HERE'S HE ENROLLED IN THE OF
THE SUPPLEMENT IT WHAT IS THE
BALANCE OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL
COUNTY IS SO.
MAYBE YOU CAN PROVIDE OUR ORDER
WITH THE CURRENT.
BALANCE AND STATUS OF
SUPPLEMENTAL OF A RETIREMENT
ACCOUNT.
I DO WILL BE AGREED TO DO THAT.
WE WILL AGREE TO PROVIDE THAT
THE CURRENT BALANCE --
WITHIN THE COMING WEEK.
THIS IS WE CAN [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OBTAIN IT.
THOSE ARE MY QUESTIONS.
THE CAN SHARE.
AND THANK YOU FORUM.
THE YOUR COMMENTS UP IN STEPPING
INTO OBVIOUSLY A DIFFICULT
SIUATION AND SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU'VE DONE TO TRY.
TO RIGHT THE SHIP --
AND ON ON A COUPLE OF THINGS AND
I THINK WE GOT SOME OF THE
RESPONSES IN TERMS TO THE
TRANSFER OF FUNDS AND REALLY
THAT THE ISSUE THEREIN DOT
INDICATES MAKING SURE THAT FOLKS
MAY HOLD THAT THE FUNDS ARE.
UP UNIT THE UP TO WHATEVER
EXTENT --
THERE IS IMPROPER USE THAT THE
FUNDS ARE REPLENISHED TED.
SO I KNOW IT'S HARD RIGHT --
AND I THINK THAT WE CAN SAY THAT
OUTSIDE OF WHATEVER THE NEGATION
MIGHT BE HAPPENING THAT AT THE
VERY LEAST THAT AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS ONE THAT YOU.
AGREE WITH THAT THE VERY LEAST
US [inaudible]
KIND OF MUST START FEELING THAT
WAY YES WE WE WE AGREE WITH THAT
AUDIT RECOMMENDATION --
WE ARE INFORMED BY THE WRIST OF
COUNSEL --
THAT IS REVIEWING IT THAT THAT
IS -- A
POSSIBILITY AND WE ARE JUST
LOOKING CURRENTLY FOR THE
CORRECT AVENUE --
BOTH.
FROM A LEGAL PERSPECTIVE AND
FROM A FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE
[inaudible] TO ACCOMPLISH IT
FUNCTIONALLY.
UP I THINK AND YOU KNOW IN TERMS
OF THE ATTORNEY IT NOTICES --
AND I GET THAT.
THERE ARE I'M.
BUT THAT COULD BE LIFE FOR
REASONS WHY I NOTICE IS THEM.
IT WILL PUT OUT THERE --
IT COULD BECAUSE SO MANY EXOTIC
ABUSE BECAUSE SOME OF OUR STATE
AND WHATEVER BUT DOES THE POLICY.
INDICATE THAT THERE'S A
DIFFERENT WAR BASED UPON
DIFFERENT REASONS WHY.
SOMEONE ATE THEM UP.
SAW SOMEONE IS TERMINATOR GETS
TO ME AND OTHERS IN OTHER WORDS
HOW DOES IT YOU HAVE A PAUSE
BACK YOU HAVE A MORE GENEROUS
BOSS IN THE STATE. NINETEEN DAYS.
JUST SENDING IT IN NINETEEN DAYS
WHO CARES OF OUR PARENTS ACROSS
WRITER SOME OF THAT A STATE.
SENATE THEY'RE NOT AN APPEAL.
AND AND SO YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
THAT'S BEING MENTIONED IS THAT
HAS SOME WAY TO EXCUSE.
SOME OF THESE VIOLATIONS BUT NO
THOSE ARE EXCEPTIONS IN THE
POLICY THAT ALLOW --
FOR ó ALLOW FOR A SIDESTEPPING
THE POLICY [inaudible]
IT.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT --
THERE ARE NO EXCEPTIONS WE DID
THE FULL REVIEW TO DETERMINE THE
EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM THAT WAS --
AND THE HARM TO THE COMMUNITY AS
A RESULT OF THAT. FOR OUR OWN.
BUT BETTER MEET --
THAT BEING SAID.
I WHAT IT APPEARS MAY HAVE
HAPPENED IS.
THAT THERE WAS IN THE CORRECT
LEVEL OF MANAGEMENT OVERSIGHT OF
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
CONDUCTING THIS NOW THERE IS.
A OVERALL MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE
IN PLACE TO WHERE PEOPLE KNOW
WHO THEIR MANAGERS ARE THEY KNOW
THAT.
THOSE MANAGERS ACTUALLY DISCUSS
UP THE CHAIN IN THAT SHOW.
GETS INFORMATION IF THERE IS AN
ISSUE.
SO NOW YOU CANNOT BE
[inaudible]
A DOCUMENT ENTRY --
CLERK OR A MID LEVEL MANAGER
THAT GETS A BUNCH OF PAPER
STACKED ON THEIR DESK
[inaudible]
AND SCRAMBLES AND BACK DATES A
BUNCH OF NOTICES IF THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED OR IF THERE'S SOMETHING
MORE NEFARIOUS IT BACK THAT
SIMPLY [inaudible]
WON'T.
GO UNNOTICED ANYMORE EA THAT YOU
SAID THAT YOU LOOK AT ALL OF
THESE SIX THOUSAND AND SO YOU
HAVE CAN YOU PROVIDE US WITH.
WE COULD PROVIDE A BREAKDOWN YES --
AND TO SHOW EXACTLY WHAT KINDS
OF NOTICES THOSE WERE AND AND WE
ALSO HAVE ALL THE NOTICES.
I THAT WERE BACKDATED PRINTED
OUT IN A IN A DATABASE IN A
BINDER -- I
AT THE FOR C. OFFICE IN THAT CAN
BE PROVIDED TO THE THE AUDITOR --
YEAH I GUESS I'D I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT I THINK THAT --
MY UNDERSTANDING AT LEAST.
THREE HUNDRED CHILDREN.
HOW THEIR SERVICES TERMINATED --
THAT HAD COME TO THAT WEBER
THERE WASN'T AN AMPLE AMOUNT OF
TIME FOR APPEAL.
AND I WILL I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
CERTAINLY THE NUMBERS TO LEAST
AGAIN.
THE DOCUMENTATION IS CRITICAL UP
PARTICULARLY AS IT APPLIES --
TO DETERMINATION SERVICES TO A
CHILD [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
NOW.
IN TERMS OF LOOK AT THE I THINK
OUR CHAIR A PROPERLY SENATE SO
THAT YOU TALK ABOUT INTEGRITY
AND CULTURE IT ALWAYS WILL
CONSTRUCT THE TOP.
AND I'M ONE OF THE TROUBLING
ASPECTS IS THE LACK OF
DOCUMENTATION OF YOU KIND OF
BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING BUT IF
YOU DON'T ACTUALLY SHOW TO
ACTIONS AND OR THROUGH
DOCUMENTATION.
IS JUST WORDS AND WE KNOW THE
PRIOR EXACT DIRECTOR SAID THAT I
THOUGHT IT WAS A WASTE OF
TAXPAYER MONEY [inaudible]
AND THE REASON WHY THE AUDIT
OCCURRED WAS BECAUSE WORKERS
WERE COMPLAINING ABOUT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
AND YET THE THAT TIME AND AGAIN
WE WERE TOLD BY MANAGEMENT ALL
THE WORKERS ARE LYING JUST ONE
AND THEY'RE JUST TRYING TO PUT
LEVERAGE FOR THE NEGOTIATIONS ON
ON ARE NOT YET.
EVERYTHING THAT THEY SAID WAS
HAPPENING WAS HAPPENING.
AND SO THE REASON WHY I MENTION
THAT IS WELL FIRST OF ALL.
WERE ANY WORKERS THAT COMPLAINT
OR RAISED ISSUES FIRED
TERMINATED REPRIMANDED IN ANY
WAY HARMED.
BECAUSE THEY CAME FORWARD. TO
THE BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE NO.
BECAUSE THAT THE IMPORTANCE OF
FOUGHT THAT THAT STATEMENT IS IS
STILL.
IF SOMEBODY PROVIDES A COMPLAINT
AND IS NOT ADDRESS AND IS NOT A
DRESS APPROPRIATELY.
AND THAT INDIVIDUAL SHOUT WE
DAHLE TATE RETALIATED THAT IS A
SOMETHING OF THAT THAT WOULD GO
TO MY LEVEL.
AND TO GO TO THE LEVEL OF DOES
EXACTLY THAT MAKE YOU BUT YOU
WON'T PRIOR YOU'RE THERE.
AND AND I AND THE REASON I'M
ASKING YOU THIS BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTATEMENT GIVEN THEIR TEN
MONTHS AS INTERIM.
I THINK EUROPE CONSULTING FOR A
FEW MONTHS BEFORE.
BUT ANY LEADER THAT COMES AND IS
GOING TO FIND OUT WHAT THE HECK
IS GOING ON HERE HOW DID THIS
HAPPEN.
YOU KNOW --
SUITED YOU TALK TO YOU WHEN YOU
GOT IN THERE IS TALK OF THE
WORKERS.
DID YOU TALK TO THE ARMS ONCE
HATE ONE ON ONE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THIS PLACE
DID YOU.
DID YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO DO THAT
YES YES YES --
A YES OR A WEEK WE HAD THE I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE ONE
THING THAT I WAS AS AS A DO I
HAVE AN OPEN DOOR POLICY.
AND MY RESPONSE THERE'S NO
BECAUSE I HAVE AN OPEN DOOR
PRACTICE I'M GONNA WAIT FOR YOU
TO TELL ME.
THE PROBLEM AYE AYE GOAL TO YOU
SO IN THAT REGARD WHAT ONE OF MY
FIRST A OF RESPONSIBILITIES AND
ACTIONS WAS TO ACTUALLY GET TO
MEET ALL THE STAFF.
AND TO BE OUT THERE LOOKING AT
HOW THEY WORK AND WHAT THE
RESPONSE DID YOU EVER
CONFIDENTIALLY TALK TO SOME OF
US HAVE A WHAT HAPPENED WERE YOU
EVER HEAR.
ANYONE EVER THREATEN YOU DID
ANYONE EVER TELL YOU TO BACKDATE
DATA DID YOU EVER DO THAT THE
ABSENCE OF BY ASKING THEIR WITH
WHEN I WAS THAT I DID HAVE
CONFIDENTIAL.
CONVERSATIONS ON SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY PERCEIVE OR
HAPPENING IN THOSE WERE PUBLIC
CORRECT DID YOU DID YOU EVER ASK
AND HE THE WORKERS I AB OF I
THINK THAT WE HEARD THAT.
EMPLOYEES THAT WERE DETERMINED
TO HAVE DONE THE BACKDATING.
ARE NO LONGER WITH FORESEES.
BUT SO DOES THE ONES THAT ARE
DOING THE DATA ENTRY.
MY CONCERN IS THAT IT'S THE
WORKERS THAT WERE TERMINATED BUT
THAT IT WAS A POT MEAN YOU TOOK
MY THOUSAND WAS A POLICY IN
PLACE --
THAT IS DIRECTED FROM A
SUPERVISOR OR MANAGER LEVEL AND
YOU HAVE TO TALK TO THE WORKERS
TO FIND OUT IF THAT POLICY WAS
IN PLACE YOU EVER TALK TO ANYONE
IN COMP AND CONFIDENCE. TO FIND
OUT IF ANY OF THE WORKERS --
DIE THAT WERE TERMINATED OUR NEW
OF THIS PRACTICE WERE INSTRUCTED
TO DO SO BY.
A SUPERIOR NOT SPECIFIC FOR THAT
WAS TO IMPLEMENT A EXIT
INTERVIEW ASSESSMENT FOR ALL
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO LEFT.
AND WITH THAT REPORT THAT WE
JUST SAW HANDLED BY THE HR
DEPARTMENT WE WERE ABLE TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT WAS THE
REASON WHY SOME OF THESE PEOPLE
WERE QUITTING.
Y. WOULD BE LEAVING TO GO TO
ANOTHER DEPARTMENT WHAT WOULD
DEFINING OTHER JOBS WHAT WERE
THE REASONS WHY THEY LEFT THE
COMPANY.
AND WE WEEK WE DID THAT AND THAT
WAS PART OF OUR OUT OF HELPING
US ESTABLISH A RETENTION POLICY
TO INCLUDE BUT NOT LIMITED.
TO THE IT STAFF TRAINING.
DHEA STAFF RECOGNITION DUG
THOUGH THE STOP UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE IS A MECHANISM. TO TO
TO PROVIDE US WITH DATA YOUR
CONCERNS AND ISSUES AND AS SUCH
WE'VE HAD SITUATIONS WERE.
UP EMPLOYEES OF COME TO MEAN TO
DURING MY TIME AND HE SAID WE
HAVE THIS CONSISTENT STERN AND
THIS ISSUE.
AND A WHEN THAT WAS DONE
CONFIDENTIAL AND CONFIDENTIALLY.
AND WHEN I LOOKED INTO IT IT WAS
A PRO I CORRECTED.
AND WITHOUT GOING TO A DETAILS --
DOES --
INDIVIDUALS WERE --
CAME BACK TO ME SO THANK YOU FOR
ME THE CORRECT IN THAT THING
JUST -- IT
TOOK ME ABOUT THREE WEEKS TO
REALLY GET THE FULL
UNDERSTANDING OF HEALTH CORRECT.
AND I I WOULD LIKE TO BRIEFLY
FOLLOW UP ON THAT --
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE REPORT WAS TO CREATE A NOT
JUST TO CREATE BUT TO RE
EMPHASIZE THE POLICY OF NO
RETALIATION AND THAT IS BEEN --
CREATE A CREATED BY.
INCREASED IMPLEMENTED PROVIDED
TO THE JAIL LACKEY AND IT IS COR
TO THE NEW MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE --
THE EXECUTIVE TEAM WANTS TO KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON FROM IT'S FROM
ALL LEVELS OF EMPLOYEES AND
WANTS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE TAKE
ANY CORRECTIVE ACTION THAT'S
NECESSARY.
AND IS COMMITTED. TO NOT
RETALIATE AGAINST ANY EMPLOYEE
WHO AYE HAS ANY COMPLAINT
REGARDING ANY SORT OF COMPLAINTS
ISSUE.
THANK YOU AND I'M.
A LOT OF COMMENT ABOUT THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION LIKE THIS ALL
HAPPEN BEFORE PERFECT SEEN THIS
HAPPEN BEFORE REFUSING IT --
SIR YOU ARE APPOINTED BY AND
REPORT TO THE BOARD [inaudible]
THAT'S RIGHT [inaudible]
SO.
CONSIDERING ALL THIS HAPPENED
BEFORE --
ARE ANY OF THE SAME BOARD
MEMBERS ON THE BOARD THAT WERE
THERE.
IN THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION YES
[inaudible]
HOW MANY --
OR AND HOW MAY SERVE ON THE
BOARD --
RIGHT NO OF SEVEN OR EIGHT EIGHT
WITH ADDITIONAL NEW BOARD MEMBER
OKAY SO AT LEAST HALF OF THE
BOARD.
ARE THE SAME BOARD MEMBERS OVER
THERE -- BUT
IN BRITAIN THESE ISSUES WERE.
A PRETTY SEVERE ISSUES WERE
OCCURRING.
IF IF IF I MIGHT ADD.
DEED THAT THE BOARDS
UNDERSTANDING OF THE OPERATIONS
IS ONLY CLEAR ANSWERS THINK IF
IN FACT MY PREDECESSOR.
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION.
DAVID I AS A BUT INTO EXACTLY
DIRECT TO PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY
TO THAT PROCESS.
NOW IF I WOULD HOLD SOMETHING
THEN THEN THAT ONLY I WOULD KNOW
IT WITH THAT INFORMATION SO.
THAT ONE THING THAT'S TANTAMOUNT
TO THE PROCESS NOW IS
TRANSPARENCY AND THE AT THE DISK
THINK CLEAR UNDERSTANDING THAT.
IT'S TRANSPARENCY THAT WE SEE
AND IF I AYE INFORMED ABOARD AS
EVERY ASPECT OF THE OPERATION.
AND TOWARDS THAT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT I I DO RECALL
THAT DURING A AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE BOARD ONLY KNOWS WHAT
IT KNOWS.
BUT I'M AGAIN INTEGRITY STARTS
ATOP THE TOP ANDMY RECOLLECTION
ALLOWS IS RECURRING WAS AT THE
BOARD.
AND THE EXACT DIRECTOR --
WHERE ARE SPEAKING FROM THE SAME
TALKING POINTS AND SO I THINK
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL THAT WE
UNDERSTAND?
THE ROLE OF LEADERSHIP OF
EVERYONE INVOLVED NOT JUST YOU
ONE PERSON CAN'T COMING YEAR AND
DO IT ON OUR OWN --
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE CHANGE AND THAT THE
WORKERS ARE RESPECTED AND THAT
THE CHILDREN ARE CARED FOR IN A
WAY THAT WE EXPECT.
WHEN OUR MONEY IS COMING DOWN --
IT TOO TO SUPPORT THEM AND SELF
BUT BUT THANK YOU SIR BUT I'D
JUST LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON ON
THAT.
LAST RESPONSE --
THE BOARD HAS.
YEAH I SEEN A 50% TURNOVER SENSE
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION --
MAYOR BROWN I MYSELF HAVE
RECOMMENDED THAT ADDITIONAL
TALENT BE BROUGHT TO THE BOARD
AND THERE IS ACTIVE SEARCH.
FOR TALENTED NEW BOARD MEMBERS
HOWEVER AS YOU CAN IMAGINE.
THAT WITH A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THE SORT OF TIME COMMITMENT FOR
C. DOES FROM ITS BOARD MEMBERS.
THAT IT'S NOT ALWAYS
[inaudible]
THE FASTEST AND EASIEST --
SO TALENT SEARCH THE I I GET
THAT I'VE BEEN ON A NUMBER OF
NONPROFIT BOARDS IT'S THAT
CERTAINLY THANKLESS WORK IN MANY
WAYS.
I'M I WOULD SUGGEST THAT MAYBE
AN ACTUAL PROVIDER OR A PARENT.
I'D TO SERVE ON THE BOARD AS
WELL COULD PROVIDE PERSPECTIVE
THAT HAS NOT EXISTED IN
LEADERSHIP --
INSULIN ON THE BOARD IN THE TO
THE EXTENT I BELIEVE IT SHOULD
ATTACK YOU.
CENTERVILLE YEAH I JUST HAVE ONE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
ALL OF YOU --
COULD YOU --
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES IN SUSPENSE BY THAT.
QUESTION.
RELATIVE --
TO THE EMPLOYEE IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION.
HOW -- CAN
YOU GIVE US AN IDEA HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES YOU HAVE AT THIS POINT.
WE WE HAVE AN ESTIMATED FROM IT
FLUCTUATIONS SUMS UP APARTMENT
EMPLOYEES WE HAVE ANYWHERE FROM
ABOUT EIGHTY TO NINETY OR SO
WITH SO MANAGEMENT --
ABOUT FIFTEEN MANAGEMENT SAID ON
SO YOU HAVE LIKE IT OR NINETY
PERMIT A BENEFITTED FULL TIME
AND NOT NOT NOT ALL BENEFITTED
BECAUSE SOME OF MY AGENCY
TEMPORARY.
ATTEMPTS AS WE THOSE WHO SEEK TO
FIND A FULL TIME EMPLOYEES FOR
THAT HOW MANY OF HOW MANY OF AYE
GLAZER FIGHT DON'T HAVE THE ACT
WITH NUMBERS --
CENTER BECAUSE IT IT.
THE EYES OF LAST MONTH WE WERE
TRYING TO PUT TOGETHER THE
FLUCTUATING NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE
BECAUSE OF TIME HOW MANY --
PERMANENT SO --
FULL TIME --
EMPLOYEES DO YOU HAVE.
I DON'T I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
NUMBER LIKE SAID BECAUSE I HAVE
TO DEFINITIVELY DETERMINE IF
THEY ARE AGENCY TAPS ORDER
SWITCHING OVER TO A DISEASE THAT
WOULD YOU SAY WOULD YOU SAY THAT
SO.
A LARGE PORTION OR JUST A SMALL
PORTION OR TEMPORARY --
EMPLOYEES SMALL PORTION A
TEMPORARY EMPLOYEES THEN COULD
YOU GIVE ME THE INFORMATION
ABOUT -- THE
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES AND HOW MADE
A MORE FULL TIME VERSUS
TEMPORARY OR PART TIME.
THAT YOU LEAST LEASE PLEASE
FORGIVE ME BUT I WON'T HAVE THE
EXACT NUMBERS TO PROVIDE YOU BUT
I PROVIDE THAT TO THE COMMITTEE
CAN YOU HAVE THE AUDITOR MAYBE
FOLLOW UP ON THAT --
TO GIVE US.
THE INFORMATION ABOUT SO.
THAT INFORMATION TOOL WE
REALIZED THAT WE'LL SUPPLIED BY.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD I'D
PROBABLY.
BUT I'M BY MONTHS.
BUDDY HOW MANY PEOPLE EACH MONTH.
PLUS HOW MANY ARE THERE
[inaudible]
THEORETICALLY PERMANENTLY.
I LIKE TO SEE LIKE MAYBE THAT
MAY BE AN ORGANIZED OVERALL
ORGANIZATION.
CHART SO THAT WE COULD PROBABLY
DO IT FROM.
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
TO THE PRESENT DAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR GARMENT THANK
YOU.
NO PROBLEM --
WE'RE SIGNIFICANTLY RUNNING OVER
OUR TIMELINE BUT THAT'S OKAY OF
THIS IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE I DO WANT TO ALLOW TIME
FOR OUR NEXT PANEL AND FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND FOR IS I'M
IT'S A WE'RE GONNA HAVE A HARD
STOP AT ELEVEN THIRTY BUT MISTER
SPEAKER --
MISSED BATARANG I THINK YOU HAD
YOU MAY HAVE HAD SOMETHING ELSE
TO SAY EARLIER IT IF SO AND I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY IT -- OR
ANYTHING ELSE. FOR I THINK YOU I
THINK IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO
HIM JUST TAKE A MINUTE TO TELL
YOU HOW.
HE HAPPENED TO END UP BEING THE
IN.
THE INTERIM DIRECTOR.
IF IF IF I MAY GOODBYE LIKE
CONGRATULATIONS.
I LOVE STILL THE INTERMEDIARY --
CENTER ARE I CAME ABOUT LOVE
BEING CALLED UPON BECAUSE I AYE
HANDLE CRISIS MANAGEMENT.
AND COMPLIANCE AT THAT RESPONSE
SOME OF THINGS THAT I HAVE
LEARNED IN THE THE THE AIRFORCE
IN THE FBI IN TERMS OF ENSURING
THAT WE ARE COMPLIANT WITH ALL
THE REGULATIONS.
AND ALSO AND WE HAVE THAT WE
CALL IT OUR INSPECTION STAFF.
AND I'VE BEEN FORTUNATE TO BE
PART PARTY TO THAT SO I CAME IN
BACK AS AN ABLE AS A CONSULTANT.
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES IN TERMS
OF A CRISIS MANAGEMENT AND GOT A
COMPLIANCE.
AND DURING THAT TIME I WAS ABLE
TO GET THE OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE A PERSPECTIVE
WHERE DO GAS STATION.
AND EXTENT AND COMMITMENT OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK THERE IN SERVICE
FOR COMMUNITY CAN WITH THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THIS A
CHALLENGE JOHN [inaudible]
ANYTHING ELSE.
IF NOT WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
TO SEE YOU AGAIN THANKS FOR
JOINING US LIVES.
IT'S COOPER NEXT PANEL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
IF YOU WOULD --
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD STARTING TO OF MY LEFT
YOU'RE RIGHT THEM.
FAIR ENOUGH AMERICAN I AM THAT
DIRECTOROF THE EARLY EDUCATION
SUPPORT DIVISION AT CD PERFECT
THANK YOU THANKS FOR JOINING US
THIS MEMO HIGH CAN TALK AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS.
ALSO THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THANKS FOR JOINING US WANTS TO
PRESENT.
AND YOU KNOW OUR TIME LINE I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU KNOW ADEQUATE
TIME AS WE DID THE OTHER TWO
PANELS AND LIKE TO HAVE HEARD
STOP AT ELEVEN THIRTY BUT WE DO
HAVE SOME PUBLIC COMMENT.
I'M SURE AND YOUR PRESENTATION
IS VERY IMPORTANT AS WELL SO.
THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE SO I'M GONNA
START WITH SOME BRIEF COMMENTS
AND THEN CAME IS GONNA TAKE OVER
THE AUDIT PIECE.
SO THE DEPARTMENTS PRIORITY
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS ALWAYS TO
THE FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND PLUS
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S IN
FAMILIES THAT ARE RECEIVING
SUBSIDIZED EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE.
ARE KEY GOAL IS TO ENSURE
CHILDREN ARE SUPPORTED IN THEIR
HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT.
THE SUPPORTS ARE THERE FOR
FAMILIES TO WORK OR ATTEND
SCHOOL.
AND AS WE GO THROUGH VARIOUS
CONTRACT ISSUES THERE ARE NO
DISRUPTION SERVICES FOR THESE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
OUR PRIMARY ROLE IS REQUIRED IN
LAW AND IN REGULATIONS.
IS TO COLLABORATE AND PARTNER
WITH OUR SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
CONTRACTORS TO MANAGE MONITOR
AND TRACK BUT THE PROGRAMMATIC.
AND THE FISCAL PERFORMANCES OF
THOSE CONTRACTS TO INSURE THAT
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING CARE IS
TAKING PLACE ULTIMATELY
RESULTING IN POSITIVE OUTCOMES
FOR THESE YOUNG CHILDREN.
THE I DEPARTMENT AND OUR
CONTRACTING AGENCIES INCLUDING
THEIR BOARDS OF DIRECTORS.
WHETHER THEY BE A LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY OR NONPROFIT
TAKE THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO
OPERATE THESE CONTRACTS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
CONTACT EACH AGENCIES WORK HARD
TO ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY EAST
AND EFFICIENCIES ARE IN PLACE.
FROM THE BOARD TO THE PROGRAM
LEVEL IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE HIGH
LEVELS OF CONTRACT PERFORMANCE.
BOTH PROGRAMMATIC LEE AND
FISCALLY.
WE ALSO KNOW AND DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
TAKES THEIR ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDCARE DEVELOPMENTS.
I SYSTEM VERY SERIOUSLY.
WE APPRECIATE THIS AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AS WITH THE
LARGEST AND ONE OF THE BEST
EARLY LEARNING SYSTEMS IN THE
NATION AND ALSO AT TIMES IS
COMPLICATED.
AND AS WE WORK TOGETHER TO APPLY
THE FEDERAL AND STATELAWS TO
MAKE OUR SYSTEMS WORK WE ALSO DO
SO WITH UNLIMITED RESOURCES.
EACH OF OUR OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED CHILDCARE DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES CONTRACTS ARE RENEWED
ANNUALLY THIS IS BEEN WELL
ESTABLISHED IN THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION CODE.
AS WELL AS OUR TITLE FIVE
REGULATIONS AND HAS BEEN
OCCURRING FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS.
IF CONTRACT ISSUE SURFACED ABOUT
THE PROGRAM OR THE FISCAL
CONDITIONS OF THE CONTRACTOR OF
LAWS AND REGULATIONS OUT MINOR
APPROACH AND STEPS FOR
ADDRESSING ISSUES WITH THE
CONTRACTOR.
WE TAKE THIS VERY SERIOUSLY.
EVERY CONTRACTOR RECEIVES
ONGOING MONITORING THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TRAINING AND SUPPORT
FROM OUR EARLY EDUCATION SUPPORT
STAFF.
HI MY NAME IS CAN TARGET AGAIN
AND AND JUST TO ADD ON TO THAT --
IN ADDITION TO WHAT THE EARLY
EDUCATION SUPPORT DIVISION DOES
THE OUT ITS INVESTIGATION.
DIVISION THAT'S RECEIVE ON
FINANCIAL COMPLIANCE AUDITS.
EVERY YEAR FROM ALL OF THE
AGENCIES THAT RECEIVE FUNDING
AND THEY ARE.
PERFORMED BY IS AN INDEPENDENT
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANTS AND
THEY ARE --
PERFORMED UNDER THE UNIFORM.
BATON.
FEDERAL UNIFORM GUIDANCE.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THAT SO AND
THOSE ARE ONLY ONE SOURCE OF
INFORMATION PRESS OFTEN --
WE DO OUR OWN ANALYSIS OF THOSE
REPORTS ENOUGH AND WORK WITH THE
CPA'S AND AND GET CLARIFYING
INFORMATION.
SOMETIMES WE DO IDENTIFY COSTS
THAT I NEED TO BE ADJUSTED.
ON BUT AGAIN THAT IS ONLY ONE
SOURCE OF INFORMATION --
CURRENTLY HAS WITH NO TO BE.
THE AUDITS INVESTIGATIONS
DIVISION IS --
COMPLETING ITS OWN PERFORMANCE
AUDIT WHICH IS AN IN DEPTH
PERFORMANCE AUDIT AND WAS
EXPECTED TO TAKE.
UP A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF AND THE CHILD
CARE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS FOR
FOR SEATS FROM ON JULY TWENTY
FIFTEEN THROUGH.
MARCH TWENTY SIXTEEN AND THE
AREAS THAT WE'RE COVERING OUR
MARK FISCALLY FOCUSED
ELIGIBILITY GENERAL EXPENDITURES
PAYROLL EXPENDITURES COST
ALLOCATION AND INCLUDES
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
AND OTHER TRANSACTIONS THAT
COULD INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
RELATED PARTY TYPE TRANSACTIONS.
SO ON THIS AUDIT WAS INTENDED TO
TAKE AN EXTENDED AMOUNT OF TIME
BE BECAUSE OF THE LEVEL IN THE
DEATH OF THE AUDIT.
HOWEVER IT SHOULD ALSO BE NOTED
THAT O PLEADED BEGIN THIS AUDIT
PRIOR TO SEE.
AUDIT.
AND ON DURING THE AUDIT THE
AGENCY WAS EXPERIENCE EXTENSIVE
REQUEST OF DOCUMENTATION AND
THEIR TIME FROM BOTH OF US AT
THE SAME TIME SO WE DID SAY HEY
OKAY WILL TAKE A STEP BACK.
WELL THAT YOU AND WORK WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR AND THEN WE WILL
RECONNECT AFTER THAT WHICH WE
DID AND WHERE IN THAT --
FINAL PROCESSES OF WRAPPING THAT
UP SO WE DO EXPECT THE REPORT TO
BE ISSUED.
ON ABOUT SEPTEMBER AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO WE'LL HAVE THOSE
RESULTS.
FORTHCOMING.
AND SO WITH THAT I WILL TALK
ABOUT THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
SEE A FACE ON IT --
WHAT I'LL TALK ABOUT FIRST OF
THE FOUR THAT WE AGREE WITH AND
AND THE ACTIONS THAT WE ARE
TAKING RELATED TO THOSE AND THEN
I WILL TALK ABOUT THE LAST TWO
AFTER THAT?
SO AND THE FIRST RECOMMENDATION.
AND THAT WE CONCUR WITH.
PART OF MY LIFE WITH YOU --
IS AYE RECOMMENDATION NUMBER
NINE IT'S ON PAGE THIRTY FIVE OF
THE AUDIT REPORT.
SO AND THAT RECOMMENDATION --
REQUIRES THAT DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO AND RECALCULATE THE
REIMBURSABLE COST THREE RELATED
TO THAT QUESTION COSTS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED BY THE STATE AUDITOR.
AND WE WILL DO THAT AND WE WILL
DO THAT AT THE END OF A OUR IDEA
IS WILD SO WE DO THAT ALL AT ONE
TIME.
BASED ON WHATEVER THE RESULTS
ARE AT THAT.
AND SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL --
OCCUR.
AND THAT THE NEXT RECOMMENDATION
IS NUMBER TEN ON PAGE THIRTY
FIVE AT THE REPORT --
AND THAT ASSETS --
TO CONDUCT ANY FOLLOW REVIEWS OF
FORCES ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND
SO WE WILL CONSIDER WHAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN AFTER THAT REPORTS NOT.
ONLY RELATED TO ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS BY ANY OF THE ISSUES THAT
I'M ARE RELATED TO THE AUDIT.
AND THEN --
JUST FOR CLARITY EDUCATIONAL
ROUTINELY CONSIDERS REST FROM
ALL DIFFERENT AREAS AND NOT IT
DIVISION AT HOW WE SHOULD
PROCEED WITH ON GOING FUTURE.
AUDITS IN AREAS THAT HAVE RISK
THAT EGGS IT'S JUST SOMETHING
THAT WE RETAIN THE ROUTINELY DO
WE DID IT BEFORE CFA THOUGHT AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO AFTER --
THE NEXT RECOMMENDATION RELATES
TO THE MONITORING EFFORTS BY THE
EARLY EDUCATION SUPPORT DIVISION
AND I AM.
WE AGREE THAT IN CERTAIN AREAS
WEEKEND OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
DOCUMENTATION HOWEVER IT SHOULD
BE NOTED THAT IT'S NOT EVERY
AREA THAT NO DOCUMENTATION WAS
ON PRESENTED AREAS WHERE THERE
IS NOT COMPLIANCE.
THERE IS DOCUMENTATION TO
SUPPORT THAT I'M AREAS OF
ELIGIBILITY THERE IS
DOCUMENTATION TO THE PART THAT'S
SO --
HOWEVER AND THE OTHER AREAS.
WHAT WILL BE ADDED IS A
DESCRIPTION OF THE DOCUMENTS
REVIEWED --
OBSERVATIONS THAT WERE MADE AND
INFORMATION OBTAINED THROUGH
INTERVIEWS ONE THING THAT I DO
WANNA NOTE THOUGH IS THAT --
I MONITORING REVIEW AND THE
AUDIT ARE REALLY TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS MONITORING REVIEWS ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO HAPPEN WITH
PROGRAMS THAT THEY PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THEY LOOK
AT CERTAIN AREAS--
AND THEY WORK WITH AGENCIES --
THERE'S A LOT AGENCIES TO COVER
IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME IS NOT
EXPECTED TO BE THE SAME --
IN DEPTH LEVEL OF REVIEW OF
DOCUMENTATION.
OR NECESSARILY --
THAT THEY END UP LEVEL
DOCUMENTATION REQUIRED OF AN
ARTIST I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THOSE REALLY ARE TWO DIFFERENT
FUNCTIONS --
THE MONITORING REVIEWS TECHNO
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TRAINING --
PROVIDES OPPORTUNITIES TO
IDENTIFY READ FIVE SIX CETERA.
AND IN THAT COULD RESULT IN AN
AUDIT WHICH IN THIS CASE DEAD --
WE ARE REQUESTED TO THE DO THE
AUDIT AND WE HAD STARTED THAT.
IN MARCH I TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO --
FIXED Y. TO POINT THAT OUT
[inaudible]
AND BUT AGAIN I WE AGREE THAT WE
CAN HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE THAT
WAY DOWN BE OF ASSISTANCE --
TO FOLLOW BEHIND THE CONCLUSIONS
THAT ARE REACHED IN THE AREAS
FOR COMPLIANCE IS REACHED.
AND THE LAST AREA THAT WE AGREE
WITH AS WELL IS THAT I RELATED
TO THAT.
PENSION FUNDS.
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE'S A CLASS
ACTION LAWSUIT ITS ONGOING
CURRENTLY SO AND TELL THAT CLASS
ACTION LAWSUIT IS COMPLETED.
THAT'S WHEN WE WOULD DETERMINE
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE ACTION TO
TAKE IT SHOULD BE NOTED TOO THAT --
IN THAT --
AUDITOR'S REPORT THAT THE LAST
TIME FUNDS WERE I'M PROVIDED FOR
THIS ON PENSION FUND WAS TWO
THOUSAND NINE SO THAT'S A NUMBER
OF YEARS AGO.
BUT WE WILL TAKE ACTION AGAIN
BASED ON THE THE LAWSUIT HOW
THAT TURNS OUT.
THE OTHER AREAS THAT WE WANNA
ANSWER BACK.
TO OURRECOMMENDATION NUMBER.
FOUR WHICH DOES TALK ABOUT THE
APPEAL PROCESS AND WE TALKED
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT --
BEFORE HOWEVER --
THAT YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WAS SURPRISED
CONCERNED.
ABOUT LACTATE BACKDATING OF THE
NOTICES --
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT SHOULDN'T
HAPPEN IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
FAMILIES TO RECEIVE NOTIFICATION
TIMELY AND LEAD WE EXPECT THAT
AND COMMUNICATION.
THE REASON WHY WE HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF A DIFFERENT --
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT THERE ARE.
REQUIREMENTS FOR AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO FAMILIES.
IN THIS CASE IT WAS CONCEALED.
BY THE BACKDATING OUT.
BUT THERE ARE PROCEDURES IN
PLACE AND ALSO WE DO HAVE THE
FORM THE ONE THING THAT THAT I
THINK IS IMPORTANT TO REALIZE AS
WELL IS THAT.
THE VALID GROUNDS FOR APPEALING
A NOTICE OF ACTION WHATEVER THAT
ACTION IS SIMPLY THAT THE FAMILY
DISAGREE.
THAT'S ALL I THEY DISAGREE AND
THEY CAN APPEAL TO THE AGENCY.
IF THEY DISAGREE WITH THAT --
DECISION THEY CAN APPEAL TO THAT
APARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN THE
SAMPLE FORM IT DOES INCLUDE THE
INFORMATION THE KEY INFORMATION
AND SEE IF THERE'S
RECOMMENDATION OF WHO TO CONTACT
INCLUDES A FAX NUMBER.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
ADDRESS THE IT APPEALS
COORDINATOR AT A PHONE NUMBER SO
THAT THERE IS THAT INFORMATION
[inaudible]
THEY'RE ALREADY.
IT WAS NOT CONSISTENTLY APPLIED.
WHICH IS IT IS NOT DUE TO THE
LACK OF DIRECTION BY EDUCATION
BECAUSE WE DO EXPECT THAT
INFORMATION TO BE.
INCLUDED IN THOSE NOTICES.
THE OTHER I'M ITEM THAT I WOULD
NOTE THAT THERE STATE AUDITOR
DID ALLUDED TO WAS ALLOW IS THAT --
WELL THAT THE MONITORING VISIT
DOES LOOK AT THE NOTICES.
THEY ARE NOT EXPECTED TO DO.
YOU KNOW ADVANCED INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AUDIT PROCEDURES THAT
IS SOMETHING AND AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT THIS ISSUE WAS
WITHOUT SO IT CAN BE --
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSED BUT
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU
WOULD NORMALLY EXPECT AND
MONITORING OF REVIEW.
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE MORE RELATED TO RISKS
IDENTIFIED AND A RESPONSE AND
ABOUT IT.
OKAY AND THEN THOUGH WANTS
[inaudible]
ITEM.
RELATES THAT CRITICAL APPRAISAL
OF EACH EDUCATION PROGRAM.
AND THAT WE DID WANT TO NOTE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
IT DID RECEIVE SOME CLARIFYING
INFORMATION YESTERDAY RELATED TO
THIS OUR RECOMMENDATION.
AND NOTING THAT THE STATE ORDER
DOES NOT I INTERPRET THAT
THEY'RE TO BE TWO SEPARATE
APPRAISALS THAT WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT INFORMATION.
HOWEVER WE STILL WANTED TO KNOW
THAT -- THAT
PUTS THE PROGRAM'S SELF
EVALUATION PROCESS.
WAS ADOPTED THROUGH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS AND EDUCATION
IS THE ADMINISTRATIVE AGENCY IN
THE REGULATORY AGENCY CHARGED.
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
OVERSIGHT OF THE PROGRAM'S.
THEREFORE --
WE FILL THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
INTERPRET INTERPRETATION OF WHAT
IS REQUIRED.
AND SHOULD TAKE PRECEDENCE HERE
ON ONE THING TO CONSIDER AS A
STATEWIDE PROCESS THERE'S ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT AGENCIES WITH
ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT --
DIVERSE ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURES AND SIZES AND SO --
THAT THE PROCESS NEEDS TO BE
SOMETHING THAT THAT ALL AGENCIES
KIDNEY.
AND SO WELL YES THAT WERE TO BE
INVOLVED IF WE FEEL THAT THEY
COULD RELY ON THE STAFF'S
ASSESSMENT.
IN THAT PROCESS AND THERE MAY BE
OTHER WAYS AS WELL THAT THE
DOCUMENTATION THAT COULD TAKE
PLACE.
SO THOSE WERE THAT PROTECT
PERSPECTIVES THAT WE WANTED TO
SHARE WITH YOU ALL TODAY.
AND DAM WERE.
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS FULLER
JUST ASK A QUICK.
ONE WITH RESPECT TO THIS
BACKDATING YOU KNOW WE'VE.
SORT OF DANCED AROUND THE
IDENTITY ISSUES THESE ARE
PERSONNEL ISSUES WE HAVEN'T
DISCUSSED INDIVIDUALS WHOM.
DID OR DIDN'T ENGAGE IN THIS
WHAT I WOULD CALL MISCONDUCT BUT
IS IT.
IS IT POSSIBLE IN OUR STATE THAT
THE FOLKS AT ENGAGED IN THIS
BACKDATING.
A POP UP AT ANOTHER ORGANIZATION
AND DO THE VERY SAME THING.
FELLOW AT THE MASSES EDUCATION
THIS IS STATE MONEY --
MISSES SOMETHING THAT'S UNDER
THE PURVIEW THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I GUESS JUST TO
RESTATE IT IS IT POSSIBLE THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL OR INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ENGAGED IN THESE BACKDATING?
ACTIVITIES COULD POP UP AT
ANOTHER ONE OF OUR ORGANIZATIONS
THAT.
RECEIVE STATE MONEY AND DO THE
VERY SAME THING.
SO FIRST WE TAKE THIS MATTER
VERY SERIOUSLY I AM NOT.
SUGGESTING THAT YOU DIDN'T IN
I'M MY QUESTION SHOULD NOT BE
INTERPRETED AS A CRITICISM OF
THE DEPARTMENT I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU DO.
SO AND THAT WE DO NOT TRACK
EMPLOYEES OF ALL THEIR FIVE
THIRTEEN HUNDRED CONTRACTS TO
DETERMINE WHERE THEY COULD LAND
WE INSTEAD WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW
THAT HAPPENED.
AND AND AS KIM STATED READ DO
NOT DO FORENSIC AUDITS THAT DIVE
INTO THE IT SYSTEMS THEMSELVES
BUT IN CHECKING WITH A
CONTRACTOR.
AND THEN THAT THE SYSTEM THAT
THEY USED THERE SEEM TO BE A FLY
ON THE SYSTEM ITSELF FOR IT
SHOULD NOT ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
BUT THERE WAS SOMETHING THAT
WASN'T PROGRAMMED CORRECTLY AND
HENCE WAS ALLOWING FOR IT
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
WHAT?
WHILE WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
EMPLOYEES THEMSELVES WE ACTUALLY
THINK THERE IS A SYSTEMS ISSUE
AND THAT IT SYSTEM SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PREVENT ALL OF THAT IN
THE FUTURE.
WELL THAT'S CERTAINLY TRUE HITS
AND IT'S REALLY A SHAME THAT WE
HAVE TO DESIGN SYSTEMS TO
PREVENT INDIVIDUALS FROM
ENGAGING IN INTENTIONAL
MISCONDUCT.
I DID NOT ASK THE PRIOR PANEL
WHETHER THE INDIVIDUAL OR
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED --
RECEIVED APPROPRIATE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION WHETHER THAT
DISCIPLINARY ACTION WAS IN
WRITING AND PLACED IN A
PERSONNEL FILE SO THAT SOMEONE.
WHO DOES A BACKGROUND CHECK
COULD POSSIBLY AND COVER AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO ENGAGES IN --
INTENTIONAL MISCONDUCT THAT
INVOLVES A INTEGRITY.
BUT I THINK THAT'S A SERIOUS
ISSUE.
WHERE I CAN RESULT HERE?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE
SENATOR BILL.
ARMSTRONG YOU SAID THAT YOU'RE
GOING -- TO
HARD STOP WELL I'D THAT WOULD BE
MY PREFERENCE SO THIS IS IT IS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR
MANY INCLUDING YOU AND SO PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO ASK IF I CHAIRMAN --
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF --
FIRST OF ALL --
AND WANT TO POINT OUT TO YOU.
AND AND THE PEOPLE HERE THAT TOM.
A LETTER WAS SENT TO THE
DEPARTMENT IN MARCH PASSING
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
REGARDING A COMPLIANCE --
AND WAS SENT BY EIGHT
LEGISLATORS WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED
A RESPONSE MISTER CHAIRMAN --
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE
RESPONSE.
TO OUR LETTER --
RESPONDED TO SO THAT I CAN GET.
RESPONSE --
ON THESE ISSUES THAT WE ASK --
WE HEARD.
WE HEARD --
SOME OF THE COMETS ARE RELATED.
TO THE QUESTIONS WE HAD THE
LETTER.
TO SPECIFICALLY ASKED --
TO SEVERAL DIFFERENT ISSUES WE
WANTED INFORMATION ON ABOUT
COMPLIANCE WITH LAWS AND FINDING
OUT SO.
WHAT WHAT IS ACTUALLY GOING ON
IN TERMS OF?
THE COMPLIANCE PART --
LET'S GET A RESPONSE AMENDED YOU
ALL HAVE THE LETTER AS SOON.
I PERSONALLY DON'T OF THE LETTER
I THINK WE CAN DEFINITELY FOLLOW
UP IN AND FIND OUT WITHOUT OKAY
I APPRECIATED IF YOU WOULD AND
IF YOU WOULD EXPEDITE THE
RESPONSE AND SEND IT THROUGH THE
THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MS SOBRE SUCHY
AND A COPY --
TO CENTER BILL PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND NOW IF WE NEED TO
WILL WRITE ANOTHER LETTER MAYBE
GET A FEW MORE SIGNATURES ON IT.
MAYBE IT WASN'T ENOUGH MISTER
CHAIRMAN BUT I THINK GO.
IF I GET --
LIKE YOU KNOW YOU KNOW ME I'M
VERY GOOD ABOUT GETTING
SIGNATURES ON LETTERS.
AS YOU KNOW --
SO -- BUT
ANYWAY --
THE ONLY QUESTION I HAD OF HERE
THIS TODAY --
WAS WE HAD --
A PROCESS THAT WAS KINDA
CONFUSING TO ME AND AND IT WAS
ON APRIL AND APRIL EARLY APRIL
THERE WAS --
NOTIFICATION THAT DO THE
FINDINGS THE OF OUR AUDITOR'S
REPORT --
THERE WOULD BE NO OFFER CONTINUE
FUNDING FOR THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
AND THEN A SUBSEQUENT NEXT THE
MONTH AFTER THAT.
THERE IS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
REVIEW PANEL THAT OVERTURNED A
DECISION DECIDE TO FUND THE
AGENCY. FOR THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
ON A CONDITIONAL CONTRACT BASIS
AND THE QUESTION I HAVE IS.
HE EXPLAIN THAT PROCESS AND HAS
IT BEEN USED IN THE PAST --
FREQUENTLY WERE INFREQUENTLY AND
WHAT PARTICULAR ISSUES WERE USED
TO BASE THAT DECISION.
WAS IT A OPEN PUBLIC PROCESS
THAT --
PEOPLE WERE INCH THAT WERE
INTERESTED IN THIS SUBJECT --
NOTIFIED --
WAS THEIR INVESTIGATION INTO BY
THE DEPARTMENT --
TWO CHANGE THE RECOMMENDATION --
AND IT IS A SON COMMENTER COMIN --
AND YOU HAVE A LIST OF THE
CONDITIONS THAT WE PLEASE
SUPPOSEDLY OUT OF ITS
CONDITIONALLY APPROVED.
SOMEONE I KNOW --
WHAT THE PROCESS IS?
OF WHAT PART WHAT PUBLIC INPUT
DID YOU HAVE --
ON THAT --
WHAT'S WITH OUT OF THAT HAPPENED.
SARAH DOESN'T NEED TO WHO ARE
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE THIS
ADMINISTRATOR.
PANEL THAT WE HAD MAKE THE
DECISION CAN YOU GIVE US THE
NAMES OF THE PEOPLE.
BUT LET ME I'M GONNA GO THROUGH
THE QUESTION AMOUNTS OF AREAS
BUT I AM SURE I DON'T HAVE THAN.
NAMES OF THE PEOPLE SO IT'S AN
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW POWERBALL
GET TO THAT IN A SECOND WE CAN
GET YOU THOSE.
BUT AND THE DEPARTMENT ENGAGE IN
A STANDARD PROCESS THAT WE
REVIEW ALL OF OUR CONTRACTS BY.
SUE THE PUBLIC PART HAPPENS
AHEAD OF TIME AND I THINK WHAT
WE CAN SAY ABOUT THE PUBLIC
IMPACT THAT WE RECEIVED NUMEROUS
COMPLAINTS.
AND I'M DID IT REALLY IN DEPTH
AND ADDITIONAL MONITORING OF
THIS CONTRACTOR OVER THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS INCLUING
REQUESTING A STATE AND OUGHT TO
BE DONE BY OUR OWN ON ITS
INVESTIGATION.
DEPARTMENT THE REVIEW PROCESS
FOR A CONTRACTS IS CALLED CASE
CONFERENCE AND IN THAT PROCESS
YOU ARE CORRECT THAT THE STAFF
ENGAGED.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT RECOMMENDED
THAT THE AGENCY BE SENT A NOTICE
OF PROPOSED ACTION AROUND NON
RENEWAL.
PER THAT REGULATION FORESEES IS
ALLOWED TO APPEAL THAT
RECOMMENDATION AND THEY DID SO.
THE APPEAL WAS SUBMITTED AS AN
ORAL PRESENTATION BEFORE AN
INDEPENDENT ADMINISTRATIVE
REVIEW PANEL THAT'S THE A A RP.
AND NOT A RP IS A SIGN BY THE
DEPARTMENT IT IS NOT HEARING SO
IT'S NOT A PUBLIC PROCESS.
WITH AND BACK AND FORTH DIALOGUE
BUT MANY THE AS A PROCESS.
THAT ENGAGES THE CONTRACTOR TO
BE ABLE.
TO PROVIDE A RESPONSE RELATED TO
THE CASE CONFERENCE FINDINGS.
THAT MINISTRY OF REVIEW PANEL IN
THIS INSTANCE FOUND THE
CONDITIONAL STATUS WAS MORE
APPROPRIATE THAN TERMINATION.
THE A A RP IS AN INDEPENDENT
PANEL THAT REVIEWS THE EVIDENCE
AND FACTS INDEPENDENT OF STAFF
INVOLVED OR AND RELATED
SPECIFICALLY TO THE CASE
CONFERENCE PROCESS.
THEY LOOK CONSISTENTLY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT PROCESSES APPLIED
ACROSS ALL OF OUR CONTRACTORS
AND ACROSS ANYONE WHO MAY BE
APPEALING THEIR DECISION SO THAT
IS OBJECTIVE AND CONSISTENT.
THE FORCES EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
APPEALED THE ACTION RECOMMENDED
BY CASE CONFERENCE.
AND ALSO SEND A RESPONSE TO THE
REPORT TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR ALL OF THOSE WERE
INCLUDED IN THE ERP.
STATE CONSIDERED THE INFORMATION
AND THE ORAL PRESENTATION BEFORE
MODIFYING THE KEYS CONFERENCES
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION OF NO
OFFER OF CONTINUED FUNDING. TO
AN OFFER OF CONDITIONAL
CONTRACTS STATUS WITH THE MUST
BE MEANT BY THE CONTRACTOR AS
WELL AS ENHANCED OVERSIGHT AND
MONITORING.
DO YOU HAVE A OF FILE ON THE
APPEAL.
I DON'T IS THERE --
THE ADMINISTRATIVO.
REVIEW PANEL --
DO THEY HAVE A FILE ON THE
APPEAL.
THEY HAVE A FINAL LETTER THAT IS
ISSUE THEY HAVE A FILE LIKE WITH
THE COMMUNICATIONS.
INFORMATION THAT WAS SUBMITTED.
ARM DOCUMENTS OF CONTACTS WHO
CONTACTED THEM.
AND ACCEPT.
THEIR AN INDEPENDENT PAN
SEPARATE FROM CONTACTS THAT
PUBLIC RECORDS[inaudible]
YES THEN THE OF THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE COPIES OF
THOSE PUBLIC RECORDS.
OKAY RELATED TO THE SO WE CAN
HAVE THEM REVIEWED BY.
OURSELVES IN THE AUDITOR FOR THE
COMPLETE COPY OF THAT.
RECORD I WOULD APPRECIATE IT --
DO YOU -- DO
YOU HAVE --
WHAT WHERE THE MAIN DETERMINANTS
OF?
THE THE APPEAL DECISION THAT WAS
MADE.
AT BECAUSE THAT IS INDEPENDENT I
AM ACTUALLY NOT INCLUDED IN THE
PROCESS ITSELF I HAVE TO BE KEPT
SEPARATE.
AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION
BUT I DO KNOW THAT THEY LISTENED
TO THE ORAL PRESENTATIONS.
AS WELL AS AND LOOKING THROUGH
FOR THE CONSISTENCIES AND IT WAS
THE ORAL PRESENTATION ALONG WITH
THE RESPONSES THAT HAD ALREADY
BEEN MADE.
REGARDING THE STATE AUDIT.
AND LOOKING AT THAT IS WHERE
THEY DETERMINED TO MAKE IT AN
OFFER OF CONDITIONAL CONTRACTS
STATUS SO THIS IS A OWN APPEAL
PROCESS.
WHERE IT'S SORT OF ONE SIDED THE --
HOW IT CAN PRESENT?
INFORMATION AND MATERIALS.
BUT NOBODY ELSE BECAUSE IT'S NOT
A PUBLIC PROCESS.
IS THAT CORRECT IT'S AN
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW PANEL NOT
A HEARING SO IT'S IS NOT --
WHERE --
LIKE LEGISLATORS WHO SUBMIT A
LETTER A MONTH BEFORE WOULD BE
NOTIFIED ABOUT IT OR ANY OTHER
INTERESTED PARTY.
THAT EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT --
THIS THIS --
ISSUE --
WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED. TO ATTEND
OR PARTICIPATE OR BE INFORMED
ABOUT THE PROCESS WE DID HAVE
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE ATTENDING THEY
ARE NOT AT THERE'S NO TIME FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT BECAUSE IT IS NOT
AN OFFICIAL HEARING.
SO LEGISLATORS ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO BE INFORMED ABOUT THE PROCESS
[inaudible]
THERE'S NO.
AND EVEN THOUGH WE WROTE A
LETTER SAYING EIGHT OF US AT
LEAST.
ASKED TO BE INFORMED ABOUT IT
AND WE WE'RE NOT INFORMED.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
MISCOMMUNICATION THAT HAPPENS
TARA I WILL LOOK INTO THE LETTER
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENED TO IT.
BATES AND THERE ISN'T A CHANCE
AND NOT PROCESS [inaudible]
THE PART FOR WHERE WE REALLY
TAKE THE PUBLIC IMPLIED
SERIOUSLY AS WHEN WE DROP AND
YOU ADDITIONAL MONITORING OF OUR
CONTRACTS.
AND IT I FEEL LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT DID NOT WE DID
MULTIPLE SITE VISITS WE DEAD ON
ANNOUNCED LATE VISITS TO THE
CONTRACTOR.
AND FROM THAT DEVELOPED WENT
THROUGH BOTH ARMED FEDERAL
MONITORING AS WELL AS OUR STATE
MONITORING REQUIREMENTS.
AS WELL AS REQUESTING AN AUDIT
FROM OUR AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATION UNITED YOU APPOINT
THIS A INDEPENDENT --
REVIEW PANEL ALL.
WHO DOESN'T DO ANY OF THOSE
THINGS BUT IS INDEPENDENT?
AND WHO APPOINTS THESE PEOPLE
AND WHAT IS THE PROCESS TO
CREATE THESE INDEPENDENT
[inaudible]
REVIEW PANELS [inaudible]
THERE'S AND STAFF THAT ARE
SEPARATE FROM THE ACTUAL
CONTRACTS IN AND NOT CLOSE TO IT
SO THERE ARE THERE IS SOMEONE
FROM THE EDUCATION SUPPORT
DIVISION BUT IT HAS TO BE
SOMEONE COMPLETELY NEUTRAL.
WHO HAS NOT BEEN ENGAGED IN ANY
OF THE DISCUSSION OR HEARD ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT A CONTRACT?
AND WE ALSO HAVE THE LEGAL STAFF
ANA AND AUDIT STAFF IN A FISCAL
STAFF SO THERE'S REPRESENTATION
FROM ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT.
ON THAT REVIEW PANEL SO THERE IS
A LAWYER.
MAYBE SOLELY FROM THE AUDIT.
RIGHT THAT'S NOT INVOLVED IN NOT
A OR THE SNOW HAS BEEN HOT AND
PLEASE LEAVE THAT TRIP FROM THE
PROCESS AT THE IN THE STAFFER
AND ANOTHER AREA I DEVELOPMENT
ISSUES [inaudible]
SO -- THIS
ADMINISTRATIVE PANEL
[inaudible]
IS.
UNDER THE RULES CREATED BY WHAT.
IN IT IS A CREATED BY STATUTE.
REGULATION UN DEPARTMENT
PROCEDURES.
HOW IS THIS --
CONTRACT --
RENEWAL APPEAL.
PROCESS CREATED IS IS IS A
STATUTORILY CREATED OR HOUSE IT
CREATED IT'S PART OF OUR
REGULATIONS.
SO YOU CREATED YOURSELF BEGUN A
RECEPTOR REGULATIONS.
AND NOW DID YOU PUBLISH THOSE
REGULATIONS WE I HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS
THAT THEY GO THROUGH THE OFFICE
OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW AND ARE.
OUT FOR PUBLIC HEARING THEY GET
PUBLIC FEEDBACK BACK ON THEM AND
BASED ON THE PUBLIC FEEDBACK YOU
THEN MODIFYING COMPLETE THE
REGULATORY PACKAGE.
SO DO YOU FEEL THAT --
TAKING ONE SIDE ONCE YOU KNOW
WHEN THERE'S A CONTROVERSY.
AND WHERE PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
CHILD CARE IN THEIR COUNTY.
OF TO ALMOST TWO MILLION PEOPLE.
THAT NOT INFORMING THEM OF THIS
PROCESS IN THAT APPEAL IS --
APPROPRIATE.
OR ETHICAL WERE.
HOUSE INTEGRITY WHEN PEOPLE SEE
THAT KIND OF PROCESS.
CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT AS A
POLICY YOU THINK THAT SHOULD BE
CHANGED.
I THINK THERE'S A VARIETY OF
FACTORS TO WEIGH.
AND ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ONCE IS TO KEEP A PROCESS
INDEPENDENT SO THAT WE KNOW THAT.
THE PERSONAL FEELINGS OR AT
CONNECTIONS TO VARIOUS THINGS
LIKE A CONTRACTOR NOT WAIT AND
BUT IT IS APPLY CONSISTENTLY
ACROSS A SERIES OF CONTRACTS IN
THE SAME MANNER [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
THE OPEN NURSES NOT.
THE THE ISSUE. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT I THINK I THINK.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK THESE
APPEALS AND THE PROCESS.
FOR SINCE THEY ONLY HEAR ONE
SIDE OF THE QUESTION --
OR ONE SIDE OF THE ISSUE.
AND THERE'S NO STATUTE.
THE GREAT SEIZE APPEAL PROCESS I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING.
WHERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
MULTI MILLION DOLLAR TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
CONTRACTS I THINK IT'S SOMETHING --
TO QUESTION I THINK GO.
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE INTEREST OF
THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN.
ON THOSE --
IT'S ARE FORTUNATE WE WERE
NOTIFIED ITS OF FORTUNE PUBLIC
WAS NOT INVOLVED [inaudible]
AND IT SHOWS A CULTURE THAT I
DON'T PARTICULAR APPRECIATE IT.
YOU KNOW.
SO I HAVE NO OTHER QUESTIONS --
CHAIRMAN BECAUSE THEY WANT YOU.
TO BILL TO HEAR A FEW PEOPLE.
THERE WERE LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU SENATOR BELL OF
ANY OTHER FURTHER COMMENTS. FOR
I THINK YOU I THINK I CAN JUST
REITERATE THAT WE ARE VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT OUR CHILDREN
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
WE WORK HARD EVERY DAY FOR THIS.
AND AND WE ALSO TOOK COMMENTS
AND FEEDBACK FROM THE PUBLIC
VERY SERIOUSLY THE AMOUNT OF
ADDITIONAL MONITORING WE HAVE
DONE OVER THIS CONTRACTOR.
WHEN WE HAVE THIRTEEN HUNDRED
CONTRACTS TO MONITOR EVERY
SINGLE YEAR?
REALLY SHOWS WITH ONLY EIGHTEEN
STAFF TO MONITOR THAT WE PUT
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES INTO JUST
ONE CONTRACTOR.
WELL WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS AND I WOULDN'T TAKE
ANY OF OUR QUESTIONS IS BEING.
CRITICAL OF WHAT YOU DO EACH AND
EVERY DAY FOR ALL THE REST OF US
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO COME.
AND PRESENT HERE TODAY I HAD ONE
I FOLLOW UP COMMENT THAT I DID
WANT TO MENTION AS WELL I'M
RELATED TO THE FACT THAT THE
PERFORMANCE ON IT IS ONGOING.
WE WOULD WANT TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE RESULTS OF
THAT AUDIT.
IN CONCLUSION WITH THE C. ESSAYS
ON IT BEFORE MAKING A FINAL
DECISION BECAUSE WE WOULDN'T
WANT TO PREMATURELY DISRUPT.
SERVICES TO CHILDREN EITHER NO
ACTUALLY NOT IF IT AND I'M SURE
YOU MAINTAIN YOUR CONTACT WITH
THE CHAIR OF THIS --
THROUGH THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND ALSO SENATOR BILL
AS YOU MOVE ALONG FLUID
APPRECIATE YOU DOING SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BOTH VERY
MUCH.
OKAY THIS IS NOW THE TIME FOR A
PUBLIC COMMENT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
I'D THEIR AYE IT DOES MATTER TO
ME DIPPING ON HOW MANY THERE ARE --
YOU FEEL FREE TO HAVE A SEAT.
BOTH OF YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VALENTINA'S I'M
FORESEES.
I'VE BOMB RECEIVE.
FORESEES I HAVE TWO CHILDREN
[inaudible]
AND SIX I BILL FORESEES FOR
ABOUT --
GOING ON FIVE YEARS I'M WORKING
FAMILIES LIKE MINE DEPEND ON THE
FAMILY CHILDCARE SYSTEM TO
ENSURE THAT OUR CHILDREN RECEIVE
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION IF IT
WAS NOT FOR SEIZE THAT WOULD NOT
BE ABLE --
TO FOR CHILDCARE COSTS IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS AUDIT
IT VERIFIED WHAT I EXPERIENCED
FIRST HAND AS A PARENT RECEIVING
SUBSIDIES --
IT SHOWS THAT IT'S NOT THE
EXCEPTION BUT IT WAS KIND OF A
WORKING RULE THAT FORESEES HAD.
WITH THEM THE POLICIES THAT THEY
WERE FOLLOWING --
IT'S GOOD TO KNOW THAT I'M NOT
ALONE BUT I SADDENS ME TO KNOW
HOW MANY OTHER FAMILIES.
HAVE WENT THROUGH THESE ISSUES
AND ULTIMATELY LOST CHILD CARE --
THESE ISSUES INCLUDE MISTAKES
WITH DETERMINING MY FAMILY'S
ELIGIBILITY ISSUES WITH THEIR
CHILD CARE PROVIDER BEING P.
BILLY -- BMC
SENT INCORRECT NOTICES OF
ACTIONS AND A LACK OF
INFORMATION AND ACCESSIBILITY TO
APPEAL PROCESSES --
I SPOKE OUT HERE AND I REQUESTED --
TO HAVE THIS AUDIT THE DAY AFTER
I CAME HERE MY M. SERVICES WERE
TERMINATED I DID FILE AN APPEAL --
COLLETTE.
AND JACK WERE ON MY APPEAL THEY
SAT IN THE MY APPEAL THEY
VIOLATED ALL MY RIGHTS OF MY
APPEAL I HAD TO SEEK OUT.
COUNSEL TO ASSIST ME IN MY
APPEAL ULTIMATELY THEY WERE
FOUND THAT THEY HAD VIOLATED ALL
OF THE PROCESSES THAT THEY HAVE
IN THEIR HAND BOOK AND I WAS
REINSTATED --
I AM CONCERNED THERE'S A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT INTEGRITY I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR BOARD MEMBER
OF THE BOARD MEMBERS THERE IS
ONE BOARD MEMBER IN PARTICULAR
WHO WAS INVOLVED IN ANOTHER
SCANDAL IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
WHERE ALTHOUGH HE WAS NOT GIVEN
JAIL TIME HE WAS REQUIRED TO PAY
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS SO THE FACT
THAT HE SITTING ON FORESEES
BOARD IS VERY CONCERNING?
THE FACT THAT FRED VILLASENOR
HAND PICKED TO THE MAJORITY OF
THE BOARD.
AND OUR INTERIM DIRECTOR WAS IS
A GOOD FRIEND OF THIS BOARD
MEMBER SO THEY'RE VERY CLOSELY
IN TIED AS THEY SAY THAT THERE'S
BEEN CHANGE IN MANAGEMENT THERE
HASN'T BEEN CHANGED IN
MANAGEMENT.
THERE'S BEEN CHANGE OF TITLES SO
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
SCRUPULOUS ACTIVITIES ARE STILL
WITHIN THE AGENCY BUT NOW WITH
THE HIGHER TITLE.
SO IT IS CONCERNING I AM
DISAPPOINTED THAT --
THEY'RE STILL FUNCTIONING --
I WAS HOPING THAT THE CONTRACT
WOULD HAVE BEEN DISABLED AND IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN OUTSOURCED TO
OTHER AGENCIES --
I I'M I'M PRETTY OUTRAGED WITH
EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON AND
PRETTY OUTRAGED WITH.
THE STAFF THAT ARE STILL AT THE
HELM OF THE SHIP EVEN THOUGH THE
THE MAIN FRED HAS LEFT HIS
PREDECESSORS HAVE TOOK IT OVER
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH CHANGE
IS REALLY GOING TO HAPPEN --
I DO HAVE TO SAY THAT THERE HAS
BEEN.
PROCEDURES THAT ARE DIFFERENT
NOW THAT FORESEES IS TRYING TO
FOLLOW UP ON IN REGARDS TO THIS
AUDIT -- I I
AM WORKING WITH FEAR EVERY TIME
THAT THEY ASKED ME.
TO SIGN SOMETHING THERE'S A FEAR
OF LIKE REP I'M AFRAID TO LOSE
MY CHILD CARE THERE IS
DEFINITELY A TRUST ISSUE THAT
HAS NOT BEEN FIXED --
IT IS EIGHT IT LEAVES ME EVERY
DAY QUESTIONING EVERYTHING THAT
THEY ASKED ME TO DO WHEN I HAVE
TO REPORT CHANGES I TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS ACCURATE
AS POSSIBLE.
BECAUSE I AM IN CONSTANT FEAR OF
LOSING MY CHILD CARE.
AGAIN MY NAME IS VALENTINA
RAMALLAH'S I THINK ILLNESS THANK
YOU FOR COMING TO WORK TO
PRESENT TODAY WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
CERTAINLY.
HAVE HEARD IN APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
IF IF YOU ALL COULD KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO ABOUT TWO MINUTES
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL --
I REALIZE YOU HAVE A LOT TO SAY
AND WE CERTAINLY WANT TO TRY TO
HEAR IT SO.
OKAY MANAGEMENT SANCHES I HAVE
CHILDREN RECEIVED.
THROUGH FORESEES PERSONS HAVE
BEEN VERY.
FRUSTRATING THE MEANING AND
INSULTING --
I HAVE CHRONIC HEALTH PROBLEMS
THAT LIMIT MY ABILITY
[inaudible]
TO SHARES.
I ALSO HAVE A SON WITH EPILEPSY
AND MULTIPLE DISABILITIES.
MEANING HE REQUIRES VERY
SPECIALIZED CARE FIRST FROM
SOMEONE TRAINED TO RESPOND TO
HIS CONDITION ON A ONE ON ONE
BASIS NOT.
A BIG TURNOVER.
I GET -- THE
CHILD CARE FROM FOR SERIOUS I
HAVE HAD MY DOCTOR FILL OUT AN
INCAPACITATION FORM IS WHICH I
CALL QUALIFIED --
FOR YEARS NOW IT IS NOT THE
PROBLEM OF IT JUST BEING
CERTIFIED IT'S THE FACT IT.
THE FORCES DECIDED THAT THE
INFORMATION A DOCTOR PROVIDED
ABOUT MY ILLNESS WAS NO LONGER
COLETTE AND THE REST OF THE
PEOPLE ON THEIR BOARD REQUESTED
SPECIFIC CHRONIC UP MIGHT
INFORMATION.
ON WHICH I FEEL THAT THEY NEED
TO BE TRAINED THROUGH THE HIPAA
LAW BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT THE
FEDERAL LAW.
ENFORCING SKILLS THAT THEY ARE
ABOVE THE FEDS.
AND MY DOCTOR IN MANY OCCASIONS
HAVE TO PERSONALLY CONTACT THEM
BECAUSE I WAS JUST NOT ABLE TO
GO TO MY DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENTS I
HAVE.
HEART PROBLEMS I HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PROBLEMS AND THEY ASK
WHY ARE YOU NOT HERE.
IT'S BECAUSE FOUR SCENES DIDN'T
PROVIDE ME WITH DAY CARE AND
THEY WANT IT SPECIFIC SO AS AN
AS AN ATM THAT I DON'T HAVE IF I
DID HAVE AIDS IT'S NOBODY'S
BUSINESS THAT I WOULD HAVE AIDS
OR CANCER ANYTHING.
IT'S MY PERSONAL THING AND IF I
DIE WHEN YOU SAYS I'M DEEMED
DISABLED WHICH I HAVE BEEN. FOR
A LONG TIME AND HAVE GOTTEN
WORSE HE UNDERSTOOD THAT THE
STRESS AND THE LACK OF ME BEING
ABLE TO GET SERVICES I MEAN
PROVIDE GET MY SERVICES THAT.
ALLOW ME TO GO TO DOCTORS AND
NOT SHOW UP WITH ALL THESE.
YOU KNOW KIDS.
SHOW THAT HE TOOK IT TO THE NEXT
LEVEL AND EVEN TALK TO THE STATE.
COMPLAINT PEOPLE THAT I DID THE
THE PILL FOR AND FORESEES STILL
TO THIS DAY REQUIRES SPECIFIC
DOCUMENTATION COLETTE IS STILL
IN.
FORESEE SHE'S JUST DEMOTED FROM
HER POSITION AND FOUND ANOTHER
FANCY TITLE --
AYE KEEN.
BECAUSE THEY REALIZE IT FORESEES
AGENTS FOR ME IS NOT LETTING ME --
THEY'RE JUST BLOWING ME IN MY
FAMILY --
THEY TRIED TO TO TERMINATE ME
MANY MANY TIMES --
AND LIKE I SAID MY DOCTORS HAVE
TRIED TO HELP ME OUT BUT IT'S
NEVER GOOD ENOUGH THEY WANT
SPECIFICS AND I'M NOT GOING TO
RELEASE SPECIFIC IN DEMEANOR.
MY OWN PERSONAL HEALTH TO SUIT
THE FANCY PEOPLE SITTING HERE.
I'M.
I TRY TO DETERMINE MY CHILD CARE
AND STOPPING --
MIGHT DAYS THEY'D STOP PAY MY
PROVIDER THAT WAS A EXAM
PROVIDER AND DIDN'T PAY HIM FOR
CLOSE TO ALMOST A YEAR.
OF THE ONLY PAY THEM A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AND WHICH IN THAT FACT HE HAD
LOST HIS [inaudible]
ME ANYMORE.
BECAUSE HE WAS TRYING SPECIFIC
FOR MY SON WITH ME MEDICAL
DISABILITIES AN EPILEPTIC
[inaudible]
I'M.
I GUESS THAT WAS THE COMPASSION
THAT HE COULDN'T JUST STOP
[inaudible]
WATCHING ESPECIALLY.
THE ONE I HAD A LOT OF
CONDITIONS BECAUSE HE KNEW THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
I'M AND WITH HOPES THAT.
THEY WITH THEY WERE GOING TO PAY
HIM AND THEY WOULD ALWAYS COME
UP WITH DIFFERENT REASONS OF WHY
NOT -- I
HAVE AN OPEN CONTRACT WITH
FORESEES RIGHT NOW THROUGH THE
YMCA THAT.
FORESEES ONLY MANDATED ME TO
PICK THE YMCA.
I'M WHICH LIKE I SAID I CAN'T
USE FOR MY TWO CHILDREN BECAUSE
THE OTHER ONE ALSO HAS A
DISABILITY BUT NOT AS CHRONIC AS
MY EPILEPTIC SON.
AND AS YOU KNOW COURSES
TURNOVERS ARE BIG AND MY SON
REQUIRES STAY STATEN WHICH IS AN
EMERGENCY ONE BECAUSE HE GOES ON
CONSCIENCE WITH THOSE OF
EPILEPSY.
AND IT'S TIME CENSORED SO YOU
HAVE TO BE TRAINED AND IF
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT GOES ON
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT TRAINED
WHICH IS WHY I NEED AN EXACT
PROVIDER.
IN HOME BECAUSE THINGS THE WHEN
HE FALLS HE FALLS WE DON'T KNOW
HE'S LIKE ASAN ANDREAS.
CRACK THEIR AND FOUR SEASONS NO
COMPASSION NO EMPATHY THE VERY
CALLOUS TO MY NEEDS AND I DON'T
HAVE THE FIFTY BUCKS THAT IT
REQUIRES TO PAY THE KOBE.
OF OF THE YMCA BECAUSE IT ONLY
COVERS SO MUCH NOR DID I HAVE
THE MONEY IT REQUIRED FOR LIKE A
FAMILY FOR YEARS SOME KIND OF
FEE THAT DOESN'T GET COVERED
UNDER LIKE A SUBSIDIZED.
I REQUEST FOR A GRANT OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT SCHOLARSHIP
I BELIEVE IS WHAT IT WAS CALLED.
AND EVEN AT MY SON'S SCHOOL THE
TEACHERS THE AIDS TO KEEP AN EYE
ON HIM IT'S IMPOSSIBLE I MEAN
HE'S BROKEN IS WRIST HE'S GONE
UNCONSCIOUS HE'S HAD SO MANY
OTHER PROBLEMS.
THAT THEY'VE STARTED TO PROVIDE
HIM WITH THE ONE ON ONE NEEDS
FOR LUNCHEON RECESS.
AND FORESEES DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
OR TAKE ANY OF THIS IN
CONSIDERATION.
I'M SO MY REQUEST WOULD BE TO
HAVE THEM.
TRAINED IN THE HIPAA LAWS
THROUGH THE FED.
AND ALSO --
I ALSO WANT TO RAISE THE CONCERN
THAT WE HEARD.
THERE PEOPLE SEE A AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
DIDN'T FIND ANY OF THEM
DEFICIENCIES THEM SOUTH PROBABLY
PROBLEMS DO NOT JUST HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT.
IT REALLY MAKES ME WONDER AM.
ABOUT THE QUALITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S HOW
THE OVERSIGHT EVERY OVERSEE
EVERYTHING AND IT DISAPPOINTMENT.
DISAPPOINTS ME THAT THEY DON'T
SEE ANYTHING WRONG WITH WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND NOT FINING
FINDINGS AND SO MANY WRONGFUL
THINGS.
AND IT MAKES ME REALLY WONDER IF
THEY'RE DOING LIKE WHAT THE
BOARD AT FOUR SEE IN ALL OF THE
CEO THAT PEOPLE USE TO HAVE.
IS SOMEHOW MAYBE THEY'RE REAPING
SOME KIND OF MONEY OR THEY'RE
OVERWORKED THEY'RE NOT WANTING
TO FIND SOMETHING WRONG.
I AM ENCLOSING AS MY STATEMENT
THE NEW CEO WANTS TO COVER THAT
HE'S NEW BUT NOBODY GOES INTO A
POSITION WITHOUT READING AND
LEARNING THEIR FILES IN THEIR
BACK HISTORY.
SO FOR HIM TO BE HAVING SUCH A
CALLOUS AND DISREGARD TO SAY
WERE ALL YOU WERE ON YOU BOARDS
THAT'S IRRELEVANT WE CAN YOU
PRESIDENTS AND GOVERNORS IN THE
PICKUP OR ALL THE JUNK WAS LEFT
OFF.
AND I DON'T FIND I MEAN I'M NOT
EDUCATED BY ANY MEANS TO ANYBODY
IN THIS ROOM I'M PARTY ONE OF
THE LEAST.
EDUCATED PEOPLE HERE I'M HOPING
I WOULDN'T BUT I DON'T.
I DON'T SEE HOW THEIR IGNORANCE
COMES IN ALL SHADES IN ALL FORMS
BUT IGNORANCE CAN'T BE THAT.
BLIND SIDE IT'S NOT UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE AND JUST FULL.
AND I'M HUMANE THING THEY'RE
DOING WITH US JUST BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE.
THE MONEY TO GO FIGHT AGAINST
THESE KIND OF PEOPLE.
AND IF PEOPLE AGREE WITH FORTY
SEVEN HAS A DISABILITY AND
LETTING AYE GIVEN SAN JOSE THAT
I'VE BEEN STANDING UP IT'S VERY
HARD ON MY CONDITION.
I'M SURE THEY'RE LISTING THERE
AND I AM SO.
I JUST GET NERVOUS WHEN I CAN
BECAUSE THIS IS A BIG
ORGANIZATION AND I DON'T WANNA
BE DISAPPEARED FROM THE FACE OF
THE EARTH WHEN THE CAKE.
SO WHERE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT YOU WE WILL LISTEN TO WHAT
YOU SEE.
AND I APPRECIATE YOU COMING AND
I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
TO TO TALK TO US ABOUT ABOUT
YOUR ISSUES THAT PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM THAT HER.
OBVIOUSLY LISTENING AND
HOPEFULLY SOME OF THEM WERE
TAKING NOTES IN A GROUP OF
SOAKING UP THE SUN.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET WILL VERY
DISAPPOINTING AND EEN PEOPLE
THAT DON'T HAVE CHILDREN THAT
HAVE CHILDREN IT'S VERY HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO HAVE CHILDREN.
WITH MEDICAL DISABILITIES AND
APPARENT THAT THAT'S
DISABILITIES IT'S EXTREMELY HARD.
SO THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS --
WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE OVER MY
TWO MINUTES SO WHAT I WOULD ASK --
AND YEAH IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HEAR WHAT
YOU HAVE TO SAY I'D ASK YOU TO
TRY TO BE A A BIT MORE CONCISE
IF WE CAN.
AYE KNOW YOU'VE TAKEN THE TIME
TO WRITE COMMENTS AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT --
YOU CAN CERTAINLY SEND THOSE TO
US LATER AND WILL RECEIVE THOSE
BUT PLEASE GO AHEAD WHO WANTS TO
BE FREE WAS AT THE TABLE FIRST
AND FLIP A COIN ACT.
BUT MY NAME'S PYTHIA EXHORTED
READ -- A
STATEMENT FROM A FORMER EMPLOYEE
I I AM A CURRENT EMPLOYEE.
BUT THIS STATEMENT IS FROM
SOMEONE THAT WHAT THE AGENCY IN
EACH ROOM TRIED TO KEEP IT.
TO I SAID TWO MINUTES WERE
OBVIOUSLY DOUBLE OR TRIPLE THAT
BUT TRY TO KEEP IT TO I THINK
THIS -- MY
NAME IS MARIA ESPARZA AND I'M A
PARENT OF THREE WONDERFUL
CHILDREN TWO DAUGHTERS IN THE
SUN.
WE BEGAN RECEIVING CHILD CARE
SERVICES THROUGH.
FOR IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN I WAS HIRED
THROUGH A TEMP AGENCY TOWARD
PROPORCIONAR OFFICES THE ADMIN
ASSISTANT.
AS A MEMBER OF THE STAFF OF
COURSE EITHER AS PART OF A TEAM
TO HELP PROVIDE VITAL RESOURCES
GUIDANCE AND CHILD CARE FOR LOW
INCOME PARENTS SO THEY WERE IN
WHICH SELF.
SUFFICIENCY.
OF WHAT JOINT DESPITE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK WE DO FOR
THE COMMUNITY IN THE DEDICATION
OF REGULAR STAFF EMPLOYEES
FORCES HAVE VERY SERIOUS ISSUES
OF THE WORKPLACE THESE ISSUES
STARTED AT THE TOP.
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN MY FELLOW
STAFF MEMBERS AND I BEGAN
ORGANIZING UNION AT FORCE YOU
SAID JUST THE MANY PROBLEMS
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT A LOT OF
THESE PROBLEMS IN THE AUDITOR
FORCES PRACTICES.
SUCH AS PAYING CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS LEAD ENDS MISUSING
STATE FUNDS UP THE RESULTS OF
THE AUDITOR TRUE BUT WHAT THEY
DON'T TELL YOU IS HOW FORESEES
MANAGERS ALSO MEET LIFE
UNBEARABLE FOR STAFF MEMBERS
LIKE ME.
AS AN EMPLOYEE I WAS TARGETED
HER ASSN DISCRIMINATE SUPPORTER
HAS DENIED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
pLESS EXPERIENCED TAFF WERE
GIVEN.
I WAS SHOT INTO ACCUSED OF
LEAKING INFORMATION WARM I EVEN
HAVE PERSONAL BELONGINGS STOLEN
FROM MY DESK BY MANAGERS.
IRONICALLY ONE AS A DON'T FULLY.
I HAD TO LEAVE MY JOB FORESEES
BECAUSE OF HEALTH ISSUES I STILL
SUFFER FROM THE TOXIC WORK
ENVIRONMENT I'M DEALING WITH
ANXIETY DEPRESSION AND OTHER
STUFF STRESS ISSUES.
CAUSED BY HOSTILE TREATMENT FROM
FORCE THESE MANAGERS IT'S A
SEVERE THAT MY DOCTOR IS
ENCOURAGING YOU TO PROCEED
WORKERS COMPENSATION AS A RESULT.
APPARENTLY STRUGGLING TO FIND A
NEW JOB SO I CAN GET BACK TO
WORK AND PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY.
I'M HEARTBROKEN THAT EVEN AFTER
ALL OF THESE ISSUES CAN TOY
FORESEES IS STILL OUT TO KEEP
THEIR FUNDING EVEN OF THE AUDIT
SHOWS HOW THEY'VE MISUSED IT.
THIS IS MONEY THAT FAMILIES
WOULD MEET US REALLY DEPEND ON
FOR CHILD CARE TWICE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO GIVE IT AN
ORGANIZATION.
THAT NOBLE THAT KNOWS BULLIES
THE MYSTERIES FAMILIES AND
PARENTS AND MISUSES EDUCATION
MONEY OUR FAMILIES OUR
COMMUNITIES DESERVE BETTER.
AND THEN.
WEEK I CAN SOME OF THIS YEAR BUT
TO SPEAK TO SOME OF WHAT COUNSEL
SAID EARLIER [inaudible]
STAFF THE CASE MANAGERS OF THE
ONES THAT SEND OUT THE NOTICES
OF ACTION.
THE CURRENT CASE MANAGERS ALL OF
THEM THAT ARE CURRENTLY THERE
ENDS INCLUDING SOME OF
MANAGEMENT THAT.
HAVE IN THE PAST DONE THIS.
EVERYONE THIS CURRENTLY HE'S
MANAGER EXCEPT ISSUE THAT
STARTED THIS WEEK BAY FACT IT'D
NOTICES.
SO I'M NOT SURE WHO THE
REFERRING TO THAT LIKE IS ALL
GONE THAT BACKDATED NOTICES --
AND THEN.
ALSO THE INTERIM DIRECTOR
MENTIONS BOARD TRANSPARENCY.
THERE MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN UPPER
MANAGEMENT THE BORDER BUT
THERE'S NO TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN
THE BOARD AND STAFF STAFF DON'T
KNOW WHO THE BOARD MEMBERS ARE
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO GO TO
BOARD MEETINGS THEY DON'T KNOW
ONE WORD MEANINGS ARE --
AND THEN REGARDING LIKE APPEALS
IN THE AND ALWAYS. FOR THE
INTERNALLY INTERNALLY VERY
THEY'RE DONE BY THE CURRENT
COMPLIANCE DIRECTOR --
THEY'VE BEEN DONE BY HER FOR
AWHILE TOO BUT THEY'RE NOT
ENTIRELY IMPARTIAL ONE
PREVIOUSLY SHE IS LIKE.
THE HEAD OF THE DEPARTMENT.
THE INTERIM HEAD OF THE
DEPARTMENT [inaudible]
OF BEING [inaudible]
THINK THAT'LL.
SO OFTEN HAS INCREASED ITS
REALLY.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
COME AND SPEAK TO US WHO REALLY
APPRECIATED.
WE REALIZES IS NOT ALWAYS THE AN
EASY THING TO DO AND CAN
SOMEWHAT BE INTIMIDATING SETTING
SO FOR FOLKS WHO TAKE THE TIME
TO COME WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
DOING SO [inaudible]
NEXT.
ARE GOING NEXT.
HI THERE MY NAME IS ANA
RODRIGUEZ AND I AM A FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER.
I KNOW FIRST HAND HOW MUCH LOVE
DEDICATION AND HARD WORK IT
TAKES TO PROVIDE THEM POINT CARE
THAT FAMILIES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
DEPEND ON OUR PROFESSION IS ALSO
CHALLENGING.
WORKING WITH CHILDREN IS
WONDERFUL REWARDING AND
CHALLENGING.
AND STRESSFUL ALL AT ONCE.
THAT THAT PROBABLY ISN'T A
SURPRISE TO ANYONE.
BUT WHAT MANY DON'T KNOW IS HOW
DIFFICULT BEING A CHILD PROVIDER
CAN BE WHEN WE ARE FORCED TO
WORK WITH THE DYSFUNCTIONAL AND
HOW STYLE AGENCY.
SADLY WITH THE JAY THAT AUDIT
DISCOVERED ABOUT FORESEES
MISMANAGEMENT IS NOT AN UNCOMMON
STORY.
FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
ACROSS.
OUR UNION AVE FACED SIMILAR
ISSUES.
FORCES IS NOT AN EXCEPTION.
THAT IS WHY OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY ARE SO IMPORTANT
FOR CD <c.green> AND FAMILY</c>
CHILDCARE AGENCIES.
THESE PROBLEMS ARE MADE EVEN
WORSE BY THE LACK OF A
MEANINGFUL APPEALS PROCESS FOR
PARENTS AND PROVIDERS.
WHEN AGENCIES LIKE FORCED FEES
MAKE ONE SIDED DECISIONS TO
TERMINATE ACCESS TO CHILDCARE?
PARENTS OFTEN HAVE NOWHERE TO GO.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEIR CHILDREN?
WHAT AGENCIES LIKE FORESEES
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
IN ORDER FOR CALIFORNIA TO HAVE
A HEALTHY FUNCTIONING FAMILY
CHILDCARE SYSTEM WE NEED AN
EFFECTIVE APPEALS PROCESS FOR
DECISIONS BY CD <c.green> AND</c>
AGENCIES ALIKE.
WE NEED COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
RIGHTS FOR CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
SO THAT WE CAN BE STRONG
ADVOCATES. FOR THE CHILDREN WE
CARE.
FOR ANYONE WHO HAS BEEN WATCHING
THE NEWS LATELY KNOWS THE
DANGERS THAT CHILDREN FACE WHEN
THEY DON'T HAVE STRONG ADVOCATES
TO SPEAK UP FOR THEM.
AND GUARD THEIR SAFETY.
THIS AUDIT THIS AUDIT MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT CD <c.green> CAN'T BE</c>
TRUSTED TO AFFECTED EFFECTIVELY.
OVERSEE FAMILY CHILDCARE ON
THEIR OWN.
FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDERS.
MUST HAVE A VOICE.
I AM HERE TODAY AS A FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROVIDER TO TELL YOU
THAT THE RIGHT FOR US. TO
NEGOTIATE A UNION CONTRACT IS
CRUCIAL FOR FIXING OUR BROKEN
CHILDCARE SYSTEM.
IT IS HOW WE GUARANTEE THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE NOT ONLY GIVEN
EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN LIFE.
BUT ALSO TO BE PROTECTED FROM
THE DISRUPTION.
AND MISMANAGED MISMANAGEMENT OF
AGENCIES [inaudible]
LIKE FORESEES.
IT IS HOW WE IT IS HOW WE FIGHT
POVERTY THOUGHT OF RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC INJUSTICE THAT OUR
COMMUNITY SPACE.
AND SPEAK UP FOR CHILDREN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
BUT WE CAN ONLY DO THAT WHEN WE
HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE
[inaudible]
AND ON THE BOARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEN THINK
[inaudible]
NEXT SIR PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME OF THE YOU DON'T
FOLLOW FROM MAYBE NOT --
UNEMPLOYED YOU FOR FEE FOR A
FIGURE.
AND HE TOOK A BREATH OF SOME
CONFIRMED I HAVE --
BIPARTISAN MY FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
ARE DOING DIFFICULT IF I HAVE A
FEELING I'M GOING TO OUR MEN OF
USES AT THE AGE OF MUCH OF WHAT
PREFERMENT LIKE YOU WERE OFTEN.
RETALIATION FOURTH WE CANNOT
[inaudible]
A MANAGEMENT MAKING FALSE
ACCUSATIONS LIKE AND STUFF
[inaudible]
SILENT TREATMENT.
ARE WE HOLDEN REFILL FOR OF
RESOURCES ON INFORMATION
REQUIRED TO DO THE JOB
[inaudible]
HARSH CRITICISM.
SETTING UP FOR FAILURE.
DON'T TAKE IN A FEW DIFFERENT
THINGS INTO CONSIDERATION --
TENDENCIES TO PLAY OF FAVORITISM.
UNDER DON'T UP LEFT OF ARE
UNDERPAID --
CD FOR FIRMS WILL HAVE FAILED TO
LIVE AND TO US YOU ARE THINK TO
MISTER BELL ON MISTER --
ICE.
THAT.
WE WERE ABLE TO THE GET TO THESE
ARE THE FORMALWEAR AT DO IF
ALTERNATIVE BRIDGE RIVER OF DARK
TAXPAYERS MONEY HOW THE AGENCY.
OF WE SPEAK RIGHT NOW ARE HELD
THE BENEFITS.
I HAVE BEEN SUSPENDED.
SO WE HAVE NO A BENEFIT RIGHT
NOW -- YET
THEY'VE MONEY [inaudible] TO PAY
[inaudible]
EXPENSIVE ATTORNEYS.
BUT NOT IN THE FINAL BENEFITS WE
HAVE NO BENEFIT RIGHT NOW --
WE NEED LEADERSHIP WE NEED
INTEGRITY ON NOT NOT THAT THEY
WERE SHIPPED AROUND THINKING
THING.
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED AND IF WHAT
WE ARE ASKING [inaudible]
FOR LEADERSHIP [inaudible]
A WE NEED YOUR HELP TO MAKE
THESE THE TO MAKE SURE WE COME
FROM FULFILL THE MISSION OF
HELPING CHILDREN.
PERRANCE A PROVIDER.
ARE NOT FORGOTTEN ABOUT OUR
STAFF MEMBER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I KNOW RETALIATION PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS SIR
I WILL BE BRIEF.
YOU KNOW I MIGHT OF THAT BECAUSE
THE UNITED BEEN --
I WAS WITH YOU JUST TWENTY YEARS
AS A SUBSIDY.
CASE MANAGER AND I WITNESSED
MANY QUESTIONABLE.
ACTIONS BY THE PART OF
MANAGEMENT TO AND WHEN I CHOSE
TO SPEAK UP BLOW THE WHISTLE AND
PUSH FOR UNION REPRESENTATION
AYE WE SUBSEQUENTLY FIRED.
I NOW WORK FOR SEIU LOCAL FIVE
TWO WHAT DID JOE I DID NOT GET
AN EXIT REVIEW I WAS PLACED ON
PAID ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE IN
APRIL.
OUR WHEN I SPOKE UP AGAINST THE
AGAINST THE AGENCY APRIL OF WHAT
YEARS --
APRIL OF LAST YEAR [inaudible]
AND THE SO I SPOKE UP AT THE
BUSH SENATOR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ABOUT THE INJUSTICES
THAT WERE GOING ON I WAS PAID I
WAS PUT ON PAID ADMINISTRATIVE
LEAVE.
AND IN AUGUST I WAS FIRED BY
EMAIL DID YOUR INJUSTICES
INCLUDE THE BACKDATING.
NOPE BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU
SOMETHING ABOUT ACTED IT WAS
COMMON A PRACTICE AND UNDER
SUPER.
NOW ACTUALLY WITH MANAGEMENT SAW
DIRECTION THAT WE SHOULD BE
ACTED NOTICES OF ACTION BECAUSE
IT WANTED TO REMAIN COMPLIANT
WITH CD.
SO WE DID THAT. FOR ALL THOSE
THINGS AYE AYE WELL THAT WAS
PART OF THE THE PROCESS.
AND IS THE SENIOR CASE MANAGER
FORESEES AYE WITNESSES MANY
ABUSES THAT THE MAJOR ADVANTAGE
RED HAT CONDUCTED.
AT THE AGENCY NOW THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT IS VERY
THOROUGH AND I BELIEVE IT IS
ONLY THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG AND
I ALSO BELIEVE THERE ARE MANY
MORE AREAS WHERE FORESEES HAS
FAILED PARENTS.
PROVIDERS EMPLOYEES AND
TAXPAYERS AND WHAT VALENTINA
SAID WAS RIGHT THERE THE WHAT
YOU SEE RIGHT NOW AT THE FORCE
HE COUNSELED WITH REGARDS AND
MANAGEMENT IS NOT DO MANAGEMENT
THE ONLY NEW MANAGER.
IS -- JOE
MATT AROUND THE INTERIM
EXECUTIVE IT'S THE VEHICLE LET
COULDN'T WHOSE.
SO WHAT IS NOW THE COMPLIANCE
OFFICER WAS.
THE SUBSIDY PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
MANY YEARS.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD.
HAS BEEN THERE FOR DECADES.
AND ALL THEY DID WAS SHIFT
PEOPLE AROUND IN ORDER TO MAKE
IT SEEM LIKE THESE NEW
MANAGEMENT THERE REALLY ISN'T.
AND I LIKE I SAID I WILL BE
BRIEF NOT ONLY THAT THE AUDIT
POINT TO FORCE THESE
DEFICIENCIES IT ALSO ADDRESSES
THOSE OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO MONITOR
WHAT THE CONTRACT AS OPPOSED TO
BE DOING.
IDEA I GET A HOLD OF EIGHTY
EIGHT CONTRACT DOT CASES ARE
FILES OF CONTRACTED AGENCY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT HE IS
HE AYE YOU REQUESTED.
I HAVE BEEN GOING THROUGH THEM
OVER AND OVER LOOKING AT THEM.
AND WHAT I FOUND THAT THE IS
THAT THERE SEEMS TO BE A PATTERN.
A LOT OF THOSE --
EIGHTY EIGHT THERE WERE VERY FEW
THAT WERE BASICALLY TERMINATED
IN ONLY ONE INSTANCE OF THAT CD
IMMEDIATELY TERMINATE A
CONTRACTING AGENCY THAT'S
BECAUSE THE VIOLATED.
HALF OF THE THIRTEEN HER REASONS
FOR IMMEDIATE TERMINATION.
THE OTHER ONES SEEM TO BE ON A
DEFAULT MODE THAT THE THAT THE
CITY USES WHICH IS. TO BASICALLY
BUT I'M BY NO OFFER OF A
CONTINUED FUND THE THEN THE GOTO
PANEL REVIEW THE BATTERY OF YOU
THEY SENT THOUGH THERE WERE
CHANGE STORE SAID.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA PUT
UNCONDITIONAL STATUS THEN THEY
PUT AMONG CONDITIONAL STATUS AND
THEN THE CYCLE GOES AND THEN AT
THE END WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING AT
THEM AND THEY SAY WELL DID YOU
DO IF WE TOLD YOU TO DO AND THEY
LOOK AT THE ADDENDUM.
THAT IS WHY YOU THINK QUITE TO
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT YOU YOU
SUPPOSED TO DO BUT YOU DID SOME
OF THEM.
SO GUESS WHAT WE TO PUT ON
ANOTHER CONDITIONAL [inaudible]
CONTRACT STATUS.
AND THEN THEY GO BUT LOOK AT IT
AGAIN AND THEN THEY COME BACK
AND ACCORDING TO THE SPOT THAT
WAS LOOKING AT AND THEY SAY WELL
YOU KNOW YOU GET THAT SOME OF
THEM BUT WE FOUND SOME OTHER
ONES SO WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
ANOTHER CHANCE.
PUT YOU ON THERE WERE SOME THERE
WERE LIKE SIX YEARS INTO
CONDITIONAL CONTRACT STATUS AND
SOME OF THESE AGENCIES OWED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. TO THE CD
<c.green>.</c>
IT'S STILL THE CONTINUE TO BE
UNCONDITIONAL CONTRACT STATUS.
SO WE SHOULD NOT BE SURPRISED
THAT THE CD HAS OPTED TO PLACE
FORCES ON A CONDITIONAL
CONTRACTS THAT IS NOW OR FOR
MANY YEARS TO COME.
OF THE RESEARCH INDICATES THAT
FORESEES SHOWS THE MOST IF IT'S
SO THE MOST MINIMAL INDICATION
OF EFFORT.
THE CD WILL PLACE IT ON ANOTHER
CONDITIONALS THAT FOR THAT NOT
THE NEXT YEAR THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR FOR FOR ALL OTHER READ
THESE REASONS WE BELIEVE THAT
NOT ONLY --
FORESEES BUT ALSO THIS CD MUST
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THE
RESPONSIBLE USE OF TAXPAYER
FUNDS AND THE PROVISION OF
QUALITY SERVICES TO THE CHILDREN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT SIR MANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT.
COLOR ANY CLOSING REMARKS.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR YOUR ATTENTIVENESS I'M
THIS MORNING AS YOU INDICATED.
MYSELF AND SENATOR ABOUT.
EVEN OUR JURISDICTION UMMM YOU
KNOW THAT THIS IS A KEEN
INTEREST US BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
FOR ALSO INTERESTED COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
FOR THEIR INTEREST --
AND I YOU KNOW LOOK.
THIS THIS AUDIT WAS VERY
INFORMATIVE <c.green> DID AGAIN --</c>
CONFIRM SOME.
SUSPICIONS AND AND THINGS ARE
BEING TOLD US CERTAINLY TO
MYSELF AND SENATOR ABOUT.
I DO ALSO THINK THAT IT EXPOSES
AND THERE IN MY OPINION.
OF THE OPPORTUNITY FOR OF A
BETTER OVERSIGHT BY CITY I I
THINK THAT WE CAN'T ALLOW --
AND THIS TO BEGIN TO DEBATE TO
HAPPEN TO BE CONTAINED HAPPENED
AND AT THIS CONDITIONAL STATUS
YOU KNOW BUT IS THAT.
HOW TO BE HAVE OUTCOME FROM
CONDITIONAL STATUS THAT MAKES
SENSE GOING FORWARD THAT
ACTUALLY HAS ACCOUNTABILITY
ATTACHED TO AND?
I IMAGINE I THINK TO MYSELF
CENTER BELL WILL BE DISCUSSING
MONTHS OURSELVES --
BUT HADN'T THEY WITH THEIR SIDE
OF THE APPEAL PROCESS OR OTHER
AREAS WHERE SEE VERY APPEALS OF
IT MAY BE ADEQUATE OF YOU MAY
HAVE A DIVERSE OPINION AND AND
AND ME M. --
BRING SOMETHING FORWARD IN THAT
REGARD --
AND THE LASTING ALL SAY --
AS I THE HEARING SIDE STEPPED
OUT OF A WATCH THE VIDEO FOR
THEIR AT THE PORTIONS I STEPPED
OUT.
OF THEM IS THAT YOU KNOW SPECIAL
ON A DAY LIKE TODAY OR SUPREME
COURT JUST STRUCK A MAJOR BLOW --
TO WORKERS --
IT'S ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCE THAT'S AT
THAT THERE'S THAT.
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCE THAT IS
RETALIATION AGAINST WORKERS THAT
WORKERS CAN'T FEEL FREE TO COME
FORWARD --
IT'S A COMMON REFRAIN THAT.
HAS BEEN HEARD FOR YEARS NOW.
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT ONLY
UNACCEPTABLE.
WITH ANY.
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS A CULTURE
OF INTEGRITY.
ALBUM BUT IT'S ILLEGAL.
AND AND IF THAT PATTERN.
IS SHOWN TO HAVE CONTINUED IT'S
A MAJOR PROBLEM AND SO --
IN HIGH WILL.
NO IT'S ALWAYS ALLOW FOLKS
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE TO BE
BETTER TO GET BETTER --
THAT THAT'S PART OF OF OF BEING
RESPONSIBLE IN A POSITION OF
LEADERSHIP IS TO ALLOW FOR THAT
TO HAPPEN.
BUT IT HAS TO BE SINCERE AND HAS
BEEN DONE.
CLEARLY TRANSPARENTLY --
WITH EMPOWERMENT OF EVERYBODY
INVOLVED INCLUDING THE WORKERS
INCLUDING THE FAMILIES A DAY
NEED TO BE EMPOWERED TO THIS
PROCESS I HAVEN'T.
HEARD ANY SPECIFIC ACTIONS THAT
WERE TAKEN AT OF ACTUALLY
EMPOWERED THOSE THAT HAVE
SUFFERED THE MOST.
AND SO THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
MISTER CHAIR ONCE AGAIN --
I APPRECIATE THE AUDITOR'S FOR
THEIR WONDERFUL WORK AND YOU'LL
BE CERTAIN DE TO HEAR MORE.
OF FROM US IN THE FUTURE THANK
YOU.
WELL ON BEHALF OF MY CHAIR I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR THE
VERY VERY INFORMATIVE --
DISCUSSION TODAY.
I COME TO THIS SORT OF NEW TO
THE PROCESS MY COLLEAGUE AT THE
PROCESS BUT THE ISSUE MY
COLLEAGUES ARE CERTAINLY MUCH
MORE FAMILIAR WITH IT THAN I AM
AS EVIDENCED BY THE NATURE OF
THEIR QUESTIONS.
OF THAT I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT -- THIS
ISSUE OF THE APPLICATION OF
STATES FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDS
HERE IS IS FAIRLY IMPORTANT AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
THAT THESE FUNDS ARE USED AS
INTENDED THEN THAT IS TO PROVIDE
LOW INCOME FAMILIES WITH SAFE
AND HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT FOR
EDUCATION AND CHILD CARE.
AND MORE PARTICULARLY THAT WITH
RESPECT TO THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT MANAGE THESE FUNDS.
THAT IN THOSE ORGANIZATIONS WE
INSTILL A CULTURE [inaudible]
OF WHERE.
INTEGRITY IS VALUED AND IN FACT
IS PLACED AT THE TOP OF THE LIST.
OF THE CORE VALUES OF THE
ORGANIZATION --
WITH REGARD TO THIS BACKDATING
WHICH YOU CAN TELL US FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE TO ME.
A IN GENERAL AND IN SPECIFIC AS
IT PERTAINS TO THIS PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATION IN THE AUDIT WE
SORT OF DANCED AROUND THE ISSUE
A BIT WHICH IS UNUSUAL FOR ME IN
AN OVERSIGHT [inaudible]
HEARING.
WE DIDN'T SERVE.
GO INTO THE INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION THAT THE
ORGANIZATION I HOPE CONDUCTED
AND DOCUMENTED.
WE DIDN'T DISCUSS THE PERSONS IN
THE POSITIONS INVOLVED IN SO.
PACIFIC WE ISCUSS PERSONS IN
POSITIONS INVOLVED.
IN THE BACK DATING WE DIDN'T
DISCUSS PARTICULAR DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS --
TAKEN IN THESE CASES WHICH I
HOPE WERE TAKEN AND I HOPE WERE
DOCUMENTED IN.
APPROPRIATE EMPLOYEE PERSONNEL
FILES WE DID ATTEMPT TO DIG DOWN
VERIFY THAT THE PERSONS WHO WERE
INVOLVED IN THE BACKDATING.
I ACTUALLY HAVE DEPARTED THE
ORGANIZATION HOPEFULLY AND IN
SOME SORT OF DEFINITIVE WAY.
AS HAS BEEN ALLEGED DID NOT
OCCUR -- SO.
I CAN ONLY SAY THOSE ISSUES AND
I JUST HIGHLIGHTED.
IT'S CERTAINLY BE OF INTEREST TO
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THIS
ORGANIZATION AND THE NEW INTERIM
CEO AND FRANKLY SHOULD BE OF
INTEREST TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AS YOU CONDUCT YOUR
OVERSIGHT AND MONITORING.
EFFORTS OF THIS ORGANIZATION.
SO HAVING SAID ALL THAT I GUESS
IF WE COME BACK TO THIS ISSUE IN
THE FUTURE AND IF I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF ASSUMING THE ROLE
OF MY CHAIR AND OVERSIGHT
HEARING YOU CAN PROBABLY
ANTICIPATES A MORE DETAILED
QUESTIONS ON THE SUBJECTS THAT I
JUST MENTIONED.
HAVING SAID ALL THAT I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES.
FOR HELPING ME WITH THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARING OUT
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO THANK OUR
ABSOLUTELY OUTSTANDING.
A CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR INNER
STAFF FOR THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
THEY HAVE MADE TO THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARING THIS AUDIT AND IN
GENERAL TO THE OPERATION OF OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM OF THE
FOURTH SEASON THE PROBATIVE
EDUCATION.
FOR PARTICIPATING IN THANK YOU
SPECIFICALLY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR THE OUTSTANDING
WORK THAT YOU DO.
EACH AND EVERY DAY FOR ALL OF US.
SO HAVING SAID ALL THAT IF
THERE'S NOTHING FURTHER THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARING IS NOW
ADJOURNED AT TWELVE NOON
STRAIGHT UP [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NO PROBS MICHELLE.
A LITTLE BIT OUT OF MY ELEMENT
YEAH BUT THANK YOU IT IS A VERY
BUSY TIME.
I THINK THE TIMING SHIFT AND
VOEPEL AND NOT UNDERSTOOD IT
[inaudible]
NOW RULES.
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU DO.
SEE AN EXTRA [inaudible]
NO PROBLEM